PLEASE FOR GOING TO GET STARTED
WITH OUR WITH OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING TODAY
. THANK YOU
EVERYBODY- WELCOME GOOD
MORNING- THIS IS- THE STATE
SENATE. ENERGY UTILITIES AND
COMMUNICATIONS COMMITTEE
WELCOME EVERYBODY- THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF A HEARING THAT
WE HAD IN NOVEMBER IT IN
RESPONSE TO INCIDENTS- IN
OCTOBER OF LAST YEAR- IN WHICH-
THREE OF THE LARGEST- STATE.
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITIES A SHUT
OFF ELECTRICITY- AND POWER TO
MILLIONS OF CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE MAJORITY OF
WHICH WERE IN THE ERA SERVICE
AREA OF PGA ANY. IN ADDITION TO
LOSING ELECTRICITY MANY
CALIFORNIANS ALSO LOST
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
DURING THE POWERSHOT OFFICE FOR
CALIFORNIANS. IN THE EVACUATION
ZONE OF THE- CAM K<c.cyan> FIRES</c>
SPECIFICALLY THE LOSS OF THESE
SERVICES MAY HAVE LIMITED THEIR
ABILITY TO RECEIVE EMERGENCY
WARNINGS ABOUT THE FIRE AND
EVACUATION ROUTES PHONE AND
INTERNET OUTAGES WERE NOT
CONFIRMED WERE NOT CONFINED TO
AREAS WHERE POWER WAS SHUT OFF.
EVEN IN SITUATIONS WHERE
CALIFORNIA'S CALIFORNIANS WERE
PREPARED TO LOSE POWER MANY
CONSUMERS WERE UNPREPARED TO
LOSE PHONE AND INTERNET
SERVICES. POWER SHOPS ARE NOT
THE ONLY CAUSE OF
TELECOMMUNICATION OUTAGES A
NUMBER OF FACTORS INCLUDING
ACCIDENTS COMPUTER FAILURES AND
POORLY MAINTAINED
INFRASTRUCTURE ALSO CAUSED
OUTAGES. TELECOMMUNICATIONS
OUTAGES ARE NOT NEW BUT RECENT
PHONE AND INTERNET OUTAGES HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH LOSING THESE
ESSENTIAL SERVICES ESPECIALLY
DURING TIMES OF URGENT NEED
THIS HEARING IS INTENDED TO
CONTINUE TO EXPLORE THE CAUSES
OF TELECOMMUNICATION OUTAGES.
THE LESSONS THAT WERE LEARNED
FROM THE RECENT OUTRAGEOUS AND
WHAT WE CAN DO TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE A RELIABLE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AT WORK.
TODAY'S HEARING IS AGAIN A
CONTINUATION OF WHAT WE STARTED
IN NOVEMBER BUT SPECIFICALLY
WILL BE LOOKING MORE. INTO THE
TELECOMMUNICATION ASPECT OF
THIS INCIDENT. THIS HEARING IS
AS SCHEDULED- TO LAST
APPROXIMATELY THREE HOURS WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE HAVE A
PRETTY PACKED AGENDA. SO WHERE
WE'RE GONNA ASK- MEMBERS TO
REALLY FOCUS ON ON WHAT. AREAS
THEY WOULD LIKE TO- DEALT AND
FURTHER IN THE IN THE. WITH
WITH WITH HOPE THAT WE CAN
REALLY AT A HIGHLIGHT THE MOST
IMPORTANT AREAS THAT ARE OF
CONCERN TO NOT ONLY US BUT OF
THE PUBLIC. WE HAVE TRIED TO DO
OUR BEST OF COURSE YOU KNOW THE
THREE HOUR HEARING INCLUDES
QUITE A BIT OF TESTIMONY AND WE
TRY TO DO OUR BEST TO INCLUDE.
A VERY DIVERSE GROUP OF VOICES
AND REPRESENTATION FOR THOSE
AFFECTED. AND IN MANY CASES
WILL- THIS WILL BE THE VERY
FIRST TIME THIS COMMITTEE. HAS
BE HEARING FROM THE TECH
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
DIRECTLY FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME. WE KNOW. THAT THIS-
HEARING WILL NOT COVER. EVERY
SINGLE ISSUE OF COURSE- THERE
THERE'S QUITE A BIT THE PEOPLE
LIKE TO HEAR FROM BUT- WE WILL
BE- TAKE TAKING A LOT OF THOSE
ISSUES THAT ARE NOT ONLY NOT
HER TUTOR BUT REYES TODAY ES.
INTO CONSIDERATION IN IN FUTURE
HEARINGS AND FUTURE OF MATTERS
THAT WE MAY HAVE. WHAT THE SAID
I WANT TO WELCOME OUR FIRST
PANELIST FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. WE
HAVE. HELEN WE HAVE. SORRY
ABOUT THAT. WE HAVE HELL IN MY
COULD MAKE WHICH IS- ASSISTANT
GENERAL COUNSEL WE HAVE CLICK
CLIFF. WRECK WRECKED CHAFFIN IT
LOSES THE COMMISSIONER AND WE
HAVE MARIBEL BADGER THE
PRESIDENT FOR THE PC WELCOME
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. SO
SORRY ABOUT THAT AFTER MY
CONFERENCE. I'M FIRST CELL I
WILL START MORNING KEREN WEST
SO. AND SENATORS AND THANK YOU
FOR INVITING ME HERE TO SPEAK
TODAY MY NAME IS HELEN
MISCARRIAGE I'M AN ASSISTANT
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION WHERE I HAVE WORKED
FOR THIRTY THREE YEARS. MOSTLY
IN THE AREA OF COMMUNICATIONS
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO SET THE
COMMUNICATION STAGE FOR YOU
TODAY. NOT THAT LONG AGO
CONSUMERS HAD TRADITIONAL VOICE
SERVICE PROVIDED OVER LAND
LINES MY EIGHTEEN T. WHICH
LATER BECAME. RATHER PACIFIC
BELL OFFICIALLY BECAME EIGHTEEN
T. AND GT CALIFORNIA WHICH
LATER BECAME VERIZON AND A HOST
OF SMALLER TELEPHONE COMPANIES
ALSO PROVIDED THE SERVICE.
MOBILE SERVICE WAS THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND VOICE OVER
INTERNET PROTOCOL WHICH ALLOWS
A USER TO MAKE VOICE CALLS
USING A BROADBAND INTERNET
CONNECTION DID NOT EVEN EXIST.
THE LANDSCAPE TODAY IS
DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT. WHILE
MANY CUSTOMERS STILL HAVE
TRADITIONAL PHONE SERVICE IN
CALIFORNIA V. O. I. P. HAS
BECOME THE DOMINANT WIRELINE
SERVICE IN MILLIONS OF
CUSTOMERS HAD OPTED FOR
WIRELESS. TEN YEARS AGO THE FCC
ADOPTED A NATIONAL BROADBAND
PLAN. WHICH ENVISIONED
TRANSITIONING THE NATION'S
ENTIRE COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK
TWO ONE IT IS INTERNET BASED.
THAT TRANSITION DRIVEN BY
CHANGES IN TECHNOLOGY WHICH
WERE ALREADY UNDER WAY. HAS
CREATED ARTIFICIAL DISTINCTIONS
AND HOW WE REGULATE DIFFERENT
SERVICES AND TECHNOLOGIES. TO
GIVE YOU SOME BASICS
TELECOMMUNICATIONS MEANS SIMPLY
THE TRANSMISSION OF INFORMATION
FROM ONE POINT TO ANOTHER.
HISTORICALLY THE CPUC HAS
REGULATED VOICE AND DATA
SERVICES BECAUSE BOTH INVOLVED
TRANSMITTING INFORMATION FROM
ONE CUSTOMER TO ANOTHER. THE
NETWORK USED TO TRANSMIT THIS
INFORMATION IS MADE UP OF FIBER
OPTIC LINES COPPER WIRE REMOTE
TERMINALS BACK CALL TRUNKS
GENERATORS AND OTHER EQUIPMENT
THAT WE REFER TO AS FACILITIES.
OVER TIME YOU SERVICES WERE
DEVELOPED IN THOSE TO USE THE
SAME FACILITIES FOR EXAMPLE
VOIP SERVICE AND BROADBAND
SERVICE CAN BE PROVIDED OVER
THE COPPER WIRES THAT MADE UP
THE ORIGINAL VOICE TELEPHONE
NETWORK. CONVERSELY TRADITIONAL
TELEPHONE SERVICE CAN BE
PROVIDED OVER FIBER OPTIC
LINES. FURTHER EXCEPT FOR THE
PORTION TRANSMISSION FROM A
CELL TOWER TO YOUR MOBILE PHONE
WIRELESS SERVICE ALSO IS
PROVIDED ON THE SAME FACILITIES
JUST WIRELESS NETWORK. WHEN WE
REFER TO A SERVICE AS A SUIT
FUTURE SERVICE FOR- ESSENTIALLY
SPACE WE SIMPLY MEAN THAT THE
PROVIDER CONTROLS ARE OPERATE
YOU QUIT MEN OVER WHICH THE
TRANSMISSION TRAVELS. TO
PROVIDE TO ME ONLY FACILITIES
OR LEASE THEM ARE THE WAY TO
PROVIDERS RESPONSIBLE FOR THOSE
FACILITIES. THE CBC'S ABILITY
TO REGULATE SPECIFIC SERVICES
IS DICTATED BY STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW AND CALIFORNIA'S
SHARES WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AUTHORITY TO
REGULATE COMMUNICATION SERVICES
AND PROVIDERS. CALIFORNIA LAW
HISTORICALLY WAS TECHNOLOGY
NEUTRAL. MEANING STATE LAWS
APPLY TO ALL SERVICES
TRANSMITTING INFORMATION OVER
COMMUNICATIONS FACILITIES
WHETHER THOSE SERVICES WERE
USING WIRES OR WIRELESS.
SECTION TWO THIRTY THREE OF THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE
SPECIFICALLY STATES THAT A
TELEPHONE LINE DEFINED IT
STATUTE INCLUDES ALL FACILITIES
AND EQUIPMENT. USED TO PROVIDE
TELEPHONE SERVICE QUOTE WITH OR
WITHOUT THE USE OF TRANSMISSION
WIRES. UNDER STATE LAW THE PC
REGULATED ALL ASPECTS OF
TRADITIONAL TELEPHONE SERVICE
AND- WIRELESS SERVICES WELL. AS
COMPETITION BEGAN ON FULL
BEGINNING IN THE NINETEEN
NINETIES THE CPC RESPONDED BY
CHANGING THE WAY IT REGULATED
TRADITIONAL PHONE SERVICE
ELIMINATING PRICE REGULATIONS
AND ALLOWING PROVIDERS REPLACE
TERRACE WITH CUSTOMER SERVICE
AGREEMENTS. IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN
FEDERAL LAW LIMITED HOW STATE'S
CAN REGULATE WIRELESS SERVICE
EVEN THOUGH CALIFORNIA LAW PUTS
WIRELESS SERVICE UNDER PC
JURISDICTION. THE LEGISLATION
CONGRESS ENACTED CONSTRAINED
STATE AUTHORITY BY PROHIBITING
STATES FROM REGULATING WIRELESS
RATES AND ENTRY INTO THE
MARKET. THAT SAME STATUE
HOWEVER RESERVE TO THE STATE TO
THIRTY TO REGULATE QUOTE OTHER
TERMS AND CONDITIONS OF
WIRELESS SERVICE. WIRELESS
SERVICE FIRST CAME ALONG IN
CALIFORNIA THE PC DEEMED
WIRELESS PROVIDERS TO BE
TELEPHONE CORPORATIONS UNDER
FEDERAL LAW JUST AS TRADITIONAL
WIRELINE COMPANIES WERE. THAT'S
UNDER SECTION TWO THIRTY FOUR
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE IN
THE PC IMPOSE ON THEM ALL THE
RIGHTS DUTIES AND OBLIGATIONS
OF OTHER CPUC LICENSEES. IN A
DECISION THE UC ISSUED
IMPLEMENTING THAT CHANGE IN
FEDERAL LAW IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE THE COMMISSION REQUIRED
WIRELESS PROVIDERS TO PAINT A
WIRELESS REGISTRATION OR WHAT
WE CALL W. LINE OUR NUMBER. IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX WATCH TO
EXPANDING COMPETITION IN THE
VIDEO MARKET THE LEGISLATURE
ENACTED THE DIGITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND VIDEO
COMPETITION ACT OR GIVE CA.
WHICH GAVE LICENSING AUTHORITY.
OVER VIDEO COMPANIES TO THE CPC
BUT AFFORDED THE COMMISSION
LITTLE OVERSIGHT OF THE SERVICE
OTHER THAN A SIMPLIFIED LICENSE
REVIEW PROCESS EACH FRANCHISE
THE COMPS CPC ISSUES UNDER
DIFFICULT FOR TEN YEARS. AND
THE RENEWAL PROCESS DOES NOT
ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO REVIEW
THE FRANCHISE SHE'S PERFORMANCE
AT ANY POINT. IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN LEGISLATURE ENACTED
SECTION. EXCUSE ME AND ACTED SB
ELEVEN SIXTY ONE WHICH PUT INTO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES CODE
SECTION SEVEN TEN. THAT
SECTIONS SEVERELY RESTRICTED
THE COMMISSION'S ABILITY TO
REGULATE VOICE OVER INTERNET
PROTOCOL SERVICE AS WELL AS IP
ENABLE SERVICES. THE STATUE DID
CONTAIN AN EXCEPTION FOR BACKUP
POWER. BUT THAT. EXCEPTION
LIMITED THE P. UC'S AUTHORITY
TO WHAT HE DID ADOPTED IN A
DECISION ISSUED IN TWO TOP TWO
THOUSAND TEN AND THAT DECISION
JUST CONCERNED PROVIDING NOTICE
TO CUSTOMERS. FINALLY A
PROTRACTED BATTLE OF TEN YEARS
THE FCC DETERMINED IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THAT
BROADBAND SERVICE SHOULD BE
EXEMPT FROM ALL STATE
REGULATION EVEN THOUGH
BROADBAND SERVICE ALSO TRAVELS
OVER THE SAME FACILITIES AS
TRADITIONAL PHONE SERVICE. AND
WIRELESS SERVICE AND PROVIDES
ESSENTIAL ACCESS TO NECESSARY
SERVICES SUCH AS NINE ONE ONE.
THE ENERGY IS ATION MAPS AND
EVACUATION INFORMATION. SEVERAL
PARTIES INCLUDING THE CPUC
CHALLENGE THE FCC'S DECISION TO
PREEMPT STATES FROM REGULATING
BROADBAND SERVICE IN FACT THE
CPC WAS THE ONLY SATE
COMMISSION. THE UNITED STATES
THAT CHALLENGE THAT DECISION.
IN A DECISION ISSUED OCTOBER
FIRST OF LAST YEAR THE DC
CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS
REVERSED THAT PART OF THE FCC'S
ORDER WHICH PREEMPTED THE
STATE'S. NONE OF THE INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE FILED
FOR THE REPEAL OF THE DC
CIRCUIT'S DECISION. IT IS STILL
UNCLEAR THAT MEANS. SECTION
SEVEN TEN HAS SUNSET AS OF
EIGHT DAYS AGO LEAVING OPEN THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PC TO
EXERCISE ITS AUTHORITY TO
ENSURE THE NINE ONE ONE
SERVICES AVAILABLE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. AND ACTUALLY
DELIVERED EVEN IN TIMES OF
DISASTERS ALTHOUGH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES HAS RESPONSIBILITY TO
IMPLEMENT THE NINE ONE ONE
SYSTEM- YES DOES NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER THE ENTITIES
TO CARRY THE NINE ONE ONE
TRAFFIC TRANSMITTING THE
EMERGENCY CALL FROM A
DISTRAUGHT CONSUMER TO THE
DISPATCH CENTER. AND BURKE FROM
THERE TO THE RELEVANT FIRST
RESPONDER. THAT AUTHORITY FALL
SQUARELY UNDER THE CPC. AS
YOU'LL HEAR FROM PRESIDENT
BASHER AND COMMISSION RUPTURE
OFTEN MANY SYSTEM FAILURES
REQUIRE THE ABILITIES OF BOTH
THE OP THE C. P. U. C. M. O.
YES TO REMEDY. SO THAT'S THAT'S
MY SETTING OF THE STAGE. THAT
DONE I WILL. COMMISSION RUSSIA
FROM WILL GO ON TO DISCUSS THE
COMMISSION EXISTING SERVICE
QUALITY RULES FOR THE PC AS
WELL AS THE RECENT NETWORK
STUDY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO CENTERS
A PLEASURE TO BE HERE. AS HELEN
MENTIONED I WILL TALK ABOUT OUR
EXISTING SERVICE QUALITY RULES
AND OUR NETWORK EXAMINATION. OR
REQUIRE TELEPHONE COMPANIES. TO
REPORT ON THREE MAIN SERVICE
QUALITY METRICS CUSTOMER
TROUBLE REPORTS CUSTOMER
SERVICE ANSWER TIME. IN THE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT CUSTOMERS
ARE OUT OF SERVICE BUT- THESE
RULES APPLY TO THE TRADITIONAL
VOICE TELEPHONE SERVICE
PROVIDED BY COMPANIES LIKE
EIGHTEEN T. TEN FRONTIER. THEY
DO NOT HOWEVER APPLY TO
WIRELESS VOICE CABLE VIDEO OR
INTERNET OUTAGES. THE OUT OF
SERVICE MEASURES VERY IMPORTANT
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT INDICATOR
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY IT MEASURES
THE ABILITY OF THE PUBLIC TO
CONTACT NINE ONE ONE. AND
EMERGENCY SERVICE SERVICES IT
REQUIRES CARRIERS TO RESTORE
90% OF SERVICE OUTAGES FOR
REGULAR THE REGULAR TELEPHONE
SERVICE WITHIN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS OR LESS ON STATEWIDE
AVERAGE THIS IS BY NO MEANS AN
IMPOSSIBLE STANDARD TO MEET.
YET THE LARGEST SERVICE
PROVIDERS ROUTINELY FAIL TO
MEET THESE REQUIREMENTS WE
DON'T HAVE DATA YET COMPLETELY
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN BUT. FOR
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN T.
STATEWIDE AVERAGE FOR SERVICE
RESTORE ILL. WITH FORTY EIGHT
PERCENT. FRONTIERS WITH SIXTY
THREE PERCENT. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN TEASE WAS 56%
AND FRONTIERS WAS 78% OF COURSE
POURS SERVICE QUALITY LIMITS
THE PUBLIC'S ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE ECONOMY. CONTACT NINE ONE
ONE. ORDER RECEIVE
COMMUNICATIONS DURING AN
EMERGENCY. PURSUANT TO A
PENALTY PROGRAM THAT WE
ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THE P. YOU SEE FIND THESE
COMPANIES FOR FAILURE TO MEET
THE SERVICE REQUIREMENTS. AS
PERMITTED BY THE PROGRAM IN
LIEU OF PAYING FINES INTO THE
GENERAL FUND. THE COMPANY'S
OPTED INSTEAD TO PAY TWICE THE
AMOUNT OF THE FINES INTO
PROJECTS THAT THE COMMISSION
MONITORS. TO IMPROVE PARTS OF
THE NETWORK THAT POOR SERVICE
QUALITY OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS
THE COMPANIES HAVE INVESTED
SIXTEEN MILLION DOLLARS. IN
SPECIFIC PARTS OF THE NETWORKS
WHICH WERE FAILING IN LIEU OF
PENALTIES. THERE ARE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT TYPES OF OUTAGES
REPORTS THAT THE SPEED YOU SEE
FCC AND CARILLO YES REQUIRE WE
DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO INTO.
DETAIL ABOUT THOSE BUT AT A
HIGH LEVEL AS I MENTIONED WE
REQUIRE REPORTING ON THESE
THREE SERVICE QUALITY REPORTS
THESE METRICS. PROVIDERS ALSO
MUST SUBMIT REPORTS TO US OF
MAJOR SERVICE OUTAGES WHEN THEY
OCCUR AND THESE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO EXTEND TO
WIRELESS INVOICE PROVIDERS OUR
SERVERS OUT IS REPORTING
REQUIREMENT IS BASED ON THE
FEDERAL COMMUNICATION STANDARDS
NETWORK OUTAGE. REPORTING
SYSTEM KNOWN AS NO WARS AND
THESE REQUIRE ALL CARRIERS TO
REPORT ON MARCH SERVICE OUTAGES
THE SPECIFIC CRITERIA VARY
DEPENDING ON THE LENGTH OF THE
OUT ITS NUMBER OF CUSTOMERS
AFFECTED. TYPE OF BUT IS IT
ACTED SO THE- STATE THE FCC
MAJOR OUTAGE REPORTING THERE'S
A THIRD REPORTING REQUIREMENT
WHICH IS VOLUNTARY IT'S KNOWN
AS THE DISASTER INFORMATION
REPORTING SYSTEM ORDERS. OF
NOTE LARA THE OCTOBER POWER PS
PS TWO ROOMS WITH THE FIRST
TIME THAT THE FCC HAD ACTIVATED
DOORS FOR CALIFORNIA. THE FCC
ACTIVATES THAT IN CONSULTATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY AND PREVIOUSLY HAD
ONLY ACTIVATED THIS FOR
HURRICANES OR LARGE STORMS. AND
THEN FINALLY CARILLO YES IS IN
THE PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING SB
SEVEN SIX SEVENTY FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH AS YOU KNOW IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE EVEN MORE
TIMELY INFORMATION TO EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS STATED PROPOSED
RULES THAT ARE OUT FOR COMMENT
DIRECTOR GIL TUCCI WILL SPEAK
TO MORE TO THIS REQUIREMENT IN
HIS TESTIMONY. SO THAT'S AN
OVERVIEW OF THE OUR EXISTING
SERVICE QUALITY RULES I WANT TO
NOW TURN TO DISCUSS OUR NETWORK
EXAM. THIS IS AN INVESTIGATION
THE P. YOU SEE ORDERED. OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NETWORKS OF
EIGHTEEN T. CALIFORNIA AND
FRONTIER THOSE ARE THE STATE'S
TWO MAJOR LAND LINE PROVIDERS
WE ORDERED AS A RESULT OF THEIR
CONSISTENT FAILURE. TO MEET
EXISTING SERVICE QUALITY
METRICS THE REPORT COVERS THE
PERIOD. TWENTY TEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. KEY FINDINGS OF THE
NETWORK EXAMPLE. WIRELINE
SERVICE QUALITY HAS STEADILY
DETERIORATED THEY'RE MORE
OUTAGES SERVICE RESTORATION
TIMES ARE GETTING LONGER. THE
NETWORKS ARE NOT ROBUST AND
RESILIENCE ARE RESILIENT. BOTH
COMPANIES HAVE CUT BACK ON
PREVENTIVE MAINTENANCE THEY'RE
NOT MAINTAINING THEIR NETWORKS
TO WITHSTAND ENVIRONMENTAL AND
WEATHER RELATED CONDITIONS. THE
RESULT IS A STRONG RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN BAD WEATHER AND SERVICE
OUTAGES AND WE SAW THIS THIS
FALL WITH THE WILD FIRES AND
THE PSP EVENTS. BOTH COMPANIES
HAVE BEEN DIS INVESTING IN
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
TRADITIONAL LANDLINE OPERATIONS
AND MOVING MONEY INTO OTHER
BUSINESS AREAS. SUCH AS
BROADBAND. EIGHTEEN T. IN
PARTICULAR HAS FOCUSED ITS
INVESTMENT ON PROVIDING SERVICE
AND HIGHER INCOME COMMUNITIES.
AS A RESULT THEIR CUSTOMERS IN
LOWER INCOME AREAS EXPERIENCE
MORE OUTAGES AND WERE SERVICE.
AND THEN FINALLY THE EXAM FOUND
THAT THERE IS A DIRECT
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE AMOUNT
OF COMPETITION IN THE AREA. AND
SERVICE QUALITY RESULTS. IS
WITH LOW COME LIMITED OR NO
COMPETITION HAVE LOWER SERVICE
QUALITY RESULTS. MEAN THAT
CUSTOMERS WHO LIKELY HAVE NO
ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF SERVICE
TYPICALLY LESS POPULATED ROTORS
AND THEREFORE RELY ON
TRADITIONAL PHONE SERVICE THE
MOST. EXPERIENCE THE WORST
SERVICE QUALITY. WE RELEASED
THE SUMMARY AND REDACTED
PORTIONS OF THE REPORT THOSE
ARE AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO RELEASING ON
REDACTED VERSIONS OF THE FULL
REPORT. HOWEVER BOTH EIGHTEEN
T. IN FRONT HERE HAVE FILED
VERY SWEEPING CONFIDENTIALLY
CONFIDENTIALITY CLAIMS ABOUT
THE REPORT AS WE ARE REQUIRED
BY LAW WE ARE GOING THROUGH
EACH AND EVERYONE OF THEM
CLAIMED BY CLAIMS. WITH AND
WE'VE BEEN DOING THAT OVER THE
PAST FEW MONTHS AND WE HOPE TO
RELEASE A LESS REDACTED VERSION.
SOON SO NEXT STEPS. GOING
FORWARD WE'RE GONNA BE LOOKING
CLOSELY AT THE ISSUES
HIGHLIGHTED. BY THE EXAM
INCLUDING THE ADEQUACY OF OUR
CURRENT SERVICE QUALITY
METRICS. AND EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE CURRENT PENALTY MECHANISMS.
WILL ALSO CONSIDER WHAT SERVICE
QUALITY ISSUES EXIST FOR OTHER
TYPES OF COMMUNICATION SERVICES.
I'D LIKE TO NOTE FINALLY THAT
SOME OF THE IN THE IT IT IN
EQUITIES IDENTIFIED IN THE
NETWORK EXAM FOR TRADITIONAL
PHONE SERVICE. ARE BEING FOUND
IN OTHER. TYPES OF SERVICE
BROADBAND AND OTHER SERVICES AS
WELL. MANY OF YOU MAY BE
FAMILIAR WITH A RECENT STUDY BY
THE U. S. C. INDICATING THAT IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. COMPETITION
AND THE FASTEST BROADBAND
SERVICES ARE LESS LIKELY TO
OCCUR IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. THESE
FINDINGS ARE TROUBLING.
CONSISTENT WITH OUR STATUTORY
MANDATES WE WILL CONTINUE WITH
OUR INVESTIGATIONS ON OUR WORK
TO ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE FAIR ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
SERVICES. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I'LL TURN TO PRESIDENT
PATCHER. THANK YOU CLOSE. I AM
FIGHTING OFF THAT COLD THAT HAS
MADE THE ROUNDS PLEASE FORGIVE
ME FOR MY VOICE THANK YOU A
TEAR HUESO AND SENATORS- FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY- MY NAME
IS MERRY BILL BADGERING I'M
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
THIS PAST OCTOBER CALIFORNIA
SUFFERED THROUGH MULTIPLE WILD
FIRES AND THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF. IN IN SKEWS ME
THE PS PS THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT UP EVENTS THAT
IMPACTED COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS THESE PS PST VANS IN
PARTICULAR RESULTED IN MAJOR
IMPACTS TO THE COMMUNICATIONS
GRID. CUSTOMERS OF ALL SERVICES
WERE IMPACTED WITH THEIR LAN
LINE CABLE THE- I. P. OR
WIRELESS CARRIERS REPORTED
OUTAGES FOR NEAR HALF A MILLION
WIRELINE CUSTOMERS AND ALMOST A
MILLION WIRELESS CUSTOMERS.
HUNDREDS OF CELL SITES WERE OUT
OF SERVICE FOR VARIOUS LENGTHS
OF TIME AND WHY WIRELINE
FACILITIES ALSO SUFFERED IN.
PARTICULARLY THE CABLE
PROVIDERS FOR EXAMPLE MARIN
COUNTY AND I THINK THIS IS
NOTED IN YOUR- STAFF ANALYSIS
AS WELL MARIN COUNTY HAD 57% OF
ITS TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
CELLULAR TOWERS OUT OF SERVICE
AT ONE TIME DURING THE PSP YES.
ON OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTH I JUST
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THAT THE
PERCENTAGES DON'T WELL
REPRESENT MANY THOUSANDS AND IN
SOME CASES MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
IMPACTED. IN THE BAY AREA
SENATE DOWNEY AND CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY THERE WERE 11% OF CELL
TOWERS FAILED TO WORK ACCORDING
TO THE REPORTS FROM THE FCC.
CINEMA LAKE HUMBOLDT SANTA CRUZ
AND CALAVERAS COUNTIES HAD DAYS
WHERE OVER 20% OF THE CELL
TOWERS WERE OUT. LACK OF
COMMUNICATION SERVICE IS NOT A
MERE INCONVENIENCE IT ENDANGERS
LIVES. CALIFORNIANS RELY ON
THEIR PHONES AND THE INTERNET
WHETHER WIRED OR WIRELESS TO
RECEIVE EMERGENCY NOTIFICATIONS
TO CONTACT FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
AND TO REACH FIRST RESPONDERS
SKEWS ME. THESE OUTAGES WERE
UNEXPECTED GIVEN THE PREVIOUS
ASSURANCES THAT THE
COMMUNICATIONS COMPANY PROVIDED
TO THE FCC TO YOU THE LATE
LEGISLATURE AND TO WE THE CPUC
THESE COMPANIES HAVE THE
OBLIGATION AS WELL AS THE
PRIVILEGE AND RESPONSIBILITY TO
PROVIDE SERVICE TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS THESE OUTAGES WERE
UNACCEPTABLE. THE CPUC IS
CLOSELY WORKING CLOSELY WITH
CAL YES AND CAL FIRE TO ENSURE
THAT THE COMMUNICATIONS
CUSTOMERS ARE ABLE TO ACCESS
THESE SERVICES AT ALL TIMES
DURING AN EMERGENCY. OUR
AGENCIES HAVE DIFFERENT ROLES
BUT COLLECTIVELY WE SERVE TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC SAFETY. CAL
YES AND CAL FIRE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR SITUATION
MANAGEMENT AND NEEDS SPECIFIC
AND ACTIONABLE INFORMATION
IMMEDIATELY. THE CPUC HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO DEVELOP RULES
TO ENSURE SAFE AND RELIABLE
SERVICE. THE CPUC IS WORKING TO
ENSURE EMERGENCY RESPONDERS
HAVE THE INFORMATION NECESSARY
TO DO THEIR JOB AND THAT WE
HAVE THE RULES IN PLACE TO HOLD
SERVIE PROVIDERS ACCOUNTABLE.
DURING THE PS PS EVENTS I WAS
AT THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
AND I SAW FIRST HAND HOW MUCH
IMPROVEMENT IS INDEED NEEDED.
PRIOR TO THE INTERVENTION FROM
CAL O. E. S. DIRECTOR MARK
KILLER DUTY THE ROOM FOR THE
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDER WAS
PROVIDERS WAS NEARLY EMPTY. THE
ENGAGEMENT AND THE DELIVERY OF
REAL TIME INFORMATION DURING
THIS CRITICAL PERIOD WAS SIMPLY
NON EXISTENT CLEARLY THE
EXISTING VOLUNTARY SYSTEM WHICH
WAS MENTIONED BY HELEN. AND S.
EARLIER IS NOT WORKING WE HAVE
SEEN THAT COMMUNICATION
CARRIERS REPORTING MUST BE
IMPROVED MUST BE MORE RELIABLE.
AND READILY AVAILABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC AND
THE COMPANIES THEMSELVES MUST
IMPROVE SITUATIONAL
COMMUNICATIONS. I AM THE
ASSIGNED COMMISSIONER ON THE
EMERGENCY DISASTER RELIEF
MEASURES AB PROCEEDING THIS
PROCEEDING SEEKS TO IMPROVE
DISASTER RESPONSE AND CREATE A
UNIFORM FRAMEWORK FOR ALL THE
UTILITIES UNDER THE
COMMISSION'S JURISDICTION. AS
PART OF THIS PROCEEDING I SENT
A LETTER ON NOVEMBER THIRTEENTH
TO THE LARGEST COMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA
REGARDING THEIR PERFORMANCE
DURING THE OCTOBER PS PS EVENTS.
I YES THE COMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO REPORT THE AMOUNT
OF BACKUP POWER CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE AVAILABLE TO PINPOINT
LOCATIONS IN THEIR NETWORKS
THAT REQUIRE HARDENING FOR
WILDFIRE AND PS PSP EVENTS. AND
I CALLED A PUBLIC MEETING TO
HEAR RESPONSES FROM THE COMPANY
EXECUTIVES. ON NOVEMBER
EIGHTEENTH MAJOR WIRELESS
WIRELINE AND CABLE PROVIDERS OF
VOICE SERVICES RESPONDED WITH
THE AMOUNT OF BACKUP POWER
THEIR FACILITIES HAVE AND THE
PLANS IN WHICH FOR REFUELING IT
PLANS IN PLACE FOR RE FUELING
THE GENERATORS. IN ADDITION WE
OBTAIN DATA ON THE NUMBER OF
CELL SITES. LOCATED IN TIER TWO
AND TIER THREE FIRE THREAT
AREAS AS WELL AS THE AMOUNT AND
TYPE OF BACKUP POWER AT THESE
LOCATIONS. COLLECTIVELY THE
DATA ILLUSTRATES THE CURRENT
CONDITION OF RESILIENCY OF OUR
COMMUNICATIONS GRET. THIS
INFORMATION WILL BE USED TO
INFORM AND GUIDE THE POLICY
THAT STRENGTHENS OUR
COMMUNICATIONS GRID PREPARES IT
TO WITHSTAND DISASTERS AND
INSURERS IT WILL REMAIN
OPERATIONAL DURING PS PS EVENTS
AND DISASTERS. THE HEARING ON
NOVEMBER TWENTIETH WAS
SPECIFICALLY HELD TO ADDRESS
FAILURES IN THE COMMUNICATION
NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE DURING
THE FIRES AND THE PS PS EVENTS
I MADE IT VERY CLEAR. THAT
THEIR FAILURES WERE NOT
ACCEPTABLE I HIGHLIGHTED THE
COMMUNICATION ISSUES WIH THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND THE NEED
FOR STANDARDS FOR BACKUP POWER
AND PUBLIC OUTAGE. REPORTING AT
THE HEARING CARRIERS INFORMED
ME THAT THEY HAD ADVANCED A-
ALL POWER ON AMENDED AUTOMATED
SKEWS ME NETWORK COMP OPERATION
SYSTEMS AND YET. AND YET WE
HAVE CARRIERS WHO HAVE NOT
PROVIDED INFORMATION TO OUR
STATE WARNING CENTER. AT THAT
TIME IF CARE IS HAVE THESE
ADVANCED SYSTEMS WHY ARE THEY
NOT BEING SHARED WITH CAL O. E.
S. OR THE PUBLIC TO ENHANCE
PUBLIC SAFETY. GOING FORWARD
THIS PROCEEDING WILL FOCUS ON
THE ADOPTION OF FURTHER RULES
TO ADDRESS COMMUNICATION
NETWORK OUTAGES DURING
EMERGENCY EVENTS TO KEEP THE
COMMUNICATION NETWORKS FUNCTION.
ON DECEMBER EIGHTEENTH THE CPUC
ISSUED AS MENTIONED EARLIER A
RULING THAT INCLUDES ENABLING
TRANSPARENT COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN INDUSTRY FIRST
RESPONDERS ACROSS THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE PUBLIC IN A
TIMELY MANNER DURING DISASTROUS
EVENTS AND DEVELOPING.
REQUIREMENTS FOR RESILIENT AND
DEPENDABLE COMMUNICATIONS GRID
TO FURTHER ADDRESS
COMMUNICATIONS OUTAGES DURING
EMERGENCY EVENTS. ADDITIONALLY
LAST SPRING THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE MODE
AS IT ENTERED A MOTION IN THE
EMERGENCY MEASURES PROCEEDING
WHICH RAISED IMPORTANT ISSUES
REGARDING RESILIENCY AND YOU
WILL HEAR FROM THEM LATER TODAY
THEY ADVOCATED FOR SPECIFIC
DUTIES FOR CARRIERS FOR THE
DELIVERY. OF NINE ONE ONE.
CALLS AND ROBUST BATTERY BACKUP
REQUIREMENTS WROTE DIVERSITY
AND ASKED US TO IMPROVE THE
RELIABILITY OF ALERT WARNINGS
WE WANT TO BRING THESE
PROPOSALS INTO OUR PUBLIC
PROCESS. IN A IN A SECOND C. U.
P. C. IN A SECOND HEARING PC
UCC PROCEEDING TO WHICH I AM
ALSO A SIGNED THE D. ENERGY IS
ATION PROCEEDING WE WILL REFINE
THE P. S. P. S. PLANNING AND
NOTIFICATION GUIDELINES SO
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS RECEIVED THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
MINIMIZE THE IMPACT OF PSP A-
P. S. P. S. OF DENSE. ON THEIR
NETWORKS AND PURCHASE PLANNING
EXERCISE WITH THE ELECTRIC I
USE IN ADVANCE OF THE WILDFIRE
SEASON. ON JOHN JANUARY FIRST
AS HELEN MENTIONED THE P. YOU
SEE CODE SECTION SEVEN TEN
WHICH DE REGULATED INTERNET
BASED SERVICES SUNSET IT. THE
COMMISSION TAKES THIS
RESTORATION OF OUR FORTY AND
NEW RESPONSIBILITY SERIOUSLY.
AS I AS HAS BEEN CONVEYED BY MY
COLLEAGUES TODAY AND BY RECENT
EVENTS THERE'S CONSIDERABLE
ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY. GOING FOR THE
COMMISSION WILL SEEK TO PROTECT
PUBLIC SAFETY AND TO INSURE
QUALITY OF SERVICE INCLUDING
CONTINUE PROVISIONS OF NINE ONE
ONE AND OTHER EMERGENCY
SERVICES VITAL TO PUBLIC SAFETY
AS PROTECTING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SAFETY AND THE GENERAL WELFARE.
WE ARE ALREADY WORKING TO
EXTEND THE PROTECTIONS
PROVIDED. TO THE REST OF THE
TELEPHONE CUSTOMERS TO
CONSUMERS WITH COMPLAINTS ABOUT
THE ALLIED PEACE SERVICE. AND
ANY MORE SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES TO
PROTECTIONS WILL FOR THE
CONSUMERS WILL GO THROUGH THE
COMMISSIONER'S FORMAL PROCESS.
THE COMMISSION'S FORMAL PROCESS
WHICH WILL GIVE THE PUBLIC AN
INDUSTRY AMPLE NOTICE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE DEVELOPMENT OF ANY
REGULATORY CHANGES. WELL BEFORE
THE NEXT WILDFIRE SEASON STARTS
WE MUST TOGETHER DETERMINE HOW
WE VIEW NINE ONE ONE EMERGENCY
ALERTS AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
COMMUNICATIONS ARE THESE
NECESSITIES THAT SHOULD BE
ACCESSED UNFAILINGLY. EVEN WHEN
THE POWER IS OUT SHOULD IT
MATTER IF THE SERVICE IS A LAND
LINE SERVICE OR WIRELESS OR
INTERNET BASED SERVICE ALL OF
THESE INITIATIVES ARE
RESPONSIBLE. AND WITH IN OUR
STATUTORY MANDATE THERE ARE
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND THE
ESSENTIAL COMPONENTS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY WHICH SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME I APPRECIATE THE
INVITATION FOR BEING HERE WITH
MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR.
ONE OF THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
DISPATCHER I KNOW YOU'RE NEW TO
THE POSITION BUT WE'VE- WE'VE
BECOME A STATE THAT SO DEPEND
ON ELECTRICITY AND YOU OVERSEE
ELECTRICITY AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND YOU
OVERSEE TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND
WE'VE BEEN SEEING TRENDS. FOR
DECADES NOW PEOPLE LEAVING HARD-LINE TO CELL PHONES IN THIS
BEEN GOING ON FOR SOME TIME AND
YES IF I WERE JUST DID USE AN
EXAMPLE YOU KNOW TRYING TO. RE
IMPLEMENT A NEW TAX YOU KNOW
THEY THEY WERE THEY FELL BEHIND
THE TREND. YOU KNOW ALMOST A
DECADE OR SO ON ON WATCHING HOW
THINGS WERE CHANGING AND HOW
THEY HAD TO CHARGE. TAXPAYERS
FOR THE- CHARGE TO HAVE A NINE
ONE ONE SERVICE SIDE I'M JUST
CURIOUS IF YOU COULD TELL ME
ONE OR TWO OR THREE INITIATIVES
THAT THE CPUC. PURSUED. FIFTEEN
TEN FIVE YEARS AGO TO. TO TELL
THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
AND THE ELECTRIC INDUSTRY HEY
YOU IF THIS HAPPENS YOU SHOULD
BE PREPARED LIKE- HAVE A BACK
UP GENERATOR. OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT WHAT WHAT WHAT IS THE CPUC
DONE TO BE PROACTIVE OVER THE
LAST DECADE OR TWO. AND THANK
YOU CENTER MORE LOCK ON AS YOU
RIGHTLY STATED I'M NEW TO THE
CITY. AS OF. AUGUST SIXTEENTH-
AND I THINK SOME OF THOSE
ACTIONS WERE OUTLINED IN-
HELEN'S TESTIMONY AND EVEN SOME
WERE. IN COMMISSIONER WRECK
SHAMANS TESTIMONY BUT I'M GONNA
TURN TO- HELEN TO FURTHER AND
NANCY EIGHT SOME OF THOSE ITEMS
THAT WE HAVE UNDERTAKEN. INDEED
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
NOT BEEN I'M GONNA USE THE WORD
ALLOWED. TO IMPLEMENT. HELLO.
SENATOR OUT AND PRESIDENT
MATCHER THE COMMISSION. HAS.
NOT BEEN AS. HAS NOT REGULARLY
NEW SERVICES TO THE EXTENT
REGULATED OLDER SERVICES THAT
WAS THE. JUST OF MY TESTIMONY
AND SO WE HAVE THE COMMISSION
HAS ALLOWED NASCENT INDUSTRIES
LIKE WIRELESS AND BEFORE
SECTION SEVEN TEN WAS PASSED V.
O. I. P. TO JUST DEVELOP
WITHOUT MUCH REGULATION WE WERE
CONSTRAINED BY FEDERAL LAW FROM
REGULATING WIRELESS RATES TREE-
AND WE DID ATTEMPT TO ADOPT
BACKUP POWER RULES AND ACTUALLY
THE FCC DID THAT AS WELL THEN
THE FCC'S EFFORT FAILED. IN THE
COMMISSION ADOPTED RULES FOR
THE RULES REALLY JUST ABOUT
NOTICE TO CUSTOMERS. AND WE
HAVE. TAKING A CLOSER LOOK AT
THIS MORE RECENTLY BUT IN PAST
YEARS IT WAS REALLY MORE OF AN
EMPHASIS ON. ALLOWING THESE
INDUSTRIES TO DEVELOP AND THAT
WAS CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION AS WELL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SENATE
JACKSON. I'D LIKE TO TAKES LIKE
A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO THIS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE HAS BEEN
A BATTLE BETWEEN THE FCC AND
WHAT THE STATE'S CAN DO- YOU'VE
BEEN LIMITED BY CERTAIN FEDERAL
LAWS LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT TODAY
MY UNDERSTANDING FROM YOUR
TESTIMONY IS THAT THE FCC TRIED
TO REASSERT SOME OF THOR EDDIE
THAT YOU BELIEVE THE STATE HAS.
STATE HAS PREVAILED. SENATOR
YOU REFERRING TO THE BROADBAND
ISSUE. OKAY SO MY QUESTION IS
WEIRD DO YOU BELIEVE THE STATE
HAS THE AUTHORITY THAT WE HAVE
NOT EXERCISED THAT WE NEED TO
EXERCISE OVER THE
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK
SPECIFICALLY THE WIRELESS
NETWORKS WE KNOW DURING THE PS
PS. A THE BARK COALS THAT AS
YOU MENTIONED SO MANY THE
SYSTEMS WERE DOWN. WE HAD IF
I'M NOT MISTAKEN NO ABILITY TO
ASCERTAIN WHY THEY WERE DOWN
BECAUSE THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES DIDN'T FEEL THEY HAD
THAT THEY OWED US ANY
OBLIGATION TO THAT THAT THEY
WERE UNDER NO REQUIREMENTS. TO
COMPLY TO BE PART OF THE.
DURING OUR- FORTY DAYS OF
THOMAS FIRE IN THE SUBSEQUENT
DEBRIS FLOW THAT COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS WHENEVER HE A MERCHANT
SEE OFFICES WERE NOT ENGAGED TO
TOLD US BASICALLY TO GO POUND
SAND- AND SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE DO HAVE. THE AUTHORITY OR
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE THE
AUTHORITY WHAT IS SEEK YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SEE. IN ORDER
FOR- WIRELESS COMPANIES TO NOT
ONLY BE RESPONSIVE BUT
RESPONSIBLE. AND TAKE A STRONG
ROLE IN TRYING TO SURE THAT
WHEN WE HAVE THESE ADVANCE WE
DON'T LOSE OUR COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS FOR THE BASIS OF NOT
ONLY FOR OUR ECONOMY. BUT ALSO
THE SECURITY IN THE SAFETY OF
OUR ABILITY AS FAMILIES TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER
WHEN THE SYSTEM'S GOING. DID IT
LITERALLY IN EVERY WAY SHAPE
AND FORM THAT'S NOT ACCEPTABLE
WHAT CAN WE APPEAR ON THIS DIET
IS DUE TO HELP YOU MAKE THESE
COMPANIES MORE ACCOUNTABLE AND
RESPONSIBLE. I'LL TAKE A FIRST
SWING AND THAT SENATOR AND THEN
TURNED TO MY COLLEAGUES- WE
HAVE PROCEEDINGS THAT I
MENTIONED IN MY TESTIMONY THAT
ARE UNDER WAY WERE WE WILL BE
FLUSHING OUT SOME OF THE
AUTHORITY. THAT WE DO HAVE AND
SOME OF THE RESTORED AUTHORITY
S. SINCE THE SUN SETTING OF
SEVEN TEN- BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY
WE NEED TO HAVE A LIABILITY AND
AS HAS BEEN WELL STATED TODAY.
AND RELIABILITY WILL COME IN
THE MOST. YEAH IT IN THE MOST
CURRENT TIME AND IN THE NEAR
FUTURE WITH BATTERY BACKUP AND
GENERATION. AND THAT TAKES
DIFFERENT FORMS ON DIFFERENT
SYSTEMS BUT- AND I CERTAINLY
RESPECT THAT HOWEVER- THEY THE
THAT IS WHAT WE NEED WE HAVE TO
HAVE A LIABILITY ISSUE SO WELL
MENTION SENATOR. YOU HAVE DEAD
AIR. NO COMMUNICATIONS THAT
IMPACTS WAS WAS WELL STATED IN
THE STAFF AND NOW IS THAT
IMPACTS HOSPITALS IT IN PACKS-
THE COMMERCE OF OUR STATE TAX
EVERYTHING AND THEN THEN WE
HAVE POWER SURGES WHEN THEY
COME BACK ON AS WELL. ACT SO WE
THE RELIABILITY AND WE HAVE TO
GET THEIR LIFE AND THEY NEED TO
ALSO IT HERE TO THE- GUIDELINES
THAT WE HAVE ALREADY INSTITUTED
IN TERMS OF WHEN THAT HOW LONG
THEY HAVE TO. HAVE THAT BACK UP
AND THAT RELIABILITY AND HOW
SOON THEY HAVE TO HAVE IT. SO
HELEN ARE THERE SOME COUPLE
THINGS I PROBABLY MISSED IT
WOULD LIKE TO ENUNCIATE THANK
YOU PRESIDENT BASHER CENERS AT
THE WHAT I WOULD SAY IS. WE
ALSO NEED TO MOVE OFF OF
VOLUNTARY DISCLOSURE I KNOW
THAT A BILL PASSED THIS YEAR-
OR RATHER IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AND IT DIDN'T IS A
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION WE HAVE
TO SEE HOW THAT. UNFOLDS BUT
THE FIRST RESPONDERS HAVE
PULLED THE COMMISSION. IN
PUBLIC TWICE WHEN I'VE BEEN
PRESENT THAT VOLUNTARY JUST
REPORTING OF OUTAGE INFORMATION
IS SIMPLY NOT GOOD ENOUGH
THEY'RE GETTING INFORMATION IN
CASE IN IN CONSISTENT FORMATS.
SPENT JUST THE REPORTING IS
THREE AND DOESN'T WORK SO WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT AND TO. WE
NEED HELP PLEDGES I THINK A LOT
OF. WITH MY LIFE HEARING HAD IN
NOVEMBER WHERE WE GOD FEARING
COMMITMENTS FROM THE CARRIER
THE DEGREE TO WHICH THEY WERE
WILLING TO PUBLICLY DISCLOSE
THEIR OUTAGE INFORMATION IN MY
LAST QUESTION IS DO YOU BELIEVE
WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY IS A
STATE TO IMPOSE THAT
REQUIREMENT OR IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT THE FCC HAS
PREEMPTED. I'M THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
IMPOSE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
AND ALSO TO IT WOULD REQUIRE
BACKUP POWER. I THINK YOU'LL
GET A DIFFERENT ANSWER FROM THE
INDUSTRY. THE OWNER OF. THE
MEASURE CHAIRED AND CHAIRMAN OF
THE THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY- SO I HAPPEN TO REPRESENT
TO SOME OF THOSE RULE AREAS
SINCE THE FIRST OF FIRST I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A STATEMENT. THE
P. YOU SEE. SAYS THAT THE
PROVIDERS DON'T DISCLOSE IN THE
PROVIDER SAY THE P. YOU SEE
DOZEN NEWS TO WORK SO I'M IN
THE MIDDLE OF THIS AND I'M
GONNA BE ASKING THEM THE SAME
QUESTIONS WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT
TIME NOW WHERE WE HAVE. WE HAVE
POWER OUTAGES IT WASN'T COMMON
FIVE YEARS AGO WE'VE HAD
CATASTROPHIC WILD FIRE THAT WAS
A- COMMON FIVE YEARS AGO. BUT
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE AND THE.
TAXPAYERS OR RATE PAYERS I
SHOULD SAY HAVE STEPPED UP TO
THE PLATE. WE DID A BILL LAST
YEAR THAT INCREASE THE FEE FOR
NINE ONE ONE SERVICES I KNOW
THAT THAT MONIES IN THE
PIPELINE AND ISN'T. ON THE
GROUND YET. SO WE STEPPED UP
THERE WE ALSO PASSED A BILL.
COUPLE YEARS BACK YES SIXTEEN
SIXTY TWO WHICH. DR MONEY TO
LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS.
KAMALA YOUR SOME OF YOUR
COSTITUENTS DO AND ALSO FOR
RULE AREAS WHERE WE PROVIDED
ASSISTANCE FOR- NON PROFITS A
IN THE UTILITIES TO BE ABLE TO
GO OUT AND PROVIDE INTERNET
SERVICES TO LIBRARIES HOSPITALS
AND UNDERSERVED AREAS. FIRST SO
WE'VE STEPPED UP SO MY QUESTION
TO YOU IS WITH ALL THOSE THINGS
PUT INTO PLACE WHAT WOULD YOU
WHAT WOULD YOU RECOMMEND TO THE
LEGISLATURE. TO HELP. BRING
POWER BACK ON IN A MORE MAN OR
NOT I DON'T WANT TO HEAR THAT
THE I MEAN ASKED HIM THE SAME
QUESTIONS AGAIN ON THE
OPPORTUNITY TO I'M TRYING TO
FIND OUT THE FACTS SO I KNOW
WERE TO MOVE WE'VE DONE A LOT
AT THE ON OUR SIDE I BELIEVE ON
OUR SIDE OF IT. BUT WE NEED THE
FACTS THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY GET
DOWN TO WHERE WE GET THE
SERVICES OUT TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHEN WE HAVE THESE
CATASTROPHIC EVENTS NOW I
HAPPEN TO REPRESENT- PARADISE-
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY. AND
I WILL TELL YOU. THE WELL IT'S
OTHER PROVIDERS WHERE THERE.
WHEN THE WHEN THE LINES WERE
DOWN AND THEY SET UP TOWERS AND
WE WERE ABLE TO COMMUNICATE
SOMEWHAT AFTER THE FIRE
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE FIRE WHEN
THE SMOKE WAS STILL IT WAS
STILL SMOKING. BUT WHEN YOU'RE
IN. SISKIYOU OR YOUR IN ALPINE
OR YOUR IN NEVADA COUNTY AND
YOU HAVE A FIRE A TEENS FIRE
THERE'S NO POSSIBLE WAY YOU CAN
GET THE POWER UP IN FORTY EIGHT
HOURS WHEN YOU'RE- WORKING IN
MOUNTAINS LIKE THIS. AND THE
MOST OF THOSE CONSTITUENTS ARE
ON LAND LINES OUT THERE BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE CELL SERVICES. SO
YOU HAVE TO COMPARE APPLES TO
APPLES. AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'M
ASKING YOU WHAT WHAT WHAT WOULD
YOU RECOMMEND TO THIS
LEGISLATURE DO. WITH THESE NEW.
POWER OUTAGES THAT WE'RE GONNA
SEE FOR THE FUTURE THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO KNOW AND
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR BLAME I
WOULD SAY IF IT'S ON THERE AND
I WANT THEM THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
TO. SAY I WANT TO ME TELL ME
WHO'S AT FAULT. BECAUSE WE'VE I
THINK STEPPED UP IN THE
TAXPAYERS AND RATEPAYERS OF
STEPPED UP NOW IT'S TIME TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE- COORDINATE
BETWEEN YOU. AND THEM TO GET IT
DONE. SENATOR IS THANK YOU AND
YOU HAVE STEPPED UP. AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE IT AND- SOME
OF THE- THE STEPS THAT YOU HAVE
DONE WITH TO ARTICULATED TODAY
AND WE- WILL BE IN THEM.
PROCEEDINGS THAT I MENTIONED
FURTHER EXAMINING AND- A
UTILIZING AND IMPLEMENTING SOME
OF THE THINGS THAT WE NOW HAVE
THE- AUTHORITY AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO. I AGREE WITH YOU THE
BLAME GAME DOESN'T WORK WE
POINTING THE FINGER TO THE
INDUSTRY. AND ANDERSON PUTTING
THE FINGER BACK AT US IT
DOESN'T WORK I WILL ADMIT. IN
MY- HEARING IN NOVEMBER I DID
GET A LITTLE EMOTIONAL ABOUT
THE FACT THAT I DIDN'T THINK
THEY SHOWED UP THE WAY THEY
NEEDED TO AND IN THE OCTOBER
NOVEMBER EVENTS. BUT THE TOOLS
WE NEED ARE THE TOOLS WE
DISCUSSED AND- WE NEED
INFORMATION WE NEED DATA WE
NEED TO KNOW WHERE PEOPLE ARE
AWARE WHERE THE OUTAGES ARE WE
NEED TO KNOW. WHY THEY ARE WE
NEED TO KNOW. WHAT'S ON CERTAIN
POLLS I KNOW THAT'S NOT
SPECIFIC TO TODAY BUT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT INFORMATION- AND SO
IF THINGS IF POLLS GO DOWN FOR
EXAMPLE HAVE NO CLUE WHAT.
WHO'S WHO'S ON THAT POLE. BUT
THERE UTILIZING HOW THE
UTILIZING THAT. AT FOR WHAT.
AND I THINK A COMBINATION OF
THE INFORMATION THAT- YES-
CALLOW YES NEEDS AS WELL AS CAL
FIRE IN THE ON AND- SEE BE UC'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF
DATA. AND AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
THE RELIABILITY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND THOSE ARE THINGS
ARE WORKING ON AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY ON DOING. IT WE HAVE
TO. DO MY COLLEAGUES TO DO
ANYTHING ELSE. NO I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD I THINK
PRESIDENT VENTURE HAS COVERED
THAT THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU AM I THINK.
THANK CHAIRMAN FOR. CLEANING
THIS HEARING TODAY AND WHAT
BRINGS YOUR IS. PS PS BUT
REALLY WHAT BRINGS HERE'S
WHAT'S SOMETHING ON A
COMMISSIONER. RUSSIA IVAN-
TOUCHED UPON AND WHAT WE
LEARNED IN 200-010-2000 ELEVEN.
THE WALL FULL MAINTENANCE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE BUYER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS. COMPANIES
AND WE SAW IT WITH THE RAIN AND
THE END OF 200-010-2000 LEVEL
ONE OUT. THOUSANDS OF CUSTOMERS
WERE OUT OF PHONE SERVICE FOR.
MANY MANY DAYS AND WE HAD
HEARINGS. HERE AND DOWN IN LOS
ANGELES AND WE GET THEIR OWN
EMPLOYEES THE COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA COME BEFORE
US AND TESTIFIED. THAT THE A
WORK ORDERS THIS HIGH. THAT
WEREN'T BEING WORKED. AND IT'S
CRITICAL TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
THE ARGUMENT THAT. WHILE THE
CUSTOMERS ARE MIGRATING AWAY
FROM THE LAND LINE BUT THAT
LAND LINE IS STILL CRITICAL TO
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO WHETHER
IT'S WIRELESS SERVICE WHETHER
IT'S FOR YOU. AND THAT LAST
MILE THAT COPPER IS NOT BEING
MAINTAINED SO I NEED TO
UNDERSTAND. WHERE ARE WE
HOLDING YOUR FEET TO THE FIRE
IT WAS THE IN VERIZON. AND
EIGHTEEN T. NOW IT'S FRONTIER
EIGHTEEN TO WHAT ARE WE DOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT CAUGHT HIS
MAINTAIN THIS CRITICAL NOT ONLY
THE LAND LINE CUSTOMER BUT-
WIRELESS. THE WHITE. HOUSE
BURKE AND ROOM SHE HAD MORE
WORN. OUT SENATOR THE STATE.
ALLOCATED OUT BEST FOR THOSE
RURAL AREAS. THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SHE CRITICAL
IT'S NOT BEING MET THANK.
SENATOR BRADFORD WE I THINK YOU
DID IT QUITE WELL WE NOW HAVE
THE FINDINGS OF THIS NETWORK
EXAMINATION THAT PLAINLY LAY
OUT WHAT THE CARRIERS ARE NOT
DOING. WE HAVE A SYSTEM IN
PLACE FOR FINING THEM BUT WE
DON'T KNOW IF IT'S WORKING IF
IT'S SUFFICIENT WE DON'T KNOW
IF THE EXISTING METRICS ARE
ENOUGH IF WE NEED TO EXPAND
THEM. AND WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT THAT RIGHT AWAY IN
THIS NEXT YEAR. BUT AGAIN WE
KNEW THAT IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
WE KNEW IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
AND ARE WE- AGAIN HAVING
ONGOING DIALOGUE TO MAKE SURE
LIKE TO SAY THIS. COPPER IS
MAINTAINED THAT LAOS LAST FALL
SERVICES CRITICAL TO EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO HERE. GOING. FOR IT
TO END THE SOMETHING TO ASK THE
CARRIERS ABOUT IT'S A VERY BIG
CHALLENGE BECAUSE THEY ARE
DISINVEST TING IN THOSE
TRADITIONAL SERVICES THEY- SEE.
MORE OPPORTUNITIES IN BROADBAND
ANOTHER SERVICES WIRELESS
SERVICES. AS YOU KNOW THERE'S
STILL MILLIONS OF CUSTOMERS IN
CALIFORNIA DEPEND ON
TRADITIONAL LAND LINES WE SEE
WHAT A VITAL ROLE THEY PLAY IN
EMERGENCIES IN NINE ONE ONE ONE
OTHER. POWERS OFF. IN THOSE
NETWORKS NEED TO BE MAINTAINED.
I THINK WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT
TAKING A CLOSER LOOK IN COMING
UP WITH NEW RULES WILL ENSURE
CONTINUED INVESTMENT I THINK
STRONG LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
AND HOLDING THE CARRIER'S FEET
TO THE FIRE WILL HELP AS WELL.
CENTER GLAZER. AT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN LET ME OF
PERCENT SAY I APPRECIATE THE
SPECIAL INVITATION TO BE A PART
OF THE DAY THE IMPACT OF THE PS
PS Và ACROSS THE STATE OF THE
BEEN PROFOUND AND IT'S
CERTAINLY IN MY AREA AS WELL
AND I THINK THAT THE TO THE
CHAIRS LEADERSHIP ON THIS SAY
IT TO HEARINGS WITHIN A MATTER
OF US SIXTY DAYS IS AN
INDICATION I THINK OF WHAT YOU
FEEL IS. HOW THE URGENCY THAT
YOU BRING TO THIS ISSUE WITH
THE YOU KNOW IT IS SO CRITICAL
THAT- AS A LOT OF QUESTIONS I
HAVE BEEN ASKED ONE I'D ASK YOU
TO THE PRESIDENT. OF THE
COMMISSION. AS WE- YOU KNOW THE
THAT. WE'VE WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
THE LANDSCAPE YOU'VE LAID IT
OUT. BUT THE THING THAT MY-
RESIDENTS ASK ME. IS IT STEVE.
NINE MONTHS FROM NOW WE'RE
GONNA BE IN THE EXACT SAME HIGH
RISK MOMENT. AGAIN AND HAVE YOU
DONE EVERYTHING THAT YOU CAN
DO. TO ENSURE THAT WHAT WE
EXPERIENCE. BEFORE WILL NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN AND SO MATTER
PRESIDENT THAT'S REALLY MY
SIMPLE QUESTION TO YOU. THAT
YOU ARE FAMILIAR WITH THAT.
WHAT THE CARRIERS OF SAID
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE
INFASTRUCTURE CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHAT INSURANCE IS CAN OU GIVE
US AND WE ARE PARTNERS IN THIS
AND I RESPECT AND RECOGNIZE
THAT BUT THAT WE WILL NOT BE IN
THE SAME SITUATION NINE MONTHS
FROM NOW WHAT. WHAT ASSURANCE
CAN YOU GIVE US. WELL I THINK.
ARM EQ WELL STATED IT WE'RE ALL
PARTNERS IN THIS AND THAT
INCLUDES THE INDUSTRY AS WELL.
SO ON IT'S THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT THAT SO VERY
IMPORTANT. IT'S THE DIFFERENT
ENTITIES WITHIN THE STATE
GOVERNMENT. A CAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES CAL FIRES AND THE P.
UC WE HAVE PROCEEDINGS THAT ARE
UNDER WAY. THAT WILL ESTABLISH
ADDITIONAL RULES AND
AUTHORITIES IN OVERSIGHT. I
CAN'T PREJUDGE THAT HOWEVER-
THOSE OF SOME OF THE THINGS ARE
LOOKING AT THESE PROCEEDINGS
WILL NOT GO ON FOR YEARS. I
WILL MAKE SURE OF THAT- WE ARE-
WE ARE AS AS MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
SAID WERE ALSO REVIEWING THINGS
IN A POST. SUNSET OF SEVEN TEN
DODD ERA OF LOOKING INTO OTHER
THINGS THAT WE CAN HOLD THE
INDUSTRY RESPONSIBLE FOR I
THINK THE THINGS THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY. DONE TALKED ABOUT
THOSE THINGS THAT WE HAVE HAD
THEM TESTIFY TO. NEED TO BE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED. AND AGAIN I
DON'T MEAN TO POINT THE FINGER
BUT WE ARE ALL IN A PARTNERSHIP
HERE. THE PC HAS TO BE THE
REGULATOR AND WE HAVE TO CARRY
OUT OUR REGULATORY
RESPONSIBILITIES WHETHER THAT
MEANS- NEW AUTHORITY. OR WHAT
THAT MEANS ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT
OR FRANKLY WHETHER THAT MEANS
PENALTIES. BUT NONE OF US NONE
OF US. WANTS TO EVER SEE A FIRE
SEASON LIKE WHAT WE EXPERIENCED
THIS PAST FALL AND I'D THAT
GOES FOR ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES
IN STATE GOVERNMENT FROM THE
GOVERNOR ON DOWN THEN IN PLEASE
IN MY COLLEAGUES CAN ADD
ANYTHING TO THAT. GUY WHICH IS
STANDARD PRESIDENT VETERAN
MENTIONED EARLIER THE-
EMERGENCY MEASURES PROCEEDING
THAT THAT IS UNDER HER
OVERSIGHT AND THAT HAS AS- AN
ELEMENT IN THE NEXT PHASE WHICH
IS LAUNCHING NOW- THE ISSUE OF
BACKUP POWER AND WHAT WE DO
ABOUT THAT. SO WE ARE MOVING ON
THAT CAN YOU JUST EXPAND ON THE
TIMING OF IT. OKAY I CAN'T
BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE WHEN THE
SCOPING MAMMAL HAS GONE OUT OR
IS GOING OUT BUT ONCE IT'S
GIVING THEM A CLOSE OUT THEN WE
SET TO SCHEDULE FOR THE
PRECEDING. COMMENTS I DON'T
THINK HEARINGS ARE GONNA BE
REQUIRED BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT
FOR SURE I DON'T WANT TO PRE
JUDGE- BUT DO YOU HAVE GOALS IN
TERMS OF ONE YOU WANT YOU WANT
TO FINALIZE A PROCESS. HI I
DON'T DO IT AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND IT AND WE DON'T
WANT TO BE BUREAUCRATIC AND
EXPLAINING RIGHT. OUR PROCESS
BECAUSE MY GOD I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND IT MYSELF AFTER
BEING THERE FOR JUST. THREE
FOUR MONTHS- SO WON'T DO THAT
TO YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BUT- THE
SCOPING MEMO WE CAN- IN THAT
IT'S MY PRECEDING I CAN HAVE
SOME OVERSIGHT OVER THE-
TIMELINESS OF THAT. THANK YOU
AND I THINK THAT'LL BE
IMPORTANT GIVEN. THE CONCERNS
RAISED OVER TIME IN AND I'M NOT
APPROACHING FIRE SEASON. WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ONTO CENTER MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR-
AYE AYE TWO ONE ECHO THE THANKS
TO THE CHAIR THE THAT. THE
TEARS BEEN ON THIS ISSUE POWER
SHUT OFFS- SINCE BEFORE THE
HOLIDAYS MAKING SURE WE DON'T
REPEAT. THE HOT MESS THAT WE
HAD- OVER THE SUMMER AND INTO
THE FALL. THANK CALIFORNIANS
ARE BETTER AND VERY GRATEFUL
FOR YOUR WORK ALONG WITH
PROTEINS WORK IS WELL- JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY ONE ISSUE-
MISTER CHAIR THERE IS A- A
COMMENT MADE EARLIER- YES HAS
BEEN MOVING FAST ENOUGH FIND
NINE ONE ONE UPGRADE. THE MOVE
IN TEL. THANK YOU FOR. THEY'RE
ABOUT TO TAKE IN AND IT WAS
DEFEATED BY THIS LEGISLATURE SO
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT
WE MAKE IT VERY CLEAR WE HAD TO
WAIT TO THE LEGISLATOR PROVE
THE FUNDING. SO THAT- WE ASK AN
IMPLEMENT A NINE ONE ONE
UPGRADE TO NEXT AND NUMBER ONE.
AND THEN PRESIDENT IN IT ECHO
WHERE CENTER GLAZER WAS AND I
JUST TWO QUICK QUESTIONS RIGHT
AFTER THAT. I KNOW YOU'RE THE
SCOPING MEMO BUT I THINK THAT.
MEMBERS AND I DON'T SPEAK FOR
FOLKS BUT I THINK ALL THIS ONE
HERE HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
EXPEDITE PROCEEDINGS. PRIOR TO
FIRE SEASON- AND THAT'S REALLY
THE HEALTH IN THE ROOM ON THE
PUBLIC UTILITY SIDE. I KNOW
THIS IS A FRUSTRATION FOR YOU
BUT- YOU TALK ABOUT RULES AND
OVERSIGHT. WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
AND THEN WHAT CALVET WHAT IN
YOUR MIND WHAT CAN CALIFORNIANS
EXPECTING PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION PRIOR TO FIRE SEASON
AT ALL TO SAY. LATE SUMMER
EARLY FALL WHAT CAN EXPECT WHAT
TYPE OF ACTION WILL THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION BE ACTING
ON. SPECIFICALLY AND TO ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION- AND IN TERMS OF
THE PROCEEDINGS I WOMAN I WILL
AS THE PERSON A PERSON THAT HAS
THE PROCEEDINGS- ASSIGNED TO
ME- I'LL MAKE SURE THAT IT
SAYS- EXPEDITED AS POSSIBLE THE
ONE THING THAT IS DIFFICULT IS
ARE NOT DIFFICULT THE ONE THING
THAT IS CHALLENGING IN TERMS OF
X. EXPEDITING- ACTIVITIES IS
MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S PROPER
DUE PROCESS AND THAT INCLUDES-
THE DUE PROCESS FOR THOSE WE
REGULATE AS WELL AS THE RATE
PAYERS AND OF THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SO WE WILL WE WILL
EXPEDITE. OUR PROCEEDINGS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND IN
TERMS OF IMPLEMENTING WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THE THINGS THAT WE
NEED AND THOSE ARE THE THINGS
THAT WILL HELP US. REGULATE THE
INDUSTRY AND HAVE- PROPER
OVERSIGHT OF THE INDUSTRY SO
THAT THE THINGS THAT WE SAW THE
HOT MESSAGE YOU WELL STATED
DOESN'T OCCUR AGAIN A HOT MESS
WILL MEAN THAT PEOPLE DO HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO CALL NINE ONE
ONE WHETHER THEIR WIRELESS OR.
OUR LANDLINE YEAH IN IN I KNOW
SO YOU WANT TO JUMP IN I THINK
JUST BEING CANDID ABOUT IT. I
HAVE SOME GREAT CONCERN. ABOUT
BACKUP POWER UHHUH AND WHEN WE
HAD FOREIGN FIFTY FOUR FOLK
FOREIGN FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND
FOLKS WHO RELIED ON CABLE PHONE
SERVICE OR LAND LINE OUT THIS
YEAR. GETTING TO WHERE CENTER
DOLLY WAS MENTIONING MENDOCINO
COAST THEY CAN CALL IN AND ONE
ONE. NOW AND I HAVE GREAT
CONCERN- BOTH ON HOW FAST IS
TAKEN ACT IN HOW FAST
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND CABLE
CAN ACT THAT WE MAY BE IN STORE
FOR THE SAME THING THIS YEAR. I
THINK WE NEED TO GET OUR ACT
TOGETHER TO BE ON THE MOVE ON
THAT. AND IT'S GOING TO TAKE
TIME TO BE ABLE TO DO THE
BACKUP POWER- WHEN IT COMES TO
CELL TOWERS. AND I DON'T HAVE A
CONFIDENCE INDUSTRIES GONNA
MOVE WITHOUT A MANDATE. BECAUSE
WHAT WE SAW IN AND THIS IS A
QUESTION OF SAVE FOR THEIR
DIRECTOR MUNCIE SERVICES. EVEN
SURE INCE'S THIS SUMMER. AS IN
YOU KNOW THIS THAT THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO WOULDN'T HAPPEN
WE WERE AND THE HIGHER TO MY
BEING PRESIDENT RIGHT YES THEY
WERE TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES LITERALLY HAD TO
DRIVE HUNDREDS OF GENERATORS IN
FROM TEXAS. TRY TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA UP AND RUNNING AND
IT DIDN'T WORK BUT SO I BRING
ALL THIS UP THESE. I'M TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT. HOW THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION IS GOING
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE ON WHAT.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PRIOR TO
THE SEASON AND I THINK WHO IS
BEING HONEST ABOUT IT NOT AT
ALL I TRY TO BE DIFFICULT BUT I
THINK IT'S CAN BE CHALLENGING
FOR YOU TO DO SO. AND THAT
MEANS. WE GOT TO MOVE. WE HAVE
TO BE HONEST WITH. CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ABOUT. WHAT CHANGE
THEY'RE GONNA SEE THIS YEAR AND
I THINK WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO.
COME UP WITH THAT- HARD. LINE
MESSAGE ABOUT WHAT CHANGES ARE
GOING TO SEE. I UNDERSTAND YOU
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO DO THAT NOW.
BUT I KNOW MISTER CHAIR THAT'S
WHAT I'M INTERESTED FROM THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION. I
AND I KNOW YOU MAY HAVE FUTURE
HEARING ANNUAL HEARING
OVERSIGHT HEARING. AND
HOPEFULLY YOU'RE GONNA BE OUR
ADDRESS THAT WHEN YOU COME
BACK. ON WHAT CALIFORNIA'S CAN
SEE PRIOR TO THIS. FIRE SEASON
FROM PC. SWISHER OF YET TO THE-
CENTER OF OUR JUST WANNA
COMMENT ABOUT THE EXPEDITING OF
PROCEEDINGS IT'S- I THANK YOU
FOR PRESIDENT PATCHER THAT
THAT'S A CENTRAL. FOCUS OF HERS
TO GET THINGS DONE MORE QUICKLY.
I UNDERSTAND IT'S A CENTRAL
CONCERN OF THIRD LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN FOR SOME TIME. I WILL
SAY WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
QUICKLY RESOLVE. MANY
PROCEEDINGS RELATED TO WHILE
FOR MATTERS AS MANDATED BY SB
NINE A ONE AND A. B. TEN FIFTY
FOUR. INCLUDING PER APPROVING
THE WHILE FOR MITIGATION PLANS
WITHIN A SIX MONTH PERIOD. THE
PRECEDING THAT PRESIDENT
PATCHES TALKING ABOUT THE- P.
S. P. S. PROCEEDING WE HAD AN
EARLIER PHASE THAT WAS RESOLVED
WITHIN SIX MONTHS. WE ARE
PROCEEDING PROVIDING EMERGENCY
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT WAS
RESOLVED QUICKLY. WE'VE
IMPLEMENTED SEVERAL. VERSIONS
OF OUR COUPLE PROVISIONS OF TEN
FIFTY FOUR ALREADY SO THERE. IS
A SENSE OF URGENCY ABOUT THESE
PARTICULAR PROCEEDINGS AND
THESE PROCESSES. AND THE NEED
TO RESOLVE THEM QUICKLY WE CAN
WE HAVE STATUTORY LIMITS.
LIMITS. TO ENSURE THAT WE
COMPORT TO COMPORT WITH DUE
PROCESS BUT WE ARE TRUE. WITHIN
THOSE CONSTRAINTS WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO RESOLVE
THESE PROCEEDINGS VERY QUICKLY
MR MY LAST QUESTION IS A SIMPLE
ONE- THANK YOU SO MUCH
SCRIPTURE AND MANY PRESENT WHEN
DO YOU THINK THAT YOU CAN BE
MORE SPECIFIC. ON WHAT
CALIFORNIANS CAN EXPECT PRIOR
TO A CALL POWER SHUT OFF SEASON
IF YOU WILL- WAS AT SIXTY DAYS.
NINETY DAYS WHAT'S YOUR GOTTEN
ALL. BACK TO THIS YEAR. I WILL
BE AS SPECIFIC AS I CAN. THAT
IT NOT TO BE BUREAUCRATIC BUT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
LIMITED TO IS IN A PROCEEDING I
CAN'T PREJUDGE IT ON I WOULD BE
IN TROUBLE WITH ALL OF YOU IF I
DID THAT SO- I WILL BE AS OPEN
AND FORTHCOMING- UNDER THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE UC IF I
COULD TAKE THE WIND AND WAVE IT
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS WE
WOULD DO DIFFERENTLY NOT ONLY
IN THE TELE IT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS WORLD BUT
CERTAINLY IN ELECTRICITY WORLD.
WE DON'T HAVE. WE ARE THE
REGULATORS WERE NOT THE
IMPLEMENTOR- AS I HAVESAID TO
THEM THERE AS I'VE SAID TO THE
IOP IS IT'S NOT ABOUT THEIR
PLANS IT'S ABOUT THEIR OUTCOMES
WE CAN'T DRIVE THEIR OUTCOMES
BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY REGULATE
THAT TO BETTER OUTCOMES. AND I
WOULD SAY THE SAME IN THE TELCO
WORLD. THANK YOU SENATOR A
STERN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LIKE A MY COLLEAGUES REMARKS
CREDITING YOUR LEADERSHIP HERE
STAYING VIGILANT EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE THROUGH HOPEFULLY THE
WORST OF IT. THANK YOU ALSO
PRESENT BADGER- GETTING
BURNISHED THROUGH FIRE HERE- IN
A VERY REAL WAY IN YOUR FIRST
FEW MONTHS. TWO TWO QUESTIONS
ONE IS POINT A CLARIFICATION
CORRECTION OFTEN. IT YOU TALKED
ABOUT THE ANALYSIS OF THE DATA
YOU'VE COLLECTED GOING THROUGH
THE VARIOUS TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDERS AND THERE WOULD YOU
CALM THEIR RESTORATION RATES
THE PERCENTAGES THAT YOU TICKED
OFF FIRST CAN YOU GO BACK
THROUGH WOMEN AND JUST. WHAT
WHAT DO THEY MEAN IS THAT. HOW
HOW QUICKLY THEY'RE ABLE TO
RESTORE SERVICE WITHIN A GIVEN
PERIOD OF TIME OR OR IS IT.
ABOUT THE SORT OF I KNOW
THERE'S THE WE'RE GONNA HEAR
DATA ALSO FROM THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FOLKS BUT WE
WHERE THEY'VE GOT BACK UP
GENERATION ON WHICH SITES AT
CETERA BUT JUST. RUN THAT BACK
THROUGH S THE CENTER STERN.
ONE OF THE METRICS IS THE
AMOUNT OF TIME. THAT CERTAIN
THAT SERVICES OUT AND HOW LONG
IT TAKES TO RESTORE THE
SERVICE. AND WE HAVE A
REQUIREMENT THAT CARRIERS
RESTORE 90% OF SERVICE OUTAGES
FOR REGULAR TELEPHONE SERVICE.
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS OR
LESS ON THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE.
IT'S A WIN USE I FORGET EXACTLY
THE PERCENTAGES WERE 56% FOR AT
AND T. OR 48% FOR THE WHAT IS
THAT THAT PERTAINS TO THAT
PERTAINS TO THEIR ABILITY TO.
RESTORE SERVICE WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS ON THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE SHOT IT SO ROUGHLY HALF
FOR SO OR SOME A LITTLE MORE
THAN HAVE SOME LESS THAN HALF
FOR EIGHT ARE ABLE TO. MEET
THAT REQUIREMENT ACROSS THEIR
NETWORK. THAT'S CORRECT THEY
WERE ABLE THEY WERE UNABLE TO
RESTORE SERVICE WITHIN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS IN. IN IN FOR A 52%
OF THE CASES IN EIGHTEEN T. IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FOR EXAMPLE.
THERE'S AT THE WEB VERGE FOR
SERVICE WAS SORREL. IN WHICH
THEY WERE ABLE TO DO WAS 48% SO
52% THEY WERE NOT ABLE TO AND
IS THAT LIMITED JUST TO ACQUIRE
LISTS OR- IS THAT ALSO INCLUDE.
VOICE OVER IP THIS IS DOES THE
TRICK IN ALL THE LAND MINES
JUST FOR LAND I GOT IT SO I'M
ONE OF THOSE CUSTOMERS THAT. IS
NOW MAYBE IN THE PURVIEW OF
PC'S- WORK GOING FORWARD
ALTHOUGH I KNOW I WOULD NOTE
THAT ELEVEN THINGS ELEVEN SIXTY
ONE A LOT FOR THE MONITORING
OF. VOICE SERVICES SO I STILL.
EVEN UNDER PRESSURE PRIOR LIFE
IT SEEMS LIKE THERE WAS A
ABILITY COLLECT SOME DATA BUT
DO YOU ANTICIPATE AND I'M ON
THE FOLKS WHO WOKE UP TO A FIRE
IN THEIR BACKYARD- HAVE A WEEK
FOR MY WEAPON. WHATEVER YOU
KNOW YOU PLAN AROUND THOSE
THINGS YOU WAKE UP TO SMOKE I
HAVE NO CELL PHONE RECEPTION ON
THE MOUNTAIN ROAD I'M ON. BUT
THE LOOK THEY GET MY CAR AND
GET OUT OF THERE- NOT EVERYONE
IS AS LUCKY. AND HAS THOSE
FACULTIES OUR ABILITIES- AND MY
VOICE OVER IP SERVICE WAS DOWN.
SO DO YOU NEED MORE THORNY FROM
US TO COLLECT THE DATA REQUIRED
IS SORT OF IDENTIFY THE
VULNERABLE. SPOTS WITHIN THE
NETWORKS BOTH ON I. P. LANDLINE
AND WIRELESS OR DO YOU NEED
EXIT. ADDITIONAL STATUTORY
AUTHORITY THING TO GO. AT LEAST
AT LEAST ASSESS THE RISK AS
ACCURATELY AS POSSIBLE AND IS
GRANULAR LEE AS WE NEED TO.
MEET ALL THESE CONCERNS AS
SENATOR STERN. ONE OF THE MAJOR
IMPEDIMENTS TO OUR ABILITY TO
COLLECT DATA WAS SECTION SEVEN
TEN. BECAUSE THE INDUSTRY
ARGUED REPEATEDLY AND
FREQUENTLY THAT WE HAD NO
AUTHORITY OVER VOIP OR I. P.
SERVICES AND SO THEREFORE WE
HAVE NO RIGHT TO COLLECT THE
DATA WE DISAGREED WITH THAT
ASSESSMENT NONE THE LESS IT WAS
A ROAD BLOCK FREQUENTLY NOW
THAT SEVEN TEN IS. A SUNSET IT
OPENS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
BE MORE. AGGRESSIVE IN SEEKING
DATA AND HOPEFULLY GETTING IT.
AT LAST QUESTION IS. WERE
FOCUSED IN TELECOMMUNICATIONS
OUTAGES. BACKUP POWER ISSUES
BUT GOOD TAKING US BACK TO THE
FALL AND OUR LAST OVERSIGHT
HEARING YOU A BETTER SENSE NOW
ON TIMING FOR THE ROOT CAUSE
BUT WHAT I WOULD. ABOUT HIS
ROUTE BECAUSE THE ROOT CAUSE
WHICH CLIMATE CHANGE THEN WE
GET TO PS PS HOW CAN WE
MEDICAID AT LEAST THAT RISK THE
P. S. P. S. RISK WHERE. FRANKLY
BLIGHTED TELCO FOLKS EVEN GOT
HAD FAKED- ABOUT WHERE WAS
GOING TO BE AND THEY THEY PUT
ASSETS TO THE WRONG PLACES-
SOME IT WAS OUT OF THEIR HANDS.
HOW FAR ALONG ARE YOU IN-
LAYING OUT THOSE NEW YOU
MENTION YOUR NEW PROTOCOLS ARE
YOUR NEW REQUIREMENTS WHAT WERE
WE IN THAT PROCESS AND IN AND
OUT. THANK YOU MISTER THANK YOU
SENATOR WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT PROCEEDING BUT ON I HAVE.
IN BOTH IT IS IT TOO HEARINGS
IN NOVEMBER AND DECEMBER
MENTION THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE TO DO. IS THE I'LL
HAVE TO BETTER COMMUNICATE WITH
THE TELCOS. A TWO YEAR VERY
POINT. TELL BECAUSE DIDN'T
INFORMATION IN SOME CASES IT'S
COMES VERY LATE. ANY NINE ON
HOW THE PS PS IS ADMINISTERED.
AND ADMINISTER THEM DIFFERENTLY
ASIAN NOW- IT. ONE OF THE I USE
FOR EXAMPLE DOESN'T REALLY-
DECIDE WHEN THE PSP IS GONNA
CURRENT TELL- LESSON IN SOME
CASES COUPLE HOURS BEFORE. SO
THAT DOES PUT. DIFFICULTIES ON-
THE TELCOS FOR EXAMPLE AND
WHERE THEY NEED TO DEPLOY
GENERATORS FOR EXAMPLE THAT WAS
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE. BUT. SO ONE OF THE
THINGS I DID WANT TO MENTION IN
TERMS OF TIMING- WE'D JUST
YESTERDAY STARTED GETTING BACK-
THE- PARTIES TO THE
PROCEEDINGS- THAT I MENTIONED
IN MY TESTIMONY THE DEVELOPING
OF THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
RESILIENCY INDEPENDENT. A
DEPENDABLE COMMUNICATIONS GRID
OF FOR FURTHER SO WE CAN
FURTHER ADDRESS A COMMUNICATION
OUT JUST DURING A MARCH THE WE
JUST. THE DEADLINE FOR THOSE
COMMENTS WAS YESTERDAY SO STAFF
IS JUST NOW GOING THROUGH THOSE
COMMENTS WHICH WILL HELP. FOR
ME AND THE A. L. J. INFORM THE
SCOPE IN MEMEL WHICH WILL
INDEED COM MISTER CHAIRMAN
IMMEDIATELY. AND SENATOR I
THINK BLANK MY COLLEAGUE
COMMISSIONER REX OFTEN DID YOU
WANT TO KNOW OKAY SORRY CENTER
DOT. YEAH NUMBER MY QUESTIONS
OF ALREADY BEEN ASKED- ANSWERED
SO I APPRECIATE- MY COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING FIRST I DO
I DO WANT TO MAKE CLEAR BECAUSE
I THINK IT'S FAIR. THAT THE-
THE TELECOMS AT LEAST IN THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN FIRES-
IN THE NORTH BAY WERE EMBEDDED
IN EVERY EMERGENCY- MEETING NOT
THAT I WAS PLEASED WITH THE
RESULTS. BUT THEY WERE THERE
THEY WERE THERE ON THE GROUND
THEY WERE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN. AND I THINK THAT WE-
HELLO. IT'S BEEN MET. WHO'S AT
FAULT HERE AND THE OF THIS OLD.
HILL WE'VE ALL TALKED ABOUT TE
NEW NORMAL A NEW PARADIGM. I
DON'T KNOW FOR EXAMPLE IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WE BLAME FIRST
RESPONSE AND WHAT'S HAPPENED. I
DON'T KNOW WHO COULD FOR
SEEING. ALL THESE CATACLYSMIC
EVENTS THAT THE STATE IS- FACED
OVER THE LAST THREE TO THE
THREE TO FOUR YEARS. YES
SERIOUSLY IT'S IT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT. SO I DON'T KNOW
EVEN THE TELECOMS EVER THOUGHT
ABOUT SEVENTY TWO HOURS OF
BACKUP POWER FOR EXAMPLE- TO
HELP COMMUNITIES WHAT ONE THING
FOR SURE I REALLY DO BELIEVE
THAT- WHEN THIRTY THREE
COUNTIES ARE ALL SUDDEN CUT
OFF- I DON'T THINK THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANY
COULD EVER UNDERSTOOD. YOU KNOW
WHAT WAS GOING ON WITH P.
DECISIONS THE POWER OFF SO MANY
COUNTIES ALL ONCE I THINK
THOUGH THAT THAT GET OUT OF
JAIL FREE CARD- IS IT IS MAY BE
NECESSARY IN SOME RESPECTS WITH
THE TELECOMS- I THINK THEY NEED
TO BE PUT ON NOTICE THAT. THIS
IS A PARTNERSHIP FOR THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR ALL OUR
RESPECTIVE TAXPAYERS AND
THEY'VE GOT TO STEP UP TO THE
TAPE PLATE THEY'VE GOT TO START
IVING US THE INFORMATION
THEY'VE GOT A QUICK PLAY
DEFENSE AUDIO ON THE ACT IT
LEAST ON THAT- THE ASPECT. I
GUESS ON THE ENERGY THEY WHAT
WHAT ONE OF THE THINGS I KNOW
THAT WE GOT COMPETING GOALS WE
TALK ALL THE TIME ABOUT WE NEED
MORE OF RURAL. INTERNET SERVICE
IN THEM. BUT WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ALSO. YOU'RE KEEPING THIS
LAND LINE FOREVER LET ME TELL
YOU MY WIFE IS A PROPONENT OF
KEEPING THE LAND LINE FOR EVER.
DID YOU KNOW I JUST THINK IT'S
FRANKLY RIDICULOUS BUT THAT'S-
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING. HAPPY
WIFE HAPPY LIFE SHOULD HAVE IT.
THE CALLER RIGHT NOW WITH THE
LISTENING TO THE HEARING. BUT
THAT SAID. WE REALLY DO HAVE TO
DISCUSS THESE OR INVESTMENT
GOING TO BE IN THE LAND
LIGHTING KEEPING THE LAN LINE
FOR EVER OR ARE WE GOING TO
DEMAND THE INVESTMENTS IN RURAL
AREAS FOR THE INTERNET AND
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE AND I
THINK THAT THESE THESE ISSUES
GET CONFLATED ALL THE TIME AND
WE'RE ASKING FOR INVESTMENTS IN
BOTH YEAH THERE WAS SUCH A
THING AS A TRACK- TAPE CASSETTE
TAPES YOU KNOW THEY WERE VIDEO
STORES AT ONE POINT IN TIME YOU
KNOW TECHNOLOGY CHANGES. PEOPLE
NEED TO CHANGE- I DON'T HAVE
ALL THE ANSWERS HERE BUT THE I
THINK THAT'S UP WE NEED TO
CONSIDER AS POLICY MAKERS AND I
WILL BE ASKING YOU KNOW WHAT
YOUR THOUGHTS ARE ON THAT BUT
MORE TARGETED YOU DID MENTION-
THE- THE COMMUNICATION SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE TREATED SHOULD BE
TREATED AS PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNERS DURING PS PSP EVENTS
SB NINE OH ONE REQUIRED THAT.
IT ALSO- CODE SECTION EIGHTY
EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY SIX YEAH
SAID CONSIDER PUBLIC SAFETY
IMPACTS ON COMMUNICATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IT ALSO SAID
INCLUDE PROCEDURES FOR DIRECT
NOTIFICATION OF OPERATORS OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE IT'S SO I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS ALSO WHAT IS THE
C. P. SEAT- GONNA DO IN THAT
REGARD TO MAKE SURE THAT THE I.
O. U.'S. IS SPECIFICALLY. FOR
ME P. JEANNIE OR TREATING
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
PROVIDERS AS PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNERS IN PROVIDING PRIORITY
NOTICE A PS BSE DEBTS. WE
CERTAINLY RAISED THAT DIRECTLY
WITH THE I. O. U.'S- I HAVE IN
IN THE HEARINGS THAT I HELD
AFTER- THE OCTOBER NOVEMBER
EVENT DIRECTLY WITH P. JEANNIE
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WAS
MISSING WAS THE COMMUNITY. THE
PROPER COMMUNICATION WITH THE
TELCO COMPANIES- AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO- AS WE GO THROUGH
OUR PS PS- PROCEEDING WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HIGHLIGHT AND HOLD
ACCOUNTABLE. AS THE REGULATOR
THE I. O. U.'S. I THINK THE
ALLEN WANTED TO ANNOUNCE AN AS
YET SOMETHING ON THE ON YOUR
FIRST POINT YEAH CENTER I'M ONE
OF THOSE DIE HARD LAND LINE.
PHONE SERVICE PEOPLE AS WELL AS
I SAY THEY'LL HAVE TO PRY IT
OUT OF MY COLD DEAD FINGERS-
BUT- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE- ROBO
CALLS. WELL THAT'S TRUE THERE
IS AFTER YOU USE THE OLD
FASHIONED ANSWERING MACHINE TO
SCREEN THEM OUT. BY. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THE TRADITIONAL
WIRELINE TECHNOLOGY THAT THAT
THAT IS THE UNDERLYING
TECHNOLOGY PROVIDING THAT PHONE
SERVICE TO YOUR HOUSE AND TO
MINE IS ALSO RELYING ON FIND
MANY- SERVICES. FOR THAT HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE LAND
LINE PHONE SERVICE GOING YOUR
HOUSE THERE ARE IT'S ESSENTIAL
TO MANY SERVICES THAT ARE START
ARE PROVIDED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND- SO DO WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE. THAT PHONE
SERVICE TO EVERYBODY IN EVERY
REMOTE AREA THAT IS A POLICY
QUESTION THE COMMISSION WILL
HAVE TO LOOK AT ME WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WELL DO WE NEED
TO MAINTAIN THAT TECHNOLOGY FOR
SOME INDEFINITE PERIOD OF TIME
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE THAT FOR
SERVICES THAT DEPEND ON IT
THAT- SOMETHING OTHER THAN YOUR
PHONE IN MIND. YES THAT IS
GOING TO HAVE TO CONTINUE
BECAUSE SO MUCH DEPENDS ON IT
AND THE NETWORK IS ALL INTER
WOVEN SO NOT EITHER OR NO IT'S
NOT EITHER OR- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR MUCH SOONER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU. MY IS REALLY MORE OF
A COMMENT IN TERMS OF THE
LARGER PICTURE I TAKE MY
GUIDANCE FROM MY RECENT RE
READING OF CITIZENS AT ALL AND-
THE BIG PICTURE THINK IF YOU
WILL AYE AYE HE- THERE ARE
GOVERNMENT A LONG TIME. AND
MARBLE BOETTCHER IS PROBABLY
THE BEST PUBLIC SERVANT I'VE
EVER MET WHETHER IT'S IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OTHER STATES
THIS STATE PRIVATE SECTOR.
EXTRAORDINARY AND I WAS STROKES
ECSTATIC WHEN YOU BECAME THE
PRESIDENT OF THIS ORGANIZATION
BUT I. DIGITAL WORRIED THAT-
YOU'RE THE PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA PHOTO MATCH. IN THE
SENSE THAT AND YOU KIND OF
TALKED ABOUT IT IN THE SENSE
THAT. EVERYBODY HERE IS TRYING
TO SOLVE A PROBLEM. THE
ANALYSIS TALKS ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES TO RENT AND LIMIT
THE CURRENTS AND IMPACT FUTURE
OUTAGES WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE
ABOUT. YOUR TESTIMONY YOU
TALKED ABOUT. WE HAVE
PROCEEDINGS I CAN'T TALK ABOUT
IT BECAUSE IT'S PREJUDICE
BECAUSE MIGHT BE PREJUDICED THE
PROCEEDING. IN OTHER WORDS. THE
RAILROAD COMMISSION WHICH IS
WHAT YOU RUN BASICALLY. AND
I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS IN
HEARINGS FOR MANY YEARS. IT'S
JUST YESTERDAY'S NEWS AND
PROCTER OF IT IN TERMS OF
YOU'VE GOT THIS NEW DYNAMIC OF
A NEW WORLD ORDER THINGS THAT
WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT CENTER
BRADFORD TALKING ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND TEN WE CAN USE SO MANY
EXAMPLES THROUGHOUT HISTORY. OF
WHAT WE SOUGHT TO DO THE ENERGY
CRISIS EXAMPLE AFTER EXAMPLE.
I'M JUST FEARFUL THAT WE HAVE
GOOD PEOPLE OF GOOD WILL AROUND
THIS DíAS PEOPLE OF GOOD WILL
IN THE MINISTRATION TRYING TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM BUT WE ARE
TRYING TO. SOLVE THE PROBLEM
WITH PHOTO MATT BLOCKBUSTER AND
A DIAL NOTARY PHONE. AND THE
REALITY IS THAT IF AT THE END
OF THE DAY THE QUESTION SHOULD
BE NOT WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO
PENALIZE PEOPLE MORE OR WILL WE
COLLECT DATA I HEAR THE STORIES
ABOUT DATA. AND SAYING OKAY
WE'RE GONNA PASS A BILL THAT WE
CAN COLLECT DATA TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND BY THE TIME WE GET TO
THE THAT'S TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA DO THIS
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA START
PROCEEDING. THE REALITY IS WE
HAVE TO AS IN OUR SYSTEM AS-
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
PAPA PAGE TO PREVENT AND LIMIT
OCCURRENCES IMPACT FUTURE AT
FUTURE OUTAGES. THE QUESTION IS
CAN WE STEP BACK FOR A MOMENT.
AND LOOK AT THE NEW WORLD ORDER
THAT WE LIVE IN THE NEW DYNAMIC
WE HAD ALWAYS PRIVACY
DISCUSSIONS WITH SENATOR.
JACKSON ABOUT ALL THE CREEPY
STUFF THAT GOES ON. IN THE
PRIVACY WORLD THERE'S SO MANY
FUNDAMENTAL CHANGES I MEAN THIS
WHOLE TELEPHONE BUSINESS. YOU
KNOW I STILL HAVE A ROTARY
PHONE. IT'S IN MY MUSEUM BUT I
DON'T USE IT BUT THE POINT IS
THAT I MEAN MEMBERS THE KIDS
SO. THE QUESTION IS WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE AND I'M JUST A
LITTLE AFRAID THAT THIS
CONVERSATION IS INFORMED BY THE
ECONOMY. ON THE ONE HAND THE
SURPLUS OF URGENCY. THAT ALL OF
US ARE HONORABLY INFORMED BY
EVERYONE OF US EVERY ONE OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR YOU. ON
THE ONE HAND AND ON THE OTHER
HAND ALL AND EVEN THOUGH THIS
OLD CRUSTY MODEL THAT WE HAVE
TO HAVE THE PROCEEDINGS. AND
HEARINGS AND A. L. JAY'S. ALL
THIS GARBAGE THAT WORK WHEN WE
HAD A RAILROAD AND A DIFFERENT
WORLD. BUT I'M NOT SO SURE THAT
IF THE CHIEFS THE DELIVERABLES
SO I'M JUST WORRIED THAT WE'RE
BUILDING ON QUICKSAND. AND THAT
WE'RE BUILDING ON IT YOU KNOW
WE'RE WE'RE ALL CRAMMING.
FORMAT SHOPS AND TRYING TO FIX
THAT PROBLEM RATHER THAN
STEPPING BACK FOR A MOMENT BE
INFORMED BY THE CHALLENGE
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM WE'RE TRYING
TO SOLVE. AND THEN THINKING
THROUGH NOT BEING LIMITED BY
THE STRUCTURE. BECAUSE I THINK
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THIS
DESTRUCTIVE DISCUSSION I LOVE
WHEN USED TO IT I CAN'T TALK
ABOUT THE PROCEEDINGS BECAUSE I
GET PRE JUDGE. WE TALKS ABOUT
YOU KNOW I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE A
MAGIC WAND. MY QUESTION IS I
WROTE DOWN GIVE YOU A MAGIC
WAND. I TRUST YOU EXCELLENT
WHAT'S THE MAGIC WAND BUT THE
MAGIC ON TO ME IS NOT INFORMED
BY THE D. THOUGH GIVING MORE
AUTHORITY THE IDEAS THE TALKED
ABOUT NEW AUTHORITY OVERSIGHT
AND PENALTIES THAT YESTERDAY'S
NEWS THIS IS THE NEW TECHNOLOGY
IS GOING TO BE GONE AND OUT THE
DOOR BEFORE WE IN IMPLEMENT A
REGULATIONS LET'S FIGURE OUT
WHAT THAT NEW WORLD ORDER LOOKS
LIKE THAT WE CAN GIVE YOU THAT
MAGIC WAND SO THAT WE PROMOTE
INNOVATION PROMOTE EQUITY AND
FAIRNESS AND TAKE CARE OF THE
RULE PEOPLE IN ALL THE OTHER
CHALLENGE THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH. AND THAT'S WHAT I DO SO
BUT I WANT TO SUGGEST TONIGHT
OBVIOUSLY HAVE NO ANSWER I JUST
WANTED TO POSE IT TO TRY TO
INFORM CALIFORNIA THIS GREAT
PLACE OF CALIFORNIA THIS PLACE
IF YOU READ CITIZENS BILL IS
ALL ABOUT THE FUTURE I GOT UP
TO CUBA ON MY WALL AND I WAS
JUST CALL THE NEW SOME TEQUILA
HE WAS CALLED THE OLD ONE SAID
WHEN HE WAS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
IT'S AT THE NEW ONE SAYS FUTURE
MAN THE FUTURE ME. THANKS TO
TALKING ABOUT THE FUTURE COSTS
NOW I WANT TO TRY TO ENGAGE
THAT OUR DISCUSSION AS WE THINK
THROUGH GOING SPORT THANK YOU.
IN A ROOM. THROW SOME. ALSO YOU
MAKE REFERENCE TO SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE HERE SO I'M SORRY
BECAUSE I THINK YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT IT BUT I JUST KIND OF
WANT TO BRING IT BACK TO US AT
THE MENTION THE REPORT THAT I
HAVE YOU BEEN BREAKING DOWN A
LITTLE BIT THROUGHOUT IT YOU
CALLED AT THE NET NETWORK
EXAMINATION REPORT I WANT TO
JUST FOCUS A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THAT IF YOU CAN AND OPERATE.
FIRST OF ALL WANT TO KNOW IT'S
A PUBLIC DOCUMENT THAT WE CAN
REVIEW SECONDLY ARE YOU
CREATING A STRATEGIC PLAN TO
TACKLE ALL THE FINDINGS IN THAT
REPORT I WANT TO KNOW LONG TERM
SHORT TERM GOALS ON AND IT GOES
BACK TO- WHAT SENATOR HERTZBERG
WAS TALKING ABOUT I WANT TO
KNOW THAT THERE'S IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES BECAUSE HE'S RIGHT IN
THAT WE HAVE INFORMATION AND
THEN IT KIND OF GOES. IT TAKES
A LONG TIME TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES IN MY TIME WE GET TO
THEM IT'S ALREADY A NEW ISSUE
VERSUS THE OLD ISSUE SO CAME TO
SHARE A LITTLE BIT OF HARD
GONNA TACKLES FINDINGS AND NOW
REPORTED IT CAN WE HAVE ACCESS
TO IT THANK YOU SENATOR THE WE
RELEASED A SUMMARY AND REDACTED
PORTIONS OF THE REPORT THOSE OR
A WEBSITE OF COURSE WILL WILL.
BE HAPPY SHERRY SHARE THEM WITH
YOU WE'VE BEEN IN A FIGHT OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL MONTHS WITH
EIGHTEEN T. IN FRONT HERE OVER
MAKING THE REQUEST OF THE
PUBLIC THEY BOTH FIRED OF
CONFIDENTIALITY CLEAN WHICH WE
WERE QUITE BEING BUT WE WERE
REQUIRED BY STATUTE I WHO
DETERMINE WHAT THE TO
CONFIDENTIAL FOR YOU. WITH
THAT. CLAIM IS DOING. PORT
SHOULD BE MADE PUBLIC. THE
FINDINGS IN SUMMARY OUR ON OUR
WEBSITE SO WITH STRIVING TO
MAKE IT PUBLIC AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN. IN OUR INTENT IS TO DO
JUST WHAT YOU SAID TO FOLLOW
UP. ON THE- FIND OUT OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND TO GO
THROUGH OUR PROCESS. AND FOR
DETERMINE WHAT SPORT WHAT STEPS
DO WE NEED TO TAKE TO WE NEED
TO CHANGE THE EXISTING SERVICE
QUALITY RULES WE HAVE THREE
MAJOR RULES THAT I MENTIONED
ARE THEY ENOUGH TO THEY NEED TO
BE STRENGTHENED DO THEY NEED TO
BE EXTENDED TO DIFFERENT
SERVICE PROVIDERS WE HAVE A
SCHEME. IN PLACE FOR PENALIZING.
VIOLATIONS IS THAT THE RIGHT
SCHEMES IS THE- MORE PENALTIES
APPROPRIATE OR ARE. THE OTHERS
ARE THIS THE OF A FOCUSED ON
THE RIGHT AREAS AND SO FORTH
AND SO ON. AND WE WILL. WE WILL
MOVE EXPEDITIOUSLY IN THAT AREA.
THE WE ARE STILL TAKING ACTION
TO TRY TO BRING THE CARRIERS
INTO COMPLIANCE. AND NOT
WITHSTANDING THE FACT THAT THIS
NETWORK EXAMINATION HAS NOT
BEEN PUBLICIZED. THE TWO FILE
QUARTERLY REPORTS AS I
MENTIONED AND IF THEY'RE OUT OF
COMPLIANCE THE TO EITHER PAY OF
A PENALTY OR MAKE A AND
INVESTMENT TWICE THE AMOUNT OF
PENALTY IN LIEU OF THAT. THAT
FIGHT. THANK YOU AND THE REASON
I'M A LITTLE FRUSTRATED BECAUSE
AS YOU CAN HEAR EVERYONE UP
HERE IS REALLY WANTS TO BE
HELPFUL AND FIND SOLUTIONS
ALONG WITH YOU ON THE CARRIERS
BUT- ALMOST FEELS LIKE WE HAVE
PIECES OF INFORMATION RACES
THAT. THE WHOLE PIECE AND WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
SOMEHOW FIND THAT FULL PICTURE
SO THAT WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
SOME POLICY WHERE WE CAN BE
HELPFUL TO YOU BUT- THANK YOU
FOR SHARING THAT I JUST WANTED
OF. CLARITY ON THAT IT WILL
TAKE THEM HAVE THE MIKE THE
CENTER HERTZBERG WE I- WE
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERNS AND
FRUSTRATIONS AND I KNOW YOU'VE
HAD DIALOGUES WITH. OTHER
COMMISSIONERS PRESIDENT PICKER
ABOUT THIS ISSUE. WE HAVE BEEN
ENGAGED IN AN EFFORT
ADMINISTRATIVELY OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS THAT WE'RE
CONTINUING TO TRY TO MAKE OUR
PROCEEDINGS. QUICKER MORE
EFFECTIVE MORE TRANSPARENT.
WE'RE WE'RE PROPOSING A SET OF
RULES CHANGES WE'VE HAD SOME
WORKSHOPS ABOUT THAT RIGHT NOW.
MUCH OF WHAT YOU TALK ABOUT THE
MORE FUNDAMENTAL REFORMS NEED
STATUTORY CHANGE. WITH THE KIDS
TO BUT BY STATURE WE HAVE TO
PROCEED IN THE WAY WE DO. SO WE
WOULD WELCOME YOUR ENGAGEMENT
AND HELP IN THAT AREA THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR HILL THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND LIKE THANK
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
GREAT QUESTIONS TODAY HAD USE
JUST. PHENOMENAL DISCUSSION AND
THANK YOU PRESIDENT IN. AND
COMMISSIONER FOR YOUR
INVOLVEMENT ONE HERE LEADERSHIP
BECAUSE I THINK THAT'S BEEN THE
KEY. SINCE YOUR APPOINTMENTS-
TO THE COMMISSION AND I THINK
WE'VE ALL IS SENATOR HERTZBERG
INDICATED. FEEL A SENSE OF
RELIEF THAT THERE IS STRONG
LEADERSHIP THERE THAT'S GOING
TO TAKE US TO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY AND BRING IT INTO THE
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY MADE. THE
COMMENT AND SENATOR HERTZBERG
AND- BECAUSE YOU JUST MADE THE
ISSUE RAISED THE ISSUE OF. DUE
PROCESS THE TIMELINESS OF
PROCEEDINGS TO CHALLENGES AND I
KNOW A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO I
HAD. LEGISLATION DEALING WITH
THE CONFIDENTIALITY OF SOME OF
THE- REPORTS IN THE COMMISSION
OF THE UTILITIES AND- THE
TELECOMS AND HOW CHALLENGING
THAT HAS BEEN. BECAUSE THEY
CLAIM EVERYTHING IS
CONFIDENTIAL AND THEN IT'S UP
TO US TO FIGHT IN THE- THE
CRIMINAL ASPECTS OF RELEASING
THAT INFORMATION IS SOMETHING
THAT WE TRIED TO CHANGE AS
WELL. SO IDEA WHAT MY
SUGGESTION IS AS YOU GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS WITH THE- THE
LANDS OF EXPEDITING. AS BEST AS
POSSIBLE BASED THE CONSTRAINT.
IN THIS BUDGET TO. CONSTRUCT
YOU HAVE. PLEASE CONFIRM. MAKE
THOSE NOTES OF WHERE THOSE
CHANGES WOULD BE MOST
EFFECTIVE. TO BRING THE
COMMISSION TO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY TO THAT WE CAN DEAL
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE. AND THEN
COME TO THE BUDGET. AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT. THOSE THOSE
CHANGES MAKE THIS A MORE NIMBLE
AND- FUNCTIONAL AGENCY THAT YOU
HAVEN'T COMMISSION SO PLEASE.
LET US KNOW. IF YOU NEED HELP
WITH THAT WE WILL INDEED I. AM.
AT AS I THINK OF THE SENATOR
CENTER HERTZBERG- SORT OF
ALLUDED TO I WILL NOT TAKE.
THAT PHRASE I'M LESS
OVERWHELMING TO ME THANK YOU
AND I HOPE YOU CAN SAY IT SIX
MONTHS FROM NOW TO. BUT IT IS A
I WILL TELL YOU PERSONALLY IT'S
BEEN AB AND I HAVEN'T. I
HAVEN'T BEEN THROUGH A LOT OF
THE AND PROCESSES YET. BUT IT
WE DO OPERATE A PRETTY ARCHAIC
SYSTEM AND- THANK GOODNESS TO
COMMISSION WRECK SHAMAN AND
COMMISSIONER RANDALL FOR DOING
TACKLING SOME OF THE REFORMS
THAT THEY'VE TACKLED. AND WE'RE
STILL WORKING THROUGH THOSE AND
I COMING OUT OF GOV OP
SECRETARY GOV UPSETS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT GOVERNOR BROWN IT.
AND ALSO- NEWSHAM A CHARGE ME
WITH AMOUNTS REFORMING
GOVERNMENT AND REALLY REFORM IN
PROCESS THIS IS WHAT I ALWAYS
USED TO SAY NOT MAKING THINGS
MORE EFFICIENT BUT ACTUALLY
REFORM IN THE PROCESS. IT'S
WHAT I'VE- IT'S WHAT I'VE-
REALLY DEVOTED A LOT OF MY
PUBLIC SERVICE TO. SO I REALLY
AGREE WITH- CENTER HERTZBERG-
OBSERVATION THAT WE ARE
REGULATOR REGULATING. FOR THE
LAST CENTURY NOT THE CURRENT
CENTURY. TO CHANGE THIS S.
SPEAKING ABOUT PARTNERSHIPS TO
CHECK MAKE THE CHANGES- TO THE
PROCESS CITIES OF THE
COMMISSION WILL TAKE ALL WILL
TAKE A PARTNERSHIP THE P. C.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE
LEGISLATURE AND I AM LOOKING AT
OUR OWN PROCESSES WHICH WE ARE
DOING AND WE'VE ALREADY MADE
SOME CHANGES- I THINK THAT
CENTER RICKSHAW OF IT
COMMISSION WRECK SHOT AND-
MENTIONED EARLIER. THAT WE-
THROUGH A VERY EXPEDITED
PROCESS TO IMPLEMENT THE LAW A
WILDFIRE AND PROTOCOLS FROM
AND- TEN FIFTY FOUR AND NINE A
ONE. AND WORK WERE GOING WHERE
YOU IT AS OUT ROCK GOING WHERE
WILL THEY WERE BROWN TYLER SO
IF WE CAN TAKE GENERAC
PORTABLES STOPPED HIM SORRY BUT
NOW WE DO HAVE STILL MORE
MEMBERS ON THE- KIßM SORRY IN
A WORLD WILL. TAKE YOUR ANSWERS
CENTER MONEY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN NO. WE'VE GOT MANY
WAITING ON IMPORTANT PANEL IT
WE HAVE A LONG AGENDA SO AND WE
WILL HAVE THE PRAISES OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND DIRECT
MY QUESTION. I THINK THE
COMMISSIONERS COMMISSION
MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE I THINK
MY QUESTIONS PRIDE BEST
DIRECTED- TO COMMISSIONER.
WRECK SCHAFFEN- IT RELATES TO
LAND LINES AND WHILE MANY I
THINK FEEL. WE NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH NEW TECHNOLOGIES
AND INVEST IN THE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES I REPRESENT
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE DEPENDENT
ON THEIR LAND LINE IT'S THEIR
ONLY CONNECTION- IN TIMES OF
EMERGENCY. AND OUR LAND LINE
ACTUALLY WORKS WHEN WE LOSE OUR
POWER SO WE CAN STILL MAKE A
NINE ONE ONE CALL USING FIELD
LAND LINE SO THERE'S A
REDUNDANCY BENEFIT THEIR TO
SOME CONSUMERS- DURING TIMES OF
CRISIS MY QUESTION. YOU TALKED
TO THERE'S A PATCHWORK
AUTHORITY IN JURISDICTIONS AND
PEOPLE ARE FIGHTING OVER THIS
AUTHORITIES IN JURISDICTIONS IT
SEEMS CLEAR THAT THE P. YOU SEE
DOES HAVE AUTHORITY OVER LAND
LINE REPORTING WHEN THERE IS A
LOSS OF SERVICE THAT'S PART OF
THE REPORTING OBLIGATION. AND
TIME FOR RESTORATION. THIS P.
UC'S AUTHORITY ALSO ALLOW WHEN
THERE'S A SERIES OF SLOW
RESPONSES TO REPLACING SERVICE.
TO REQUIRE THE INVESTMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE.
TO SPEED CITY DON'T HAVE
REPEATED LOSSES OF SERVICE
EVERY TIME. THERE'S AN OUTAGE I
WOULD SAY YES AND HELEN CAN
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG I WE
HAVE THE MOST PLENARY THE
CLEAREST AND MOST PLENARY
THIRTY OVER THE TRADITIONAL
LAND LINES SO IN OUR I WANT TO
HEAR YOUR ANSWER TO. SO MY
QUESTION GOES. IF A CERTAIN
PROVIDE. TELECOM PROVIDER ON
LAND IT'S LAND LINE SERVICE
CONTINUES TO SHOW AN INABILITY
TO RESTORE SERVICE. DOES THAT
OF THE WORDING INCLUDE
REQUIRING THAT THIS THERE'S
INVESTMENT IN IN THE ACTUAL
INFRASTRUCTURE- IF THEY'RE
GIVING THAT IS THE REASON THAT
THEY'RE LOSING THE SERVICE YES
SENATOR ARE STARTING DOES
INCLUDE THE ABILITY TO DO THAT
TO REQUIRE THE CARE TO MAKE
FURTHER INVESTMENT WE HAVE NOT
DONE THAT FOR SOME YEARS
BECAUSE OF THE WAY THEN.
NETWORK HAS IF. IN BUT WE HAVE
THAT AUTHORITY. BECAUSE I THINK
ONE OF OUR DILEMMAS THANK YOU
FOR THE ANSWER IS. THE TELECOM
COMPANIES WANT TO INVEST IN THE
FUTURE IN MORE. RADIO ERVICES-
CELL TOWERS THAT CENTRO BIT THE
PUBLIC SAFETY REQUIRES
MAINTAINING THAT LAND LINE
SERVICE. TO PEOPLE THAT ARE
DEPENDENT PARTICULARLY FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE SO I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF OUR CHALLENGES AS
PURCHASING THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I CAN CENTER MONEY
NO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE AND THEIR TESTIMONY
AND YOUR YOUR LAN ANSWERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT PANEL. WHICH
LOOKS AT THE IMPACTS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
WE HAVE. MARK YOU ARE DO CHI
HIS THE FROM THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES WITH STATE
CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO HAVE CHRIS
RILEY. HE IS- THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES MANAGER WITH MARIN
COUNTY. RIGHT AND IF THEY'RE
BOTH PRESENT IF YOU COULD COME
FORWARD. THANK YOU AND WELCOME
BACK. PLEASE SIR PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE WHEN YOU'RE READY ALL
RIGHT FULL GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE- MISS CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANKS FOR HAVING
ME HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
RESILIENCY OF OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION SYSTEMS MARK
RDG DIRECTOR OF THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
LET ME START OFF BY SAYING
THAT- THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
PATHWAYS OF TODAY THAT THOSE
PATHWAYS WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR THE WIRELESS AND
INTERNET OF THINGS. HAVE
EVOLVED TO BECOME VITAL
COMPONENTS TO OUR STATE'S
PUBLIC SAFETY SYSTEM. SO MANY
OF THE COMPONENTS OF
CALIFORNIA'S EMERGENCY RESPONSE
OPERATIONS ARE BECOMING HEAVILY
DEPENDENT UPON THESE
CAPABILITIES AS SUCH ALERT
MORNINGS SYSTEMS THAT ARE
PROVIDING LIFESAVING
NOTIFICATIONS TO THE PUBLIC AND
INFORMATION SHARING AND
DISSEMINATION CAPABILITIES THAT
ALLOW FOR REAL TIME FLOW. OF
DATA FROM THE FRONT LINES OF A
DISASTER TO DECISION MAKERS.
THE REALITY IS THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
THAT WE ARE DEPENDING ON
WHETHER THROUGH VOICE OVER IP
LAND LINE CELLPHONE TV OR
COMPUTER ARE NOW REALLY
ESSENTIAL AND CRITICAL LIFELINE
SERVICES. YET AS A AND C. AND
THE RELIABILITY OF THE SYSTEMS
ARE INCONSISTENT OR SIMPLY
ABSENT WITH WHAT IS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE. THE DELIVERY OF THE
ESSENTIAL LIFELINE CAPABILITIES.
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS WE KNOW
WE'VE HAD NUMEROUS OCCASIONS
WHERE NATURAL AND HUMAN CAUSED
DISASTERS HAVE RESULTED IN
FAIRS WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THESE.
AND I'VE TESTIFIED ON THE OF
THE OF THE FINDINGS IN THE
FACTUAL DATA THAT WE HAVE SEEN
BUT I WANT TO LOOK FORWARD I
WANT TO TALK ABOUT THAT TODAY
I'LL SEND SOME CONTEXT. OF
WHERE WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO-
TO BE ABLE TO FRAME. FOR IN THE
EFFORT. DURING THE TWO THOUSAND
ON THE OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN PS PS ADVANCE. REALLY
A WORST CASE SCENARIO EMERGED
AS THE AS LARGE REGIONS OF THE
STATE'S WERE DEALING. WITH THE
MULTI DAY PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
SHUT OFFS COMBINED WITH A RED
FLAG WHETHER. AND SEVERAL FIRES
BROKE OUT. AS A ESULT OF THE
OUTAGES HUNDREDS OF CELL SITES
AND DATA LINES HAD LOST POWER.
MOST WITH INSUFFICIENT BACKUP
POWER OR NO BACKUP POWER AT
ALL. MANY CALIFORNIANS WERE
UNABLE TO COMMUNICATE GET
INFORMATION ABOUT EVCUATION
ROUTES OR OTHER LARGE OR
RECEIVE UPDATES ON PS PS OR
FIRE CONDITIONS. AND I WILL ONE
CENTERS AND HOSPITALS WERE
UNABLE TO PROCESS CRITICAL
DATER OR LEVERAGE IMPORTANT
RECORDS. TO AVOID REPEATING THE
SCENARIO. OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PARTNERS
BOTH WIRELESS AND CABLE NEED TO
PERFORM WHAT I BELIEVE. AND I
BELIEVE THERE ARE DOING THIS
NOW A COMPREHENSIVE GAP
ANALYSIS TO DEVELOP A STRATEGIC
PLAN TO RAPIDLY BUILD IN BOTH
RESILIENCY AND REDUNDANCY
THROUGHOUT THEIR SYSTEM. WE
BELIEVE THAT THE PROCESS OF
UPGRADING THE SYSTEM TO WHAT I
CALL PUBLIC SAFETY GRADE IS
PRIMARILY TO FULL INCREASING
DATA SHARING. AN INFRASTRUCTURE
HARDENING. IN THE AREA OF DATA
SHARING DURING DISASTERS LIKE
TELECOMMUTE Là DURING
DISASTERS THE- SERVICE
PROVIDERS HOLD KEY INFORMATION
CALAVERAS NEEDS IN ORDER TO
EFFECTIVELY RESPOND TO
EMERGENCIES. NO WE WENT AN
OUTAGE OCCURS ENABLES- WE ASKED
TO SHARE SUCH VALUABLE
INFORMATION WITH RESPONSE
AGENCIES IMPROVING THE ABILITY
TO MAKE DECISIONS. WHICH ARE
OFTEN LIFESAVING DECISIONS
BASED ON THAT ACTIONABLE DATA
THAT IS AVAILABLE. AT THE STATE
LOCAL LEVEL RAPIDLY KNOWING
WHEN AN OUTAGE HAS OCCURRED
INCREASES SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
AND FURTHER INFORMS AS WHEN
ALTERNATE FORMS OF
COMMUNICATION AND OR
NOTIFICATIONS ARE NEEDED.
ADDITIONALLY STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES CAN ASSESS WHETHER
COMMUNITIES ARE AT RISK OF
BEING UNABLE TO ACCESS NINE ONE
ONE SERVICE AND THEN WE CAN
IMPLEMENT APPROPRIATE
COUNTERMEASURES OR TAKE YOU SEE
BEING MANY. ACTIONS IN THE
PAST. THE INFORMATION WE NEED
HAS NOT BEEN EASILY OBTAINED
FROM THE SERVICE PROVIDERS
DURING THE RECENT. VAN WHAT ARE
WHAT OVER THIRTY COUNTIES LOST
POWER WE HAVE HAD DIFFICULTY
GETTING REQUIRED INFORMATION
FROM SEVERAL WIRELESS AND
WIRELINE PROVIDERS. NOT
LAUGHTER I PERSONALLY REACHED
OUT TO THEIR RESPECTIVE CEOS WE
ABLE TO GET THE DETAILS OUTAGE
INFORMATION NEEDED THAT WAS
ACTIONABLE AND RELEVANT. DURING
THE OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHT PS PS
A BAD FOR INSTANCE IT WAS
REPORTED THAT THREE POINT 3% OF
THE CELL TOWERS IN THE PS PS
AREAS WENT DOWN. WHILE THE
NUMBER DOES NOT SEEM
SIGNIFICANT AT FIRST CONSIDER.
THE LOCAL AREA SPECIFIC IMPACT
ABOUT THREE POINT 3% RESIDENTS
OF MARIN COUNTY AS YOU'VE HEARD
LOS CELLULAR SERVICE AND WE'RE
ABLE TO GET INFORMATION AS 57%
OF THE COUNTY CELL TOWERS WENT
OFFLINE. THIS WAS CHALLENGING.
THE ENDING THE P. S. P. S.
EVENT HOW DID THE INABILITY TO
GET INFORMATION ESSENTIAL
INFORMATION OUT BUT MARIN
COUNTY WAS A RECEIVING AND
SHELTERING COUNTY FOR CAN QUE
FIRED BACK YOU WE SEE. THE LACK
OF CELLULAR AND INTERNET
SERVICES CRIPPLED ESSENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS EXPONENTIALLY
COMPLICATING THE SITUATION. AT
PUT RIGHT LIVES AT RISK.
WITHOUT RAPIDLY RECEIVING
DETAIL AREA SPECIFIC OUTAGE
DATA CALLOW YES AND LOCAL
AGENCIES CANNOT TAKE THE
REQUIRED STEPS TO PUT ALTERNATE
COMMUNICATIONS IN PLACE. TO
ENSURE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. THERE
ARE OPPORTUNITIES HOWEVER FOR
IMPROVEMENT ALL AROUND. I'M
HAPPY TO SAY THAT SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND CAL WE **** HAVE
BEEN MEETING OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS TO ASSESS GAPS AND
DISCUSS IMPROVEMENTS THESE
MEETINGS HAVE BEEN BENEFICIAL
AND CONSTRUCTIVE AND WILL BE ON
GOING. AS WELL SB SIX SEVENTY
BY SENATOR MCGUIRE PASSED LAST
YEAR INSIDE BY THE GOVERNOR
SAYS FOR THE STARTING POINT FOR
OUTAGE INFORMATION SHARING
HELLO YES HAS RELEASED PROPOSED
REGULATIONS FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
THAT ESTABLISHES A REPORTING
THRESHOLD AND THE PROCESS BY
WHICH SERVICE PROVIDERS SHALL
REPORT. HE DRAFT REGULATIONS
WERE RELEASED FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ON DECEMBER TWENTIETH
AND WILL BE OPEN UNTIL FEBRUARY
FOURTH ANOTHER SOLUTION THAT
CALLOW YES PLEASE WOULD GREATLY
BENEFIT SHARING DURING
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS IS ANY
THING SIR PROVIDER
PARTICIPATION IN THE STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER DURING
EMERGENCY. WHEN THE STUDENTS
OPERATE CENTER ACTIVATION
SUPPORT UPPER TO SEE INCLUDING
PS PS HELLO YES NEEDS TO HAVE
SERVICE PROVIDER
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE SOCK
THAT CAN UNDERSTAND THE
SITUATION AND DIRECTLY AND
IMMEDIATELY PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION THE CAL WE **** ASK
FOR PROVIDER SHOULD ALSO
ESTABLISH A POINT OF CONTACT.
EITHER REGIONAL. AT THE
OPERATIONAL AREA LEVEL THAT CAN
BE USED BY EITHER HE'S HE'S OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHEN THEY
HAVE QUESTIONS CONCERNING
SERVICE OUTAGES. THESE LAYERS
ONS WILL BE IN A AN IMPROVEMENT
AND ALLOW FOR REAL TIME DATA
SHARING CRITICAL TO SUPPORTING
EMERGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE.
RESPONSE EFFORTS. THE OTHER
AREA INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENING.
EVERYTHING WE HAVE JUST BEEN
DISCUSSING IS REALLY AN OFF
SHOOT OF THE REAL PROBLEM DOWN
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES IN
A PERFECT WORLD. HE CAN WE CAN
IF WE CAN MITIGATE OUTAGES
THEMSELVES THE OUTAGE REPORTING
ISSUES BECOME LESS SIGNIFICANT
HOWEVER NOW CALIFORNIA HAS AN
URGENT NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEMS WE
DEPEND ON OUR BILL TO A
RESILIENT RELIABLE EVERY DONE
IN STANDARD. TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE SERVICE PROVIDERS CAN
DO THIS BY DEVELOPING AND
IMPLEMENTING A STRATEGIC PLAN
WORKING. IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE STATE THAT EXECUTES A
ROBUST INITIATIVE TO IDENTIFY
VULNERABILITIES HARDEN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND BUILD MORE
RESILIENT AND WE'VE DONE IT
SYSTEM. AS WELL SERVICE
PROVIDERS SHOULD NOT RELY ON A
PLAN THAT SIMPLY OUTLINES
PROCURING OUT OF STATE
GENERATORS ON THE FLY TO BE
BROUGHT IN DURING AN EMERGENCY.
BUT RATHER BY BUILDING IT BACK
UP POWER AT THAT IS CAPABLE OF
SUSTAINING THEIR SYSTEMS FOR
THREE TO SEVEN DAYS ENSURING
FOR ATTIC DEFENSIBLE SPACE
HARDEN BACKHAUL INFRASTRUCTURE.
SUCH AS FIBER BROADCAST
BROADBAND AND MICROWAVE AND
TAKING OTHER STEPS TO PROTECT
CELL SITES. IN HINDSIGHT I
BELIEVE THAT THESE COMPANIES
NOW UNDERSTAND THE REALITY OF
THE CASCADING CONSEQUENCES OF
MULTIPLE LARGE SCALE PS PS
ADVANCE AND THAT AN EFFORT TO
PROVIDE FOR TEMPORARY MOBILE
RESOURCES IS NOT ONLY CHALLENGE
IS SIMPLY INADEQUATE.
COMMUNICATIONS SITES MUST HAVE
PROPERLY SIZED PLACE GENERATORS
AND A REFUELING PLAN OR AN
ALTERNATE POWER SOURCE SUCH AS
SOLAR POWER WITH ADEQUATE
BATTERY BACKUP. DURING THE TWO
THOUSAND TEN NINETEEN P. S. P.
S. EVENTS IN OCTOBER OUTAGES
OUTLASTED MANY OF THE CELL
TOWERS EXISTING BACKUP CAPACITY.
AS WELL A LACK OF SUSTAINABLE
BACK CALL CONNECTIVITY IS
ANOTHER GAP. BACK CALL IS THE
CONNECTION FROM THE CELL SITE
TO THE CELLULAR NETWORK AND IS
REQUIRED FOR CELL SITES TO
FUNCTION MOST CELL SITES RELY
ON FIBER CONNECTIONS WHICH HAVE
SWITCHED WE HAVE SEEN DAMAGED
OR DESTROYED DURING A FIRE OR
AN EARTHQUAKE. BACKUP
CONDUCTIVITY WOULD TYPICALLY BE
PROVIDED VIA MICROWAVE
CONNECTIONS BUT MOST CELL SITES
DO NOT HAVE BACKUP MICROWAVE
FOR BACK CALL IN A RECENT
INCIDENT. A LACK OF REDUNDANCY
IN BACK CALL CREATED SEVERE
PROBLEM FOR THE SACRAMENTO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. ON THE
EVENING OF DECEMBER TWENTY
FIRST A DRIVER STRUCK A
TELEPHONE POLE THE SEVERED OF
FIBER CABLE MILES FROM THE
AIRPORT. OUTAGE HOWEVER LASTED
FOR TWENTY THREE HOURS BECAUSE
MANY FLIGHTS DELAYS AND LEAD TO
TWENTY CANCEL CANCELLATION
CANCELLED FLIGHTS. ON ONE OF
THE BUSIEST TRAVEL DAYS OF THE
YEAR MAYBE ONE OF YOU MAY HAVE
GOTTEN CAUGHT UP IN THAT. OKAY
HAVE THE AIRPORT MANAGEMENT
UNDERSTOOD THE LACK OF BOTH
RESILIENCY AND REDUNDANCY THEY
MAY HAVE UTILIZE MULTIPLE OTHER
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO AVOID SUCH
AN OUTAGE AS WELL. AND
UNDERSTANDING BY THE
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
THAT AN UNPROTECTED SINGLE
FIBER LINE TO CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE HAS EXTREME
VULNERABILITY IS UNACCEPTABLE
AND SPEAK TO MY FINAL POINT AND
THAT IS A LACK OF SITE
PROTECTION. LIKE THE EXAMPLES I
JUST PROVIDED SEVERAL
COMMERCIAL SITES SEVERAL
COMMERCIAL CELL SITES AND
CRITICAL FIBER LINES THAT
BURNED IN THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN FIRES WERE
LOCATED. ON THE SAME MOUNTAIN
TOP AS THE STATE'S PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS SITES.
INTERESTINGLY NONE OF THE
STATE'S PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS SITES BURN BUT
MANY AS MANY AS SIX OF THE
COMMERCIAL CELL SITES WERE TO
STORY. WE SUSPECT THAT THE GAPS
AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND OTHER
PREVENTABLE FACTORS CONTRIBUTED
TO THE VULNERABILITIES OF THESE
COMMERCIAL SITES LEADING TO THE
DESTRUCTION OF CRITICAL
COMMUNICATION SERVICES. AGAIN
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE
COOPERATIVELY WE CAN WORK TO
ACHIEVE WHAT IS NECESSARY. A
PUBLIC SAFETY GRAY COMMITTEE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEMS
SYSTEM THAT WILL ENSURE FOR
REDUNDANT AD RESILIENT AND
MOST IMPORTANTLY A RELIABLE
WIRELESS AND DATA
COMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM THAT WE
CAN THAT CAN WITHSTAND THE
RISKS WE FACE IN CALIFORNIA I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
OUR PARTNERS THE
TELECOMMUNICATION INDUSTRY. MY
WHOLE AGENCIES BEEN DIRECTED TO
WRAP AROUND AND FIND THE
SOLUTIONS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
GET THIS DONE- AND THROUGH A
SERIES OF METRICS AND TIME
FRAMES AND DELIVERABLES I
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN GET THERE
WITH NOT ONLY OUR PARTNERSHIP
WITH YOUR HELP AS WELL I THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OP TO SPEAK
ON THESE EVENTS BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF YOUR QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND SENATORS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK
TODAY ABOUT TOLD
TELECOMMUNICATION OUTAGES I AM
CHRIS RILEY ON THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES MANAGER. WITH THE
MARIN COUNTY SHERIFF'S OFFICE-
FIRST I JUST WANT TO COVER SOME
BACKGROUND OF OUR EXPERIENCES
AND I APOLOGIZE SO THIS IS
BEING COVERED BY THE DIRECTOR
AND OTHERS. BUT I JUST WANT TO
GIVE YOU A FLAVOR OF WHAT OUR
EXPERIENCES WERE IN IN MARIN
COUNTY AS YOU'RE LIKELY AWARE-
LATE LAST YEAR MARIN COUNTY
EXPERIENCE TO PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUTDOWNS. THOSE
SHUTDOWNS CAUSE
TELECOMMUNICATION OUTAGES IN A
SERIES OF CASCADING EVENTS. THE
FIRST P. AS PS WAS FROM OCTOBER
EIGHT TO TWELVE. AND THE SECOND
MORE SERIOUS EVENT FOR US- WAS
FROM OCTOBER TWENTY SIXTH TO
NOVEMBER FIRST. WHEN KENNEDY
WAS A LIKELY THE MOST
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED COUNTY IN
THE SECOND ADVENT. VIRTUALLY A
100% OF OUR COUNTY WAS WAS
WITHOUT POWER- THE PS PS TURNED
OFF POWER TO VIRTUALLY THE
ENTIRE COUNTY AS I STATED-
INITIALLY WE WERE NOTIFIED BY
P. JEANNIE THAT SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN. ONE HUNDRED AND
1-300-020-0200 TWENTY THREE
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS. IT WOULD
HAVE THEIR POWER SHUT DOWN FOR
ALMOST ONE WEEK- THAT NUMBERS
KIND OF MISLEADING BECAUSE IF-YOU THINK ABOUT IT THAT'S
REALLY TIMES THREE. WHICH IF
YOU DO THE MATH IS REALLY MORE
THAN OUR POPULATION SO. IT HAD
QUITE AN EFFECT ON US. QUITE
SEVERE. PRIOR TO THE SECOND
TIAS PAY US IS THE DIRECTOR'S
STATED AND OTHERS HAVE STATED.
KINCAID FIRE STARTED IN CINEMA
COUNTY DIRECTLY TO THE NORTH OF
MARIN. THE FIRE BURNED FROM
OCTOBER TWENTY THIRD TO
NOVEMBER SIXTH. IN A FIRE IN
THE P. S. P. S. MARIN COUNTY
PROVIDED MUTUALLY TO CINEMA IN
VARIOUS FORMS INCLUDING
PROVIDING MASCARA SHELTER- TO
ALMOST FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE IN
OUR MARIN CENTER AT THE
FAIRGROUNDS. THOSE PEOPLE AND
PETS QUITE OPERATION OUR COUNTY
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER WAS
ACTIVATED DURING THE DURATION
OF THE FIRE AND THE P. S. P. S.
AND IN OUR FUNCTION IS TO
SUPPORT FIELD OPERATIONS AND
COORDINATE RESOURCES WHICH WE
WERE DOING FOR VIRTUALLY TO
DISASTERS. AND I WILL TELL YOU
THAT THE LACK OF POWER IN THE
LACK OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS MADE
IT MORE DIFFICULT TO MANAGE THE
SHELTER OPERATION THAN THAN
WE'VE EVER SEEN EVEN MORE SO
THAN. TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHEN WE
DID THAT. THE SAME THING.
WITHIN A DAY OF THE PSP AS WE
STARTED LOSING
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICE
THROUGHOUT MARIN. THIS SERVICE
DISRUPTION WAS ACROSS THE
SPECTRUM. AS WE TALKED ABOUT
ALREADY TODAY WIRELESS VOICE
AND DATA WAS EITHER SLOW OR
NONEXISTENT. CABLE TV VOICE
OVER INTERNET PROTOCOL IN
INTERNET WAS OUT. WIRED AND
FIRED FIBER LINE PHONES AND
DATA WAS ALSO OUT OF VERY SLOW.
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN TOLD THE
TRADITIONAL COPPER LINE
TELEPHONE WOULD NEVER GO DOWN
AND MERGING SEE YET THAT WAS
NOT OUR EXPERIENCE AND I WAS
NOT THE EXPERIENCE OF OUR
RESIDENTS. MY OWN HOME WAS IT
HAS A- COPPER LINE. PHONE AND
IT WAS OUT FOR A WEEK SO THAT
WAS NOT GOOD- THE EDGES
CONTINUED FOR SEVERAL DAYS
UNTIL THE PSP HAS POWER
RESTORATION BEGAN. WE DID HAVE
SOME CONTACTS WITH THE INDUSTRY
SERVICE PROVIDERS- WE MADE
CONTACT WITH SOME OF THEM BUT
BASIC OF IT THE RESPONSE THAT
WE GOT WAS- YOU'RE GONNA GET
YOUR SERVICE BACK ON WHEN THE
POWER COMES BACK ON BECAUSE
WE'RE POWER DEPENDENT TO. SO
WHAT WERE THE IMPACTS TO PUBLIC
pSAFETY AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
I'D LIKE TO SHARE SOME OF OUR
DIRECT EXPERIENCES IN THE
COUNTY. AS I SAID OUR ROLE THAT
COUNTY OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES DURING THE RESPONSE
PHASE OF ANY DISASTER IS TO
SUPPORT FIELD OPERATIONS
COORDINATOR RESOURCES FROM OUR-
EOC AND ELSEWHERE CAN SHARE
INFORMATION. TWO OF OUR KEY
FUNCTIONS ARE ALERT AND
WARNING. AND PUBLIC INFORMATION
DISSEMINATION. WE USE MANY
DIFFERENT SYSTEMS AND PASSED TO
WARN AND SHARE INFORMATION WITH
THE PUBLIC. NOW IT IS A
MAJORITY OF THESE SYSTEMS RELY
ON TELECOMMUNICATIONS. WHEN
THEY'RE NOT WORKING WE CANNOT
WARN THE PUBLIC OF IMPENDING
DANGER. LIKEWISE THE PUBLIC MAY
NOT BE ABLE TO CALL OR TEXT FOR
HELP. WHEN TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SYSTEMS ARE DOWN WE ALSO CANNOT
COMMUNICATE EFFECTIVELY WITH
ALL THE PUBLIC SET TO RESPOND
HERS SO THAT'S WITHIN OUR
INDUSTRY SO TO SPEAK. AND THOSE
ASSISTING RESPOND HERS. WE ALSO
RELIANT TELECOMMUNICATIONS FOR
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS RESOURCE
MANAGEMENT. AND A COMMON
OPERATING PICTURE. BY THE
SYSTEM THAT WE USE IN
CONJUNCTION WITH CALLAWAY US-
AND EVEN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
IS A SYSTEM CALLED LIBYA SEE
KALLIO SEE FOR THE STATE- YOU
KNOW THAT SYSTEM. IS
INTERCONNECTED WITH THE STATE
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- AND
FEDERAL EMERGENCY MANAGERS
THROUGH THE INTERNET. SO THESE
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED BY TELL
COMMUNITY TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES. I AND WE NEED THIS
IS SERVICE TO BE RELIANT AND
REDUNDANT. YOU KNOW I REALLY
HAVE KIND OF A TOP THREE-
IMPACTS MAJOR IMPACTS OF THESE
OF THESE OUTAGES AND I MAY HAVE
MENTIONED SOME OF THEM A NUMBER
ONE REALLY IS PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS. YOU KNOW WE
HAVE RADIOS IN THOSE ARE
pALL THE OTHER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES FOR
COMMUNICATING WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THROUGHOUT FROM EOC
AND IN THE FIELD. THE LACK OF
WIRED AND CELLULAR BASE VOICE
SMS AND DATA COMMUNICATIONS AND
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED PUBLIC
SAFETY IS ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE. AND PROVIDE
CRITICAL SERVICES. NOWADAYS
MANY IMPOSED A MANY POLICE AND
FIRE AGENCIES USE MOBILE DATA
TERMINALS. THERE OFTEN THEY'RE
ALSO KNOWN AS ENTITIES. AND
THESE RUN ON CELLULAR DATA-
ALSO MORE AND MORE AGENCIES ARE
USING SMART PHONE BASED APPS
FOR THINGS LIKE DATABASE CHECKS
FOR. CRIMINALS ARE SUSPECTS LOS
PERSONS AND MEDICAL REPORTING
TO RECEIVING HOSPITALS. THE
SECOND AND PROBABLY THE MORE
IMPORTANT- OF FACTS NEGATIVE
EFFECT OF THE LACK OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES IS
THE LACK OF OUR ABILITY TO WARN
IN INFORM THOSE WITHIN OUR
COUNTY. WITH NO OR DEGRADED
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
WERE NOT ABLE TO WARN OR INFORM
THE PUBLIC VIA PHONE CALL TEXT
EMAIL OR WEBSITE. MANY OF OUR
SYSTEM SUCH AS WHAT WE CALL
MORAN WHICH IS A REVERSE NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM- OR IN ANOTHER
SYSTEM THAT WE USE WHICH IS AN
EXCELLENT SURE MOST OF YOU ARE
AWARE THAT THEY RELY ON VOICE
SMS EMAIL. APPLE OR OR A LINK
TO A WEBSITE TO PROVIDE FURTHER
INFORMATION. DURING THE RECENT
PS PS IS THAT OF AND
TELECOMMUNICATION FAILURES IT
AT THE END OF LAST YEAR. THE
MOST COMMON CONCERN AND
FEEDBACK THAT WE GOT FROM
PEOPLE IN MARIN COUNTY WAS. AND
THEY WERE PUBLIC YEAH CONSUMERS
OF OUR NEXT TO MESSAGES ON OUR
OTHER FRIEND MESSAGES WAS.
YOU'RE SENDING US INFORMATION
SOMETIMES THE TEXAS GETTING
THROUGH BUT WE OFTEN INCLUDE A
LINK TO A WEBSITE AND OF COURSE
WITH THE INTERNET DOWN THEY
WERE UNABLE TO GET THAT FOR
THEIR INFORMATION. THAT WAS THE
NUMBER ONE. FEEDBACK THAT WE
GOT- SO WE MADE SOME CHANGES
BASED ON THAT BUT BUT THEN
AGAIN WE NEED THAT TOOL TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FULL
INFORMATION BASICALLY THEY WERE
UNABLE TO OPEN THOSE LINKS ON
THERE. THERE'S SOLD THEIR
MOBILE DEVICES BECAUSE THE CELL
TOWERS ARE DOWN. AND THEN THE
THIRD. MOST IMPORTANT- FACTS-
AND IT'S RELATED TO YOU KNOW
MESSAGING THE PUBLIC OF COURSE
IS THE INABILITY TO SEND- WE AS
A WIRELESS EMERGENCY ALERTS AND
I'M HIGHLIGHTING NOW WHEN
BECAUSE THAT'S ONE OF OUR
GREATEST TOOLS- THERE'S A REAL
DIFFERENCE IN THE TOOLS THAT WE
USE FOR ALERTING THE PUBLIC-
THERE'S THE OLD. DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN OPT IN OPT OUT SO WE IT
IS NOT AN OPT IN SYSTEM SO WE
CAN REACH THE MOST PEOPLE YOU
KNOW AS LONG AS THEY COME INTO
THAT GEOGRAPHIC AREA THAT WE
TARGETED AND THEY HAVE THEIR
MOBILE DEVICE ON. WE'RE GOING
TO GET A MESSAGE TO THEM. AS
LONG AS THOSE CELL PHONE TOWERS
A RAP THIS SYSTEM REQUIRES THE
MOBILE WIRELESS TOWERS ARE UP
AND RUNNING. THIS IS IMPORTANT
NOW MORE THAN EVER GIVEN THE
FACT THAT MOST MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HAVE GIVEN UP THEIR WIRE
LINE PHONES. IN FAVOR OF
WIRELESS. AS I SAID BEFORE THIS
IS REALLY ONE OF OUR BEST A
WARNING OPTIONS GIVEN ITS NON
OPT IN NATURE. SO IF YOU WELL
I'D LIKE TO MENTION A FEW
THINGS WHEN SOMETHING'S A WE'D
LIKE TO SEE GOING FORWARD SOME
SOME TOOLS SOME CHANGES SOME
MAY BE IN A BETTER
RELATIONSHIP. WHATEVER THAT WE
NEED TO DO- TO DO A BETTER JOB.
HELLO YES CAN DO A BETTER JOB
IT'S BEEN STATED BEFORE
EMERGENCY MANAGERS NEED TO
CONSISTENT. AVAILABLE
KNOWLEDGEABLE CONTACT TO G.
WITH EACH OF THE
TELECOMMUNICATION PROVIDERS.
THAT WAY WE GET THE UP TO DATE
AND ACCURATE INFORMATION.
NUMBER TWO EMERGENCY MANAGERS
NEED TO KNOW WHERE CELL PHONE
TOWERS ARE LOCATED. I KNOW
THAT'S A STRUGGLE I KNOW IT'S
PROPRIETARY INFORMATION WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT OUR MESSAGES THAT
WERE SENDING OUT ARE
DISTRIBUTED. TO AN AREA THAT
NEEDS POTENTIALLY LIFESAVING
NOTIFICATIONS WE SEND OUT
NOTIFICATIONS ABOUT EVACUATIONS
IN SHELTERS IN PLACE. IN THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN FAR AS WE WERE
ONE OF THE FEW COUNTIES IS SEND
OUT A WE- TO THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE SCAPIN CINNAMON COMING
DOWN INTO MARIN. FOR KAREN
SHELTER. WELL WE KNOW FROM
EXPERIENCE AND STORIES- THAT IS
CURRENTLY POSSIBLE TO SEND A WE
ARE WITHOUT ACTUALLY GOING TO
THE PUBLIC. BY INADVERTENTLY
GEO LOCATING A TARGET AREA FOR
A MESSAGE. THAT DOES NOT
CONTAIN ANY TOWERS WITHIN THAT
GEO LOCATED AREA. IT'S ACTUALLY
OCCURRED IN THE STATE. SO IF WE
HAVE THAT INFORMATION WE COULD
ACT ACCORDINGLY. IN TERMS OF
KNOWING WHICH TOOL TO USE TO
THE WAR TO WARN THE PUBLIC.
THIRDLY EMERGENCY MANAGERS NEED
TO KNOW THE STATUS OF STE
CELLULAR SMS- WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERTS AND DATA
FUNCTIONALITY OF EACH PROVIDER
SYSTEM BY TARYN AREA. IN ORDER
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT PUBLIC
ALERTING OPTIONS ARE AVAILABLE
DURING EMERGENCY WE WILL SHIFT
OUR ACTIONS BASED ON WHAT WE
KNOW. IS CAPABLE OF GETTING THE
MESSAGE OUT. I NUMBER FOR
EMERGENCY MANAGERS NEED BILL AN
ADDRESS AND PHONE NUMBER OF
CELLULAR CUSTOMERS FOR
INCLUSION IN REVERSE NINE ONE
ONE SYSTEMS. CURRENTLY WE CAN
GET THAT DATA FOR PLAIN OLD
TELEPHONE LINES WHICH WE GET
FROM COMPANIES LIKE COMCAST-
FRONTIER- FOR YOU KNOW THOSE
THOSE WIRED PHONES WE POPULATE
THAT IN OUR SYSTEM- AND THAT
WAY WE CAN CALL THOSE NUMBERS
IN EVENT OF EMERGENCY WE
CURRENTLY CAN I GET THAT FOR.
FOR CELL PHONE SO THEY HAVE TO
OPT INTO OUR SYSTEM AND QUITE
HONESTLY THAT'S THE STRUGGLE OF
MOST OF THE COUNTIES IN THE
STATE VERY AVERAGE SOMEWHERE
AROUND TEN TO TWENTY PERCENT-
YOU KNOW OPT IN WHICH IS PRETTY
LOW- WE CAN DO WE CONSTANTLY
MARKET OUR SYSTEM BUT WE'RE
RELYING ON PEOPLE DOING THAT ON
AROUND. FIFTH WE WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW THE EXPECTED UP TIME AND
FUNCTIONALITY OF CELLULAR SITES
FOR PLANNING PURPOSES. AND THEN
NEED AS CLOSE TO REAL TIME AS
POSSIBLE INFORMATION AN ACTUAL
UPTIME AND FUNCTIONALITY DURING
EMERGENCY. I BELIEVE THAT'S
BEEN STATED BEFORE. IN ADDITION
TO WIRELESS AND CELLULAR WE'D
LIKE TO KNOW THE EXPECTED UP
TIME OF WIRELINE PHONE
INFRASTRUCTURE AN ACTUAL UP
TIME AND FUNCTIONALITY DURING
EMERGENCY. AS WE DISCOVERED IN
OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN MUCH OF
THE WIRELESS SYSTEM NOW DEPENDS
ON CONTINUOUS POWER OUTSIDE OF
THE RESIDENCE. DURING THE
OCTOBER TWENTY NINETEEN NOW
JUST OUTAGES IT BECAME CLEAR
THAT DATA COMMUNICATION TO SELL
SITES IS ALSO A WEAK LINK THIS
IS ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED. WE
NEED TO KNOW THE EXACT EXPECTED
IMPACT OF POWER FAILURES AND
ALSO NON POWER RELATED
COMMUNICATION FAILURES ON THE
WIRELESS AND CELLULAR
INFRASTRUCTURE. FINALLY SO
YOU'RE SITES NEED TO HAVE MUCH
MUCH BETTER RESILIENCE TO POWER
FAILURES THIS IS ALREADY BEEN
DISCUSSED- THIS IS THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THE PUBLIC
DEPENDS ON FOR POTENTIALLY LIFE
SAVING. NINE ONE ONE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY FOR MEDICAL FIRE AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEEDS. THANK YOU
NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO CENTER
MORE LET. THANK YOU MEDICARE.
MR KILLER DUDE SHE HAVE THE
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE WOULD
LIKE TO GIVE YOU A PROCLAMATION
FOR HAVING PRESENTED AT THE
MOST HEARINGS IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS YOU. IT'S A DIRECT
CORRELATION TO THE NUMBER OF
DISASTERS WE. BUT I THINK MISS
BADGERS A CATCHING UP TO YEAH
SO SHOULD BE AN INTERESTING
RACE- I WANT TO GET BACK TO A
MISTRIAL YOU IF YOU HAD A- USE
THE TERM EMERGENCY MANAGERS.
AND I'M CONCERNED ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNICATION AS WELL
PEOPLE AREN'T. ABLE TO CONTACT.
HE'S DEPARTMENTS AND FIRE
DEPARTMENTS FIRE DEPARTMENTS
AND POLICE DEPARTMENTS AB
HAVING TROUBLE AS WELL JUST
COMMUNICATINGOF THEMSELVES
WITH EACH OTHER IN ORANGE
COUNTY WE HAVE AN EIGHT HUNDRED
MEGAHERTZ SYSTEM. BUT A BIG
TOWER ON CATALINA ISLAND SO
THAT WE COULD TRY AND MAKE SURE
WE COULD COMMUNICATE I'M JUST
CURIOUS. HOW HOW WAS THE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN YOUR
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICIALS DURING
THESE- DISASTERS. IT WAS GOOD I
MEAN WEEK WE CAN RELY ON OUR-
MORE IN EMERGENCY RADIO AS A
SYSTEM AND WE'RE ACTUALLY IN
THE MIDDLE OF A- NEXT
GENERATION BUILD OUT OF THAT
SYSTEM SO IN TERMS OF. THE
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE OVER
RADIOS IT WAS FINE I MEAN
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD SYSTEM AND
WORKED WELL- I WAS IN THE A. C.
FOR. ALMOST A WEEK DURING THE
POWER SHUTDOWNS AND YOU KNOW WE
IT WAS A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE LHASA
TELECOMMUNICATIONS. BECAUSE
QUITE HONESTLY A LOT OF THE-
MANNER IN LAW AND FIRE THEY USE
THEIR CELL PHONE TWO TO
COMMUNICATE A LOT TO TAX TO
TALK TO EACH OTHER. AND THEY
WERE VERY FRUSTRATED BY THOSE
OUTAGES SO THERE IS THAT THAT
WAS IN EFFECT. MR KILLER DO G.
STAY CALM IS THAT YOUR-
COMMUNICATION SYSTEM FOR THAT
FOR YES. STATE CONDE COM S.
TACOM. I HAVE A NO I DON'T
EITHER THAT BACK OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES STATE ME
MUNICH CATIONS SYSTEM WELL WE
HAVE THE STATE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM WHICH IS
THE ENTIRE A BACKBONE OF ALL OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS IN THE STATE
THAT THE NOT ONLY HANDLES ALL
STATE AGENCIES BUT IS THE
BACKBONE FOR SUPPORTING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT ARE NINE ONE ONE
CENTERS- EXCEPT YOURSELF IF
THAT IS WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT IS OUR- PROGRAM.
IT'S NOT IT'S A HIGH FREQUENCY
RADIO I'VE HIGH FREQUENCY WAY
IT'S BOTH MICROWAVE AND- AND IT
IS A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
CAPABILITIES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT THAT THAT THAT WORK. IN
OUR I'M UNDER THE IMPRESSION
THAT. OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES ARE TRYING TO UPGRADE
AND WORK ON THEIR HIGH
FREQUENCY IN AND I HAVE A
LETTER FROM THE SHERIFF OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY- CONCERNED
ABOUT. SAY SHIP COM. OR URGENT
LINK. I'M JUST WONDERING. HOW
HOW ARE THAT THE PROCESS SEES
FOR MAYBE IMPLEMENTING THIS
TECHNOLOGY HOW'S IT COMING
ALONG. SO WE GET A LOT OF
DIFFERENT. UNDER STATE COME
DOES WITH NEW AND INNOVATIVE
CAPABILITIES WE DO PUT THEM
THROUGH A PROCESS OF
EVALUATION- VIRGIN LIKE IS ONE
OF SEVERAL- THAT- BILLS IN A
REDUNDANCY LAYS OVER THE TOP
OF. THE SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE BY
THE WAY WE HAVE I SOMETHING
LIKE SIX DIFFERENT REDUNDANT
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN HAVE. PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMUNICATIONS POINT THE POINT
TO OUR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO
OUR STATE AGENCIES THAT'S
DIFFERENT BY THE WAY THEN
PUBLIC COMMUNICATIONS THAT IS
PROVIDED BY THE PRIVATE SECTOR
CELLULAR PROVIDERS. BUT FROM
THE STANDPOINT OF STATE
COMMUNICATIONS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY WE DO LOOK AT ALL THOSE-
URGENT LIKE A TO MY KNOWLEDGE
IS ONE THAT WE HAVE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF EVALUATING- BUT IT
IS AGAIN A SYSTEM THAT WILL BE
IS OVER. AND IS THEREFORE A
REDUNDANCY THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON. YES THANK YOU ALWAYS A
PLEASURE TO SEE YOU DIRECTOR
GIL INTO CHIU SPECIALLY WHEN
THERE'S NOT A FIRE. GOING ON
BUT IT IS ALWAYS A GOOD FEELING
TO HAVE YOU THERE WHEN WE HAVE
FIRES BECAUSE I. I THINK WE ALL
I'M LOOKING AROUND THE ROOM
MANY OF US HAVE HAD THAT
EXPERIENCE AND WHEN YOU'RE IN
THE ROOM- THIS IS IT ELEVATES
SENT SENSE OF CONFIDENCE AND SO
I APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE- THE
WORK YOU'VE DONE. AND THE FACT
THAT YOU'VE CONTINUED TO DO IT-
EVEN THOUGH YOU'VE BEEN
THREATENING TO- TO START TAKING
SOME NICE LONG WALKS ON THE
BEACH FOR QUITE SOME TIME
REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
CONTINUED. EFFORTS ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA- I
WANT TO ASK YOU THE- QUESTION
TO WHAT I ASKED THE CPUC- YOU
AND I'VE TALKED FOR QUITE SOME
TIME MY PARTICULAR INTEREST IS
A CENTER. ARE DONE ON OUR
MERCHANT SEALER TO STORMS- THE
FACT THAT WE ARE IS THERE ARE
THOSE. THOSE ARE LOOKS AT
PHONES THAT ARE WITHIN THE-
AWARE THERE IS THAT NEED TO BE
WARNED ABOUT POTENTIAL.
DISASTER AND THE FACT THAT IT
IS BEEN VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
OUR WIRELESS COMPANIES TO- TAKE
SOME LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITY OR
OWNERSHIP OF THEIR-
REQUIREMENTS AS AS PARTNERS IN
THIS EFFORT. I AM PLEASED TO
HEAR THAT THAT SEEMS TO BE
INVOLVING- AYE AYE IT GIVES ME
SOME CONFIDENCE IN SOME OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT I AM DOING TO
TRY TO ENSURE THAT THAT
HAPPENS. BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR FROM YOU- WHAT AUTHORITY
YOU BELIEVE YOU NEED. TO
CONTINUE A BOWL TO COLLECT THE
INFORMATION FROM THE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES. I
AND- THIS REQUIRE THEIR
PARTICIPATION IN SOME OF THESE
COLLECTED SOLUTIONS. AS WELL AS
IN THESE EMERGENCY ALERT
SITUATIONS- WHAT. WHAT WE IS A
LEGISLATURE CAN DO TO ASSIST
YOU. AND NOT JUST. ASKING THE
COMPANIES TO PARTICIPATE BUT TO
FOR THEM TO REALIZE THAT THEY
HAVE AN OBLIGATION. UNDER LAW
TO PARTICIPATE AND TO HELP
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY- AND ALSO
TO KEEP OUR STATE GOING. DURING
THESE PSP SNC ENTERING OUR-
FIRES WHEN THE SYSTEMS ARE DOWN
WHAT DO YOU NEED. THANK YOU FOR
THE QUESTION AND COURSE THE
SUPPORT BASE- IS PHENOMENAL
FROM THE LEGISLATURE- I THINK
YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT THERE'S
A LOT PROBABLY THE ANSWER THAT
QUESTION SENATOR- YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY THE WORK THAT HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED. WITH WITH FOR
EXAMPLE ON ALERT AND WARNING
YOU KNOW YOUR BILL ABOUT DOING-
BE ABLE TO JUST- BOB DAN VERSUS
YOU KNOW OPTING OUT THAT THAT
THAT WHOLE PIECE. ACTUALLY
TAKING THAT AND MOVING THAT BOW
DOWN TO THE- CITY LEVEL WILL BE
A HUGE- ASSISTANCE SO THAT WE
HAVE ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT-
THAT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROGRAM.
THAT WILL ALSO ENHANCE THEM THE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH WITH OUR
CITIZENS- THE- WORK THAT HAS
BEEN DONE THE SENATE REQUIRES
BILLION IN BEGINNING THAT
PROCESS OF GETTING AYE DATA
REPORTING GET OUT OF REPORTED.
THAT'S GOOD THE REPORT I THINK
IT'S EVOLVING- AND- I'M I'M
HOPING THAT THAT MUCH OF THE
WORK THAT WE'RE DOING- WITH OUR
TELECOMMUNICATION PARTNERS NOW
IS TRULY. GOING TO BE
MAINTAINED A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT- WE ALL HAVE TO BE
ROWING IN THE SAME DIRECTION
AND THROUGH THAT- INITIATIVE-
THERE THERE MAY BE THINGS FOR
EXAMPLE IF WE'RE REALLY GOING
TO PUT THE- THAT THE EFFORT
FORWARD TO RAPIDLY ASSASSIN AND
BUILD OUT THE NEEDS OF
UPGRADING OUR SYSTEM TO MAKE IT
RESILIENT. THERE MAY BE SOME
LEGISLATIVE ACTIONS THAT NEED
TO TAKE PLACE THAT STREAMLINED
THAT EFFORT THAT CAN HELP THE
TELCOS BE ABLE TO- AFFECTIVELY
PUT THEIR CAPABILITIES IN PLACE
AND- MUCH LIKE WE'VE DONE IN
OTHER CRISIS SITUATIONS THERE
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES THERE TO
BE ABLE TO STREAMLINE THAT
PROCESS AND I THINK THAT WOULD
BE A GREAT PLACE WHERE WE COULD
WORK WITH YOU AND BASED UPON
THE MEETINGS WERE HAVING WITH
THE TELCOS FIND A WAY TO DO
THAT. IT IT IT SHOULD I THINK.
L. T. TO I MEAN WE ARE PRETTY
GOOD AT FORTY IS NOW BUT- I
THINK BUILDING ON THE EGGS ON
THE INITIAL UP. THE BILL THAT
THAT SET FORTH REPORTING I
THINK WE PROBABLY NEED TO
CONTINUE TO SEE HOW THAT GOES
AND PROBABLY MAYBE STEPPED THAT
UP A LITTLE BIT AS TIME GOES ON
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW THERE THE
REPORTING OF THAT IS THE
REPORTING OF THOSE OUTAGES. ARE
EXTREMELY CRITICAL AND UP IT
WAS A SOURCE OF FRUSTRATION. I
DO BELIEVE AT THIS POINT AFTER
THIS LAST PS PS A BAD- THAT WE
ARE ON MORE OF THE SAME PACE
THAN WE'VE EVER BEEN BEFORE.
BUT AS WE SAY THE PROOF'S IN
THE PUDDING AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO SEE HOW THINGS PROGRESS
THANK YOU SENATOR WILL MOVE ON
TO CENTER MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AS CHAIR. THE VERY QUICK-
MISTER DIRECTOR THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK SIR- IN ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF A CENTER JACKSON
THAT THIS IS A LIFETIME JOB UP
INTO YOUR NINETIES SO WE LOOK
FOR TO ANSWER. I'M NOT A REPEAT
WITH MISTER HILL DESCENT SO.
LOOK I DON'T WANT TO JUST-
THROW STONES TODAY BECAUSE I
THINK THAT WE'RE ALL INTERESTED
IN IN LOOKING FOR SOLUTIONS AND
WILL SAY- OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
MONTHS TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES IN ME WITH OUR OFFICE
I KNOW THAT THE MEETING WITH
YOU AND MEAN WITH MANY OF US
ABOUT SOLUTIONS ESPECIALLY ON
BACKUP POWER BUT I WANT TO
ADDRESS SIX I THINK IT'S ONE OF
OUR BIGGEST ONE ABILITIES WHEN
IT COMES TO. OUR STATE WHY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS- EARLIER THIS
PAST SUMMER OUR UNDERSTANDING
WAS THAT TELECOMMUNICATION
COMPANIES PREPARED FOR THE
WORST. AND THEN WE GET THROUGH
THIS SIGNIFICANT POWER OUTAGE
OF IN A SERIES OF EVENTS THAT
WE SAW THROUGHOUT- THE
CALIFORNIA AND IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. IT'S CLEAR THEY
WERE NOT. IN IN FACT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS. SCRAMBLING TO
BRING IN RESOURCES FROM OUT OF
STATE TO TRY TO KEEP THEIR
GRADE. IN THEIR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM UP
AND RUNNING. I'D LIKE TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING WHAT YOU
KNOW ABOUT THIS- AND THEN I'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HEAR YOUR
SUGGESTIONS- IN REGARD TO
REDUNDANT BACKUP POWER. SO
THANK YOU. THE FACTS ARE THAT I
THINK THAT THE THAT THE EVENTS
OF THE P. S. P. WHERE. YOU KNOW
UNDER UNDER THOUGHT AND- YOU
KNOW THE EVENT GOT OUT IN FRONT
OF THE TELECOMS- PROVIDERS- AND
THEY REALIZE THAT- YOU KNOW
THEIR EXISTING CAPABILITY TO
KEEP THEIR TOWERS UP AND WHAT
POWERS THEY HAD OR WHAT BACK
CALL THEY HAVE BEEN THEY HAD
SOME REGENCY POWER WAS IN THERE
IN SUFFICIENT. SO THE BASE
SCRAMBLED AROUND IT WAS THE
RELATING NEED QUITE FRANKLY
AND- AND SO- BACK THAT RESULT
IN THEM HAVING TO GO. IN STATE
BUT ALSO OUT OF STATE TO GET-
EMERGENCY POWER BE HONEST IT
WAS A LITTLE COMPLICATED
BECAUSE AS THEY CAME TO THE
BORDERS OF CALIFORNIA IF THEY
COMING FROM TEXAS- THEY DID
MEET OUR AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
AND SO THEN- YES HAD TO
SCRAMBLE TO GET WAIVERS- TO BE
ABLE TO LET THAT MAN UNDER
EMERGENCY ORDER- BECAUSE WE
NEEDED HEM AT THE TIME. IT'S
REALLY NOT THE WAY WE LIKE TO
DO BUSINESS I THINK
COLLECTIVELY IN AGAIN ALL BEING
ON THE SAME PAGE. WE HAVE. WE
HAVE FOUGHT THROUGH. WHAT
CATASTROPHIC DISASTERS LOOK
LIKE IN THE STATE WE HAVE BUILT
CATASTROPHIC RESPONSE PLANS.
THAT HAVE VERY DETAILED- DATA
OUTLINED IN THOSE- TO TALK
ABOUT LOSS OF POWER IT BACK TO
COMMUNITIES EXCEPT TRUCK. THAT
THAT DATA IS AVAILABLE AND WHEN
CAN WE HAVE TALKED TO THE
TELECOMS IN THE PAST ABOUT. THE
FACT THAT GOING OUT OF STATE OR
SIX. A PORTABLE CELL ON WHEELS-
IS NOT A SUFFICIENT FOR THE
KIND OF DISASTERS WE HAVE IN
CALIFORNIA. I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT THIS POINT. GOING THROUGH
WHAT WE'VE ALL BEEN THROUGH. I
THINK EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS
REALLY WHAT THE CASCADING
IMPACTS AND THE DIRECT IMPACTS
OF THOSE LIFE LINES ARE. SO WE
NOW HAVE A NEW STANDARD TO
OPERATE FROM. EVERYBODY'S BEEN
THROUGH IT AND I'M HOPING THAT
THROUGH THIS COLLABORATIVE.
EFFORT WHAT WILL CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD. AND TO GET WHERE
WE NEED TO GET TO YES I MENTION
MY- MY STATEMENT IS THAT DUMB.
THEY REALLY NEED TO BUILD AND
BAKE IN- AS WE DO THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS-
AYE AYE DRAFTING- CAPABILITY
WITH HIS EMERGENCY POWER THAT
IS. BEYOND FOUR HOURS AND THAT
IS REALLY PART OF HARDENING
THAT. CAPABILITY WRAPPING FIBER
LINES SO THAT THEY DON'T CRACK
BREAK BURN OR MELT- BEING ABLE
TO DO DEFENSIBLE SPACE AROUND
CELL SIZE HARDENING THOSE
SITES- AND IF THERE'S SOME.
REGULATORY OR OTHER KINDS OF
ADMINISTRATIVE ISSUES WHERE THE
STATE CAN HELP STREAMLINE THOSE
EFFORTS. I THINK WE'D SIT DOWN
AND HELP TO DO THAT AND THAT
YOU KNOW ARE THIS IS RELEASED
ABOUT CRISIS SITUATION BECAUSE
THERE IS NO WAY. NO WAY. THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE ANOTHER YEAR
LIKE WE DID IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE- AS A SOCIETY
SHOULD NOT EXPECT. THAT WE NOT
ONLY LOSE. POWER TO MILLIONS
BUT ARE ALL OF OUR
COMMUNICATIONS ALL OF OUR DATA.
WE CAN'T BE DRIVEN INTO ONE
SYSTEM. AND THEN THAT SYSTEM
THEN BECOME SO VULNERABLE THAT
WE LOSE IT ALL BECAUSE LEISER
RISK IT'S UNACCEPTABLE. SO WE
CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN SO TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE AND WE NEED
TO MOVE FOR WITH A DEFINITIVE
PLAN WORKING TOGETHER TO GET
WHAT WE NEED TO GET TO THANK
YOU WE'RE GONNA GO. TO CENTER
MONEY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I ALSO WANT TO THINK MISTER
KILLER DUE TO YOU AND ALL OF
YOUR TEAM- ALSO WELCOME TO
MISTER RILEY- SO MISTER RILEY
TOUCHED ON FIRST RESPONDER
ABILITY TO COMMUNICATE WITH
EACH OTHER- USING IMPROVED
RADIO SYSTEMS AND I I'VE SEEN
WITH CAL FIRE AND STATE PARKS
THESE NEW SYSTEMS ALLOW INTER
AGENCY COMMUNICATION ETCETERA.
I GUESS FOR MISTER GULAR DUE TO
FIRST WAS THERE ANY EVIDENCE OF
OUTAGES IMPEDING FIRST
RESPONDER ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE WITH EACH OTHER.
LET ME JUST CAST MEASURES ARE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS SO.
BETTER AND GOOD MORNING- MITCH
MEDIC OF A CHAIR. I WAS JUST
LIKE SAY IF WE DID NOT HAVE ANY
EXPERIENCE OF ANY- MAJOR
OUTAGES OR OUR ISSUES WITH OUR
NETWORK SO THAT SUPPORTS ALL
THE STATE AGENCIES THAT- RIGHT
OVER THE RADIO SYSTEM. AND IT'S
OUR NETWORK IS BUILT WITH ALL
OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY GRADE
UPGRADES THAT THE DIRECTORS
TALKING ABOUT SO. THAT'S THAT'S
REASSURING ACTUALLY IN THAT
WOULD SUGGEST. INDEPENDENT
POWER SOURCES FROM. CLEARLY
RADIOS ARE BATTERY DRIVEN BUT
THE- RELAY CENTERS AT CENTER
HAVE THEIR OWN. POWER
REDUNDANCY DURING A POWER
OUTAGE THAT'S CORRECT IN COURSE
WE HAD TO DO REFUELING
OPERATIONS TO THOSE GENERATORS%
AND THAT IS A CHALLENGE DURING
THE MIDDLE THE EVENT PARTICULAR
IN FIRE AREAS THERE MIGHT HAVE
BEEN MOMENTARY LAPSES BECAUSE
OF A FIRE THAT'S EXISTING
BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T GET IN BUT
AS SOON AS IT WAS REFILL.
RESTORE LET ME SAY THOUGH THAT
THE PUBLIC REACHED FIFTY
RESPOND HERS WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
MOVING DATA YOU KNOW THEY'RE
USING CELLS CELLS SERVICES WELL
THE USE OF THE SYSTEMS. TO
COMMUNICATE WAS IMPEDED RIGHT
THE LAND MOBILE RADIO SYSTEMS
ARE MICROWAVE NETWORK OUR
PUBLIC SAID COMMUNICATIONS THEM
WAS OPERATIONAL FOR WHAT- FOR
BUT THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR JUST
MENTIONED- BUT THE IN THE USE
OF THESE WERE IN IMPACTED JUST
LIKE- JUST LIKE- THE PUBLIC
THANK YOU IN IN THAT CAN IMPEDE
THE ABILITY TO RELATE OTHER
DATA OR- GROUPS DATA MAPPING
YEAH. TO THE OTHER SIDE OF THAT
MISTER RILEY LOU THIS IS WELL
LAND MINES WE HAVE THE ABILITY
FOR REVERSE NINE ONE ONE
NOTIFICATION IN IN THE EXTREME
OF ACTIVATION THIS IS. THE
CONCERN Là. BUT ONLY OFTEN FOR
SELF SERVICE TODAY I UNDERSTAND
THAT CORRECTLY WITH A VERY LOW
UPTAKE TOM WAS IN MARIN COUNTY
OF PEOPLE OPTING IN FOR THAT
RIVERS. NINE ONE ONE- WHY IS
THERE THAT DISTINCTION AND
WHAT'S THE REMEDY TO GET WITH
MORE AND MORE PEOPLE MOVING TO
ONLY WIRELESS AT THEIR HOMES
HAD WE BUILD THAT INTO THAN
NINE WERE VERSE NINE ONE ONE
WITHOUT REQUIRING AN OPT IN
THAT PEOPLE AREN'T USING. SO
ANY OF YOU THAT WANT TO TAKE
THEM. START AND I'LL TURN OVER%
TO CHRIS BECAUSE HE CAN TELL
YOU OPERATIONS THERE'S A LOT OF
SHARED INFRASTRUCTURE. SO WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT WIRELINE WIRELESS
AND ALL THESE OTHER
COMMUNICATIONS A LOT OF TIMES
IF YOU FALL THAT SPIDER WEB FOR
THAT INFRASTRUCTURE THE
BACKBONE OF HOW COMMUNICATIONS
MOVE. THERE'S A VULNERABILITY
POINTS THAT EXIST WITHIN THAT
SHORT TERM STRUCTURE SO- TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION YOU HAVE-
LAND LINES ARE WERE SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEM AND ANSWER THE DIRECTOR
HAD MENTIONED HERE I MEAN THAT
ARE HIGH POINT WE HAD FOR OVER.
CLOSE TO HALF A MILLION BEFORE
FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND LANDLINES
CUSTOMERS THAT'S NOT I AM NOT
CORRECTION THERE'S STILL SITES
NOT INDIVIDUAL SEEK MULTIPLIED
BY THREE LIKE A CHRIS TALKED
ABOUT THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT IN NOT HAVING THE
SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR THAT THAT
PORTION OF IT. AND SO WHEN THE
SHARED INFRASTRUCTURES DOWN. AS
CHRIS POINTED OUT HE'S HE WAS
NOT ABLE TO COMMUNICATE NOT
ONLY BY WIRE LESS TO SEND OUT
MEMBERS MESSAGE TO EVERY PHONE
OUT THERE IN HIS AREA YOU CAN
DO THAT. IF THE WIRE LINE WAS
DOWN HE COULDN'T REACH HIM IF
THERE OF A CUSTOMER THAT
BUNDLES THEIR INTERNET IN YOUR
TELEVISION AND ALL THE THINGS
THAT YOU HAVE. YOU'RE NOT GONNA
GET BROADCAST TELEVISION SIGNAL
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET AVOID
PHONE INTO YOUR HOUSE AND
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
USE YOUR INTERNET TO VALIDATE
MEANING IT'S GOING ON THERE SO.
YOU KNOW THE CHALLENGES HE
FACED AT THE COUNTY LEVEL IN
AND ALL OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE IMPACTED BY IT WE'RE FACING
THE SAME ISSUE IS THE ABILITY
TO COMMUNICATE WAS. DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY ALL AREAS. YEAH YOU
PEOPLE DON'T OPT INTO OUR
SYSTEM FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
REASONS YOU KNOW- VERY
INDIVIDUAL REASONS BUT YOU KNOW
IT MIGHT THEIR WITH MAY BE
SUSPICIOUS OF GOVERNMENT OR
THEY'RE AFRAID THAT THEY'RE
GONNA GET SPAMMER. BUT THEY
WERE GONNA SHARE THEIR
INFORMATION WITH- YOU KNOW SOME
OF THE SOME MAKETERS SOMETHING
LIKE THAT YOU KNOW EVERYBODY
HAS A LOT OF. DIFFERENT
REASONS- WE CAN GET THE DATA AS
I SAID FOR A REGULAR LINE
PHONES WE GET FOR CALM FROM
COMCAST NOW WE PUT THAT IN
THERE. SO VERIZON EIGHTEEN T.
THEY SHARE THAT INFORMATION
WITH US BUT- WIRELESS COMPANIES
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO DO THAT. I
KNOW THAT THERE WAS A BILL
RECENTLY. I THAT WAS GOING TO
EXPAND THE DEFINITION I
UNDERSTAND AND OF YOU KNOW TO
INCLUDE WIRELESS COMPANIES IN
AND REQUIRING TO SHARE THAT.
WITH US. BUT I UNDERSTAND IT
THAT FAILED- WE WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE THAT ABILITY- WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO NOTIFY AS MANY
PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE- YEAH THAT
NUMBERS YOU KNOW 15220% HOW
OFTEN IS. NOT UNUSUAL YOU KNOW
IT TOO WE- WE TALKED OR OTHER
COUNTIES AROUND THE STATE THAT
EXPERIENCED THE SAME KIND OF
LOW LEVEL ABOUT THAT YASSER IS
THIS. THE VULNERABILITY OF LAND
LINES- YEAH. THE RIVERS AND
NINE ONE ONE. SO I THINK WILL
BE HELPFUL FOR US AND- NOT AT
THIS MOMENT. IS FOLLOW UP. IF
YOU HAD A MAGIC WAND WHAT WOULD
BE. SOME WHAT WOULD BE THE
IDEAL COMMUNICATION. ACCESS FOR.
FULLER HUH. RESIDENTS RATE
PAYERS- OF IMPENDING DANGER
WHAT WHAT HOW DO WE CREATE THAT
REDUNDANCY IDEALLY FORGETTING.
ABOUT CARSON. WELL HONESTLY
THEY ALL NEED TO BE ROBUST AND
WE'VE DONE THAT ALL OF THE.
INTERNET NEEDS TO BE UP SO WE
CAN PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THERE ACTUALLY IS
NOT ONE PREFERRED. SOURCE OF
NOTIFYING THE PROPER PUBLIC
BECAUSE IT'S VERY. INCIDENT
DRIVEN YEAH BUT ONE OF THE
LESSONS I GUESS IS THE NEED FOR
REDUNDANCY THE SACRAMENTO
AIRPORT- AND- I WON'T GET INTO
THIS NOW BUT WE- WERE TRYING
OUT RESPONSES TO NATURAL
DISASTERS. AND PLAN TO POWER
OUTAGES. THIS HEARINGS NOT
ABOUT POTENTIAL SUSCEPTIBILITY
TO TERRORIST EFFORTS TO KNOCK
OUT THE GRID TO KNOCK OUT
INFORMATION SYSTEMS. IN BED BUT
OUR ABILITY TO PREPARE IN THIS
INSTANCE I WOULD THINK ALSO
BENEFIT SERVICE IN TERMS OF OUR
BROADER- SECURITY CONCERNS BUT
I KEEP THINKING CENTER. AND
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OUR NEXT
PANEL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. HELLO PHONE
TURN A CLEARLY OKAY CENTER
SKINNER DID MASS TO. KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED HERE THANK YOU DEAR
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING ARE
ALSO ON A GIVE MY APPRECIATION
TO THE REPRESENTS THE P. YOU
SEE WHO SPOKE WELL I WASN'T
SITTING ON THE DíAS I WAS
LISTENING- MISTER DRILLER DO G.
YOU WERE SAYING AND SPECIFIC
AND I APPRECIATE IT. AND MISTER
RILEY A SIMILARLY- MY DISTRICT
WAS ALSO AFFECTED BY THE POWER
OUTAGES AND I BRING IT UP NOT
BECAUSE LIKE YOU KNOW WE'RE
UNIQUE OR SOMETHING BUT AS MOST
PEOPLE KNOW BE OPEN BERKELEY
HILLS FIRE WAS THE MOST
DAMAGING DEVASTATING AND LIKE
LOS BUYER PRIOR TO. EITHER THE
COFFEE OR THE PARADISE AND MUCH
OF OUR SELL EQUIPMENT IS IN THE
BERKELEY AND OAKLAND HILLS
EXACTLY WHERE THE FIRE OCCURRED
SO OF COURSE THAT IS WHERE THE
POWER WAS TURNED OFF AND WHEN
THEIR POWER WAS TURNED OFF
THOSE VERY RESIDENTS WHO ARE
MOST SUSCEPTIBLE TO A FIRE.
DâN DID NOT HAVE FOR MANY OF
THEM EITHER INTERNET OR SELL
ACCESS TO THE VERY WAY AND
WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS THAT
SOMEONE IS NOTIFIED THEY NO
LONGER HAD AND WE THEN WE WERE
FORTUNATE WE DID NOT HAVE A
SERIOUS INCIDENT BUT THERE IS
A- IN LAFAYETTE WHICH IS BASED.
ON THE OF THE BILLS AND IN
CERTAIN EIGHT THERE WOULD FIRE.
BERKELEY KENSINGTON AREA.
CONTACT THE COUNTY WAS ALSO
ACTED AND THEN OF COURSE THRE
WAS THE FIRE IN VALLEJO THAT
JUMPED THE CARQUINEZ STRAITS.
IN HIT BY THE NORTHERN PART OF
NORTHWESTERN PART OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY AGAIN WITH THE
POWER OUTAGES. THE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE THERE DID NOT HAVE THIS
ACCESS SO- SO WE KNOW THAT
PLACES THAT NEED THIS CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE. WERE WITHOUT IT
AND- THE MAIN BESIDES JUST
BRINGING IT UP. WHEN AS WE LOOK
AT REQUIRING BACK TO POWER.
GIVEN WHERE MUCH OF THIS
EQUIPMENT IS LOCATED TO RELY ON
DIESEL GENERATORS IN THE MID IN
THE PLACE WHERE WE ARE MOST
SUSCEPTIBLE TO FIRE DOES NOT
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE. NOW I KNOW
THERE'S- DIFFICULTIES WITH- YOU
KNOW A STORAGE- BATTERY STORAGE
IN SUCH AS A LIMITED HOURS BUT-
THERE HAS BEEN A LOT OF
TECHNOLOGICAL BREAKTHROUGHS AND
I THINK IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT THAT WE REALLY LOOK
AT. WHAT WHAT TECHNOLOGICAL
WHAT TECHNOLOGIES ARE AVAILABLE
AND WHAT BREAKTHROUGHS TO BE
ABLE TO NOT BE IN A
CIRCUMSTANCE WHERE WE'RE
RELIANT PRIMARILY ON DIESEL
GENERATION AT ESPECIALLY IN
THOSE LOCATIONS THAT ARE MOST
FIRE SUSCEPTIBLE. SO I WANTED
TO JUST LEAVE YOU KNOW IF WE.
IN THINKING ABOUT HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD WHETHER THERE HAS BEEN
THOUGHT TO THESE OTHER
TECHNOLOGIES WHETHER IT'S
WHETHER IT'S OTHER TECHNOLOGIES
FOR BACKUP POWER OR WHETHER
IT'S A WHOLE NOTHER
COMMUNICATION TECHNOLOGY. WELL
YOUR YOUR- IS IT YOUR POINT IS
SO IMPORTANT IT'S ONE OF THOSE
TOPICS TO WE HAVE BEEN.
DISCUSSING COLOURED THREE- ON
THE STATE SYSTEM WE USE A
COMBINATION OF SOLAR PROPANE
DIESEL- CURRENTLY AND I WOULD
JUST SAY DURING THE PS PS
ADVANCE AND THEN IMMEDIATELY
AFTER THE NUMBER OF. DIESEL
GENERATORS THEIR PROCURED AND
NOW ARE LAID OUT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE IS INCREASED
TREMENDOUSLY- IT IS WHAT WE
HAVE TO WORK WITH NOW BUT BUT
THERE THERE CAN BE NEW
TECHNOLOGY AND WE KNOW WE'VE
BEEN TALKING WITH- FOLKS FROM-
UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS ABOUT MAYBE
DOING SOME DESIGN- AND IN THE
DISCUSSIONS WERE HAVING WITH
OUR TELCO PARTNERS. IS WHAT ARE
SOME OF THE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
WE CAN LOOK TO ADDRESS THIS NOT
AN EASY SOLUTION YET OR
SOMETHING THAT COULD BE HAPPEN
REALLY FAST BUT IT IS SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING AND
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND AND WHERE
WE CAN PARTICULARLY SOLAR. AND
RENEWABLE- IS AREA WERE FOLK
ON. THANK YOU KNOW WHAT'S IT
WILL LAST LONG TIME THAT MEAN
YOUR BATTERIES NOW THAT WITH
ENOUGH SOLAR CAM CAN YOU KNOW
KEEP KEEP I THINK POWER FOR
QUITE A LONG TIME DEL. OKAY
THANK YOU. WE'RE GONNA- NOW
HEAR FROM THE TELEPHONE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
AND THEIR- RESPONSES TO THE
OUTAGES AND THE LESSONS LEARNED
AND- HOPEFULLY WHAT THEY- PLAN
TO IMPROVE. THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICE EACH JOB. IF WE CAN
HAVE- EVERYONE JUST COME
FORWARD WE CAN HAVE A STEVE
CARLSON WITH THE WIRELESS
ASSOCIATION JEFF LONG. WITH.
THE WITH A. T. AND T. CONSIDER
MINUS WITH VERIZON. AND I'M AN
S. CAROLINE MCINTYRE IF YOU CAN
ALSO COME UP AND BE PART OF
THIS PANEL WITH THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
AND JOHN LUNDGREN WITH THE
VOLCANO TELEPHONE IF YOU CAN
ALSO JOIN THIS PANEL
. IS THE
CHAIR MEMBERS- ON BEHALF OF C.
T. I A AND CALIFORNIA'S
WIRELESS INDUSTRY WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY. OUR
COMPANIES ARE AN INTEGRAL PART
OF CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC ENGINE
SUPPORTING SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
WIRELESS RELATED JOBS AND
SEVENTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS
IN ANNUAL ECONOMIC
PRODUCTIVITY. BUT MORE THAN
THAT WE ARE ALSO PROUD TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S CONNECTIVE TISSUE.
CONNECTING AN EMPOWERING MORE
THAN FORTY MILLION PEOPLE IN
EVERY DIVERSE COMMUNITY ACROSS
THE NATION'S LARGEST STATE. OUR
BUSINESS IS CONNECTING
CALIFORNIA AND LIKE EVERY
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE OURS WAS
IMPACTED BY A HISTORICALLY
UNPRECEDENTED SERVICE OF POWER
OUTAGES IN UNIQUE AND OFTEN
UNPREDICTABLE WAYS. AND YET IN
THE FACE OF THE MENTAL POWER
CHALLENGES ARE CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES WORKED AROUND THE
CLOCK TO DO EVERYTHING IN THEIR
POWER TO KEEP OUR CALIFORNIA
ASSETS OPERATIONAL. INCLUDING
ALL HANDS DEPLOYMENT OF
TECHNICAL PERSONNEL AND
EMERGENCY ASSETS DRAW NOT JUST
FROM EVERY CORNER OF CALIFORNIA
BUT AS YOU HEARD IN SOME CASES
FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AS
MIGHT BE EXPECTED THE MAGNITUDE
AND THE UNIQUENESS OF THE
EVENTS PRESENTED CHALLENGES.
BUT I CAN ASSURE ALL OF YOU.
FOR THE SAKE OF THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS AND
BUSINESSES WHO RELY ON US EVERY
DAY. TO REACH ONE ANOTHER. THIS
INDUSTRY STANDS READY TO SHARE
LESSONS LEARNED AND TO WORK
WITH THIS LEGISLATURE BUT WE
ASK YOU SEE AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. AS CONSTRUCTIVE
WORKING PARTNERS TO BETTER
PREPARE OUR STATE ON OUR
NETWORKS FOR FUTURE EVENTS AND
THE UNPRECEDENTED NEW NORMAL OF
P. S. P. S. WE ARE PLEASED TO
BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE. TO HEAR
FROM STATE AND LOCAL PARTIES AS
WELL AS TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
THAT MAY BE NEW. TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. AS I INDICATED
AS YOU HEARD. PS PS ADVANCE FOR
UNPRECEDENTED IN THE MOST
EXTENSIVE IN CALIFORNIA'S
HISTORY. RESPONDING TO THESE ON
PRESIDENT OUTAGES WAS A
COLOSSAL TASK IT WIRELESS
CARRIERS WERE ABLE TO LARGELY
MAINTAIN SERVICES WITH
THOUSANDS OF TECHNICIANS
WORKING AROUND THE CLOCK. TO
DEPLOY EMERGENCY ASSETS ACROSS
THE STATE. THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY SUPPORTS THE
COMMITTEE'S INTEREST IN GOAL IN
BETTER UNDERSTANDING THE
CHALLENGES THAT AROSE FROM THE
P. S. P. S. EVENTS. AND AS WE
LOOK TOGETHER FOR HOW TO
ADDRESS THEM IN THE FUTURE
THERE ARE SOME BASELINE FACTS
REGARDING THESE EVENTS. THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE. FOR
EXAMPLE THE FCC'S COMMUNICATION
STATUS REPORTS SHOW THAT 96% OF
CELL SITES THROUGHOUT THE
AFFECTED AREAS. REMAINED
OPERATIONAL. DESPITE THE FACT
THAT OVER TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIANS WERE
WITHOUT POWER. SIMULTANEOUSLY
SHUTTING OFF POWER TO A LARGE
PORTION OF THE STATE AT TIMES
REACHING MORE THAN HALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES PLACED ON HEARD OF
CONSTRAINTS AND TELECOM AN
EXISTING RESOURCES. MAINTAIN
POWER BARS FACILITIES WITH A
MOVING TARGET AS THE NATURE AND
MAGNITUDE OF THE PS PS EVENTS
MADE IT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT FOR
ALL INVOLVED. PUBLIC SAFETY
GOVERNMENT BUSINESS TO KNOW
EXACTLY WHEN AND WHERE THE SHUT
OUTS WOULD OCCUR AND FOR HOW
LONG THEY WOULD CONTINUE. AS
NOTED WIRELESS NETWORKS ARE
DESIGNED WITH NUMEROUS
OVERLAPPING CELL SITES THAT MAY
PROVIDE MAXIMUM CAPACITY AND
CONTINUITY OF SERVICE EVEN WHEN
AN INDIVIDUAL SITE AS AN
OPERABLE. COMMERCIAL POWER IS
CRITICAL TO PROVIDING TELECOM
SERVICES AND COMPREHENSIVE BACK
POWERS BACKUP POWER SYSTEMS ARE
REQUIRED TO MEET A VARIETY OF
NEEDS AND A VARIETY OF
CIRCUMSTANCES. EVERY NETWORK IS
UNIQUELY DESIGNED AND POWER
FAILURES ESPECIALLY THOSE OF
THE MAGNITUDE OF P. S. P. S.
CANNOT BE SOLVED BY A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH. MOST
FACILITIES HAVE BATTERY BACKUP
SOLUTIONS WHILE FIX GENERATORS
ARE OFTEN PERMANENTLY INSTALLED
AT SITES WERE STRICTLY
FEASIBLE. PERMITTED BY STATE
AND LOCAL LAWS IN STATE TO DO
SO. IN ADDITION PORTABLE
GENERATORS ALLOW LONG TERM AND
FLEXIBLE POWER TO BE RAPIDLY
DEPLOYED TO STRATEGIC HIGH
PRIORITY SITES. INCLUDING THOSE
SERVING THE GREATEST NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS. THROUGHOUT THE PS PS
PROCESS CARRIERS FOLLOWED
ESTABLISHED PROTOCOLS AND
PROVIDED DETAILED STATUS OF
PLATES THREE TIMES A DAY. TO
THE CALIFORNIA UTILITIES
EMERGENCY ASSOCIATION EMBEDDED
WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES. PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO VICTIMS
OF WILDFIRES CARE IS ALSO
ESTABLISHED RESOURCES AT
EVACUATION CENTERS ACROSS THE
STATE WITH ON SITE CHARGING
STATIONS ACCESS TO VOICE IN MY
FIVE SERVICES AND OTHER
CUSTOMER SUPPORT AS WELL AS
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
TO PUBLIC SAFETY ENTITIES. CARE
IS ALSO A OFFERED UNLIMITED
VOICE TEXT AND DATA SERVICES TO
AFFECTED CUSTOMERS BY OFFERING
CREDITS AND OR WAVING OVERAGE
CHARGES. AS MOST OF THE STATE
LEARNS HOW TO BETTER COPE WITH
THE SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS OF
SIGNIFICANT POWER SHUTDOWNS.
CARRIERS TO OUR LEARNING HOW TO
ADAPT TO REGULAR ON
AVAILABILITY OF COMMERCIAL
POWER AND HOW BEST TO MAINTAIN
NETWORK OPERATIONS UNDER SUCH
PREVIOUSLY EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES. AS ONE
RECOMMENDATION TO BUILD ON
GOING FORWARD WE WOULD SUGGEST
AND AS WE'VE HEARD AND ACTUALLY
WAS VERY PLEASED TO HEAR FROM-
FROM FROM BUT- DIRECTOR GUARD
TO CHEAP. OUT FROM PRESIDENT
BACHELOR. THAT PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES REGULATORS OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS SIT DOWN TOGETHER
AND IDENTIFY HOW WE CAN MOST
SUCCESSFULLY WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP DURING FUTURE SET
UP. NOT NECESSARILY IN
SITUATIONS LIKE THIS WHICH IS
REQUIRED- OVERSIGHT. BUT
INFORMALLY AROUND THE TABLE
OKAY WHAT DID YOU SEE HOW TO
JUST SEE WHAT WORKED WHAT
DIDN'T. BECAUSE WHEN WE GET IT
IN THE PROCEEDINGS CIRCUMSTANCE
WERE IN FRONT OF A COMMITTEE-
THE ABILITY TO KIND OF- TO
ENGAGE IN IN THAT THE KIND OF
DIALOGUE THAT WE THINK IS
REALLY THE WAY TO DO THIS
SOMETIMES. SOMETIMES IS LACKING.
SO WITH THAT WE ARE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUE OUR WORK TOGETHER
WITH THE STATE TO REPLACE
IDENTIFIED OBSTACLES AND I DID.
ALSO WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT
THE SUGGESTION OF STREAMLINING
WAS VERY IMPORTANT WE THINK AS
WE TRY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WE HAD AND THE AND THE
OBSTACLES WE HAD STREAMLINING.
THE APPROACH TO BE ABLE TO DO
WITH THAT I THINK IT'S Vç IS
VERY IMPORTANT. AND THE OTHER
ISSUE I DIDN'T WANT A PLAYOFF
AND A AND THE- CHAIR WEST SO
WAS VERY MUCH INVOLVED WITH
THIS IS THE ABILITY TO BRING ON
NEW INFRASTRUCTURE NOT JUST
UPGRADE THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT- AS YOU
BRING A NEW INFRASTRUCTURE YOU
CREATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO- TO
PUT. SERVICE IN AREAS WHERE
OTHERS MAY BE MAY GO DOWN- THAT
STILL A REAL CHALLENGE AND IT'S
A BIG CHALLENGE AND SOME OF THE
AREAS THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE WANTED T. THAT UP- FOR THE
GROUP ANYWAY- WANTED TO. THIS
OVER TO OUR OUR WITNESSES
PEOPLE WHO HAVE DEALT WITH THIS
ON THE GROUND LET ME START WITH
JEFF LEON OF EIGHTEEN T. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR AT. MY NAME IS
JEFF LONG I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF ACCESS
CONSTRUCTION AND ENGINEERING
FOR EIGHTEEN ANTI. MY TEAM IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE PLANNING
ENGINEERING CONSTRUCTION
MAINTENANCE AND OPERATION OF
WIRELESS AND WIRELINE
FACILITIES. ACROSS THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES INCLUDING
CALIFORNIA. I PREVIOUSLY HAD
NATION WIDE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
WIRELESS BUILD AN OPERATIONS
WHICH INCLUDES DISASTER
RECOVERY. IN THE AFTERMATH OF
MANY NATURAL DISASTERS
INCLUDING HURRICANE MARIA
SANDY. AND THE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS AND EVERYTHING ELSE IN
BETWEEN. THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY. AT
THE OUTSET I WANT TO SAY THAT
WE ARE COMMITTED TO PROVIDING
COMMUNICATION SERVICES THAT THE
PUBLIC. AND PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCY CAN RELY ON. EIGHTEEN T.
HAS OPERATED IN CALIFORNIA FOR
OVER ON YOU FORTY YEARS. WE
HAVE WORKED THROUGH MANY
EMERGENCIES. AND ENGAGE WITH
THE PUBLIC ON EVERY LEVEL. I'LL
TELL YOU THAT FROM MY TEAMS
PERSPECTIVE WE HAVE THAT
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WORKING
TIRELESSLY. BEFORE DURING AND
AFTER EACH OF THESE EVENTS TO
DEPLOY HUNDREDS OF ASSETS
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE GREATER
RELIABILITY LEVENTIS THAT. I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING STEVE
SAID I WANT TO PROVIDE SOME
INSIGHT ON WHAT EIGHTEEN T.
DOING TO DEAL WITH THE NEW
NORMAL FOR THE FUTURE OF P. S.
P. S. EVENTS. AT SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE. LET ME
BE BRIEF TOP BUT THREE ACTIONS
THAT WE'RE TAKING. FIRST. WE
HAVE IMPLEMENTED REPORTING
PROTOCOLS IN ACCORDANCE WITH SB
FIVE SIXTY AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
PARTNERS ON ENGAGEMENT DURING
DISASTERS THIS WILL INCLUDE
DISCUSSIONS WITH ELECTED
OFFICIALS STATE COUNTY TRIBAL
EMERGENCY RESPONSE PERSONNEL.
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMERGENCY ASSOCIATION.
ON COMMUNICATIONS STATE AND THE
HEARING WILL ALSO WORK WITH THE
POWER COMPANIES TO ENSURE THAT
TIMELY ACCURATE CRITICAL
INFORMATION IS RECEIVED TO
IMPROVE OUR RESPONSE GOING
FORWARD. SECOND. WE HAVE
CONVENE AN EXECUTIVE LEVEL
STRIKE FORCE TO ENHANCE NETWORK
RELIABILITY FOR THE NEXT FAR
SEASON ACTIONS TRIGGERED
INCLUDE INCREASED DEPLOYMENT OF
FIX GENERATORS AUGMENTING
HUNDREDS OF EXISTING CRITICAL
SITES AND AT STEVE MENTION ALSO
BUILDING HUNDREDS OF NEW CELL
SITES WOULD FIX GENERATORS.
ORDERS WERE ALREADY PLACE FOR
HUNDREDS OF ADDITIONAL PORTABLE
GENERATORS WE MANUFACTURE
COMMITMENT TO START DELIVERY.
IN THE COMING MONTHS. BATTERY
ENHANCEMENTS. AUTOMATION
INCLUDING ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE FOR POWER
MANAGEMENT CAPABILITIES ALSO ON
THE WAY. IN THE RECENT PS PS
THE VENTS MY TEAM WORKS HARD TO
MAINTAIN COMMUNICATIONS
ULTIMATELY ACHIEVING WIRELESS
COVERAGE AT 97% OF NORMAL
WITHIN THAT THIRTY FOUR AFFECT
THE COUNTIES DURING THE PEAK
HOLIDAY IN OCTOBER. HOWEVER OUR
GOAL IS ALWAYS A 100% SO WE
NEED TO BE THE- BEST A MORE
NEEDS TO BE DONE. GIVEN THE
ACTIONS THAT WE HAVE TAKEN. IF
THE SAME INCIDENT WERE TO OCCUR
IN TWENTY TWENTY WE WILL BE
EVEN BETTER PREPARED TO RESPOND.
FINALLY. WE ARE PREPARED TO
DRAMATICALLY IN WE INCREASE
CAPITAL INVESTMENT TO TRANSFORM
OUR NETWORK IN RESPONSE TO THIS
NEW NORMAL OF MASSIVE POWER
SHUT OFFS. OUR GOAL WE HOPE OUR
COMMERCIAL POWER COMPANIES WILL
BE MORE LIMITED. AND PRECISE IN
HOW THE IMPLEMENT P. S. P. S.
EVENTS GOING FORWARD WE STRIVE
TO HAVE A ROBUST NETWORK THAT
WILL WITHSTAND THE SCALE OF
OUTAGES THAT WE EXPERIENCE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. OUR PLAN
IS TO BUILD OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL FIX GENERATORS. AT
OTHER ALTERNATIVE POWER
RESOURCES AT NEW YOU AN
EXISTING CELL SITES. THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IN
OBTAINING PERMITS FOR OVER A
THOUSAND NEW GENERATORS IS A
MONUMENTAL UNDERTAKING. DUE TO
INCONSISTENT REQUIREMENTS
ACROSS JURISDICTIONS LINK THE
REVIEW TIMES OWNERS AND WE DONE
THEM PERMITTING CONDITIONS WE
EXPECT IT COULD TAKE THREE TO
FIVE YEARS TO GET ALL THOSE
GENERATORS PERMIT BUILT AN
OPERATIONAL. WE WOULD LIKE TO
GO FASTER. AND WE WANT TO GO
FASTER BUT THAT WOULD TAKE SOME
CHANGES IN THE CURRENT
PERMITTING STRUCTURE. THE CIVIC
LEE WE BELIEVE THAT SOME
TARGETED PERMITTING. TARGETED
PERMITTING STREAMLINING EFFORTS
FOR STANDARDIZED FIX GENERATORS.
COULD ALLOW US TO COMPLETE THE
BILL OF ALL FIX GENERATOR SITES
WITHIN ONE TO THREE YEARS.
EIGHTEEN ANTI IS ALSO EXPLORING
INNOVATIVE ALTERNATIVE ENERGY
TECHNOLOGIES INCLUDING HOW YOU
DOING FUEL CELLS AND SOLAR
POWER. LET ME CONCLUDE BY
SAYING AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THE DISCUSSION TODAY
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTIONS. AT AND T. IS
PREPARED TO HELP MEET THE
EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES.
CALIFORNIA FACES WE HAVE
INVESTED AND ARE PREPARED TO
IMPROVE OUR NETWORK RELIABILITY
FOR THE NEXT FAR SEASON FURTHER
WE ARE READY TO INCREASE
INVESTMENT TO TRANSFORM OUR
NETWORK TO ADDRESS WIDESPREAD
PS PS EVENTS. EIGHTEEN ANTI
WILL CONTINUE TO ACHIEVE
IMPROVE RESULTS FOR OUR
CUSTOMERS AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE IMPROVE
COLLABORATION AND CLOUT AND
COOPERATION AMONGST THE
AGENCIES ELECTED OFFICIALS OUR
CUSTOMERS AND TELECOMMUNICATION
INDUSTRIES THANK YOU. THE
MORNING- MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING SENATORS- MY NAME'S HAS
HIS FROM MINE I'M THE CHIEF
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL FOR VERIZON
I HAVE NEXT TO ME AT MY RIGHT
TO IT IS SAW SCOTT STEWART HE'S
OUR NETWORK ENGINEER HE BUILT
OUR SYSTEM WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR. A MORE TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
I ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
PARTNERS IN GOVERNMENT-
DIRECTOR GERD DO SHE FOR HIS
COMMENTS AND PRESIDENT BACHELOR
FOR HER COMMENTS ALONG WITH THE
REST OF THE PANELISTS- WE ARE
IN A SITUATION OF ON PRESIDENTE
AT- POWER SHUT OFF THIS IS
SOMETHING NEW WE DID NOT
EXPERIENCED US IN THE PAST TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE HAD THIS
PAST YEAR. BOB ARISES IT WAS A
VERY PROUD YES THE DAY. ABOUT
HOW OUR NETWORK CONTINUE TO
SERVE OUR CUSTOMERS DURING-
THESE PROACTIVE SHOT OFFICE IN
OCTOBER. I WANT TO NOW
VERIZON'S STEPPED UP. NUMBER
ONE IS WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN
PROACTIVE BUT EVEN MORE
PROACTIVE IN PREPARING OUR
NETWORK WITH BACKUP POWER
SOURCES ALL OF OUR MACROS WHICH
PROVIDE THE COVERAGE FOR
CONNECTIVITY HAVE BACKUP POWER
SOURCES AND MOST OF THEM HAVE
GENERATORS THAT PROVIDE BOB
BACKUP POWER FOR TWENTY FOUR TO
SEVENTY TWO HOURS. WE WERE ALSO
VERY PROACTIVE IN COMMUNICATING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF THE
NETWORK SO WHILE OUR NETWORK IS.
VERY RESILIENT WITH BACKUP
POWER SOURCES WE KNOW THAT
THERE ARE CERTAIN CERTAIN
DISCRETE AREAS THAT- WILL
SUFFER DEGRADATION OR LOSS OF
POWER DURING A POWER OUTAGE I'M
ONE OF THOSE PLACES ARE A
CENTER SKINNER IN THE BERKELEY
HILLS- OAKLAND HILLS- WE
ACTUALLY HAVE BEEN THINKING
ABOUT THAT QUITE A BIT AND COME
UP WITH A SOLUTION FOR THAT.
I'M AFRAID YOU MIGHT OF
THROWING A LITTLE BIT OF COLD
WATER ON OUR SOLUTION BOB IT'S
COUPLE TO SPEAK TO WITHOUT A
LITTLE LATER. WE AT OURSELVES
WITH- SO IN TERMS OF THE
PROACTIVE COMMUNICATING- WE
ARE. SPOKE WITH CALLOW YES
PRIOR TO THE POWER SHUT OFF WE
SPOKE WITH- DIFFERENT
LEGISLATORS. WITH CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS WITH LOCAL YOU'LL SEIZE
ABOUT WHERE WE WOULD EXPECT TO
HAVE SOME POTENTIAL. IMPACTS ON
OUR NETWORK. THIS WAS SOMETHING
NEW FOR US OUR- UNDERSTANDING
HOW WIDESPREAD. THIS POWER
OUTAGE WAS GOING TO BE WE SAID
THIS IS NOT A TIME FOR US TO.
TO WAIT AND REACT WE HAVE TO BE
PROACTIVE SO WE ACTUALLY WENT
OUT AND SPOKE WITH- A LOT OF
FOLKS AND LET THEM KNOW. EXIT
THE FOLS ABOUT WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN ON OUR NETWORK. IN THAT
IT OURSELVES A CALLOW YES STATE
OPERATIONS CENTER AND OPENLY
AND CONSISTENTLY COMMUNICATE
WITH CARILLO YES TO PROVIDE
THEM REAL TIME- MISSION
CRITICAL INFORMATION. IN FACT
ON DAY ONE- WE HAD A FELLOW
NAMED JOHN LAWLER AT FOUR PM
AVAILABLE FOR THE BRIEFING THAT
CALLOW YES HAD ONE DAY
TRIGGERED. THEIR LEVEL ONE OUR
STATE OPERATIONS CENTER SO AND
I KNOW PRESIDENT BACHELOR-
MENTIONED THAT THERE WERE VERY
FEW PEOPLE THERE- THAT VERY
FIRST DAY WELL WE WERE ONE OF
THE FEW THAT WERE THERE. WEEK
HELLO YES INFORMED THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO INFORM THE
CPUC INFORMED- ALONG WITH OTHER
STRAIGHT STAKEHOLDERS ON A
DAILY BASIS AS TO THE
PERFORMANCE OF OUR NETWORK I
WAS ONE OF THE QUESTIONS THAT
WE WERE TOLD THAT THIS PANEL
TODAY WAS GOING TO ASK AS WE
KNOW HOW WELL WERE YOU
COMMUNICATING WITH THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS VERIZON
PRIDES ITSELF IN THE FACT THAT
NOT ONLY DID IT PROACTIVELY
COMMUNICATE BUT IT
COMMUNICATED- DURING THE DAY ON
REQUEST TWO OR THREE TIMES A
DAY WE WILL PROVIDE CALLOW
BUSES ARE UP. ON A REAL TIME
BASIS AT THE TOP ACT WE PROVIDE
AID END OF DAY COMMUNICATIONS
TO ALL THE CYCLE. WE ALSO RAISE
THE BAR ON TRANSPARENCY BY
PROVIDING PUBLICLY THE
PERCENTAGE OF CELL SITES IN
OPERATIONS IN THE IMPACTED. OUR
POWER SHUT OFF AREAS IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE DID BEFORE-
WE MADE A CORPORATE DECISION
THAT WE WERE GOING TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT. ABOUT THIS AND BY
ON A GOING FORWARD BASIS WE
INTEND TO BE TRANSPARENT. THE
RESULTS OF ALL OF OUR WORK WAS
THAT OUR NETWORK. SHOWED GREAT
RESILIENCY DUE TO OUR BACK UP
POWER RESOURCES ARE OVERLAPPING
CELL SITE DESIGN. AND ARE
RUNNING TO THE CRISIS WITH THE
DEPLOYMENT OF TEMPORARY ASSETS
SUCH AS CAL'S COLD SPOTS IN
PORTABLE GENERATORS WERE NEEDED.
AND SO PART OF THE RESULTS WAS
FOR EXAMPLE AT THE HEIGHT OF
THE VENTS ON OCTOBER TWENTY
EIGHTH. THE FCC REPORTED ON
AGGREGATE 27% OF WIRELESS
SERVICE CELL SITES WERE OUT OF
SERVICE AND SOMEONE COUNTY. THE
TO THE POWERSHOT AWESOME WELL
VERIZON ONLY EXPERIENCE 7% OF
SITES OUT OF SERVICE AT THE
TIME. NOW THAT 7% IS NOT
SOMETHING TO CROW ABOUT-
BECAUSE WE HAVE TO DO BETTER
AND WE OF KNOWLEDGE THAT. BUT
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO SAY IS OUR
RESILIENCY ACTUALLY SHOWED UP%
IN THE NUMBERS. THE SAME IS FOR
MARIN COUNTY MARIN COUNTY THERE
WAS A 57% CELL SITES OUT OF
SERVICE ACCORDING TO THE- DERS
REPORTS. ARISES OUT OF SERVICE
WAS 8% OF ITS CELL SITES BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT COVERAGE
WAS AL. BECAUSE WE HAVE THIS
OVERLAP IN THE SIGN AND WE HAVE
THE TEMPORARY ASSETS THAT WE
DEPLOY. AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
METRIC THAT WE NEED TO DISCUSS
IN THIS COLLABORATIVE. AS WE GO
FORWARD IN A COLLABORATIVE
MANNER IS WHAT DOES IT REALLY
MEAN FOR CELL SITE TO BE OUT
DOES THAT MEAN THAT COVERAGES
OUT. NOT NECESSARILY AND
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
REALLY BE CAREFUL ABOUT
EQUATING CELL SITES OUT WITH
COVERAGE OUT. WE THINK THAT
THERE IS A REAL NEED FOR
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN INDUSTRY
THE ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND
GOVERNMENT AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO COME UP WITH
SOLUTIONS TO THE- PRESIDENTE
CHALLENGES CLIMATE CHANGE HAS
IMPOSED ON CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PREPARED TO PARTNER WITH
CALIFORNIA TO DEVELOP THE
SENSIBLE AND FEASIBLE
SOLUTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND I FORGOT TO CLARIFY THAT
MISTER CARLSON MISTER LONG AND
MR AMMAN. ARE REPRESENTING THE
WIRELESS INDUSTRY WE HAVE
CAROLINE MACINTYRE REPRESENTING
THE CABLE INDUSTRY AND- JOHN
LUNDGREN. IS REPRESENTING
WIRELESS LINE SO NOW WE'LL HEAR
FROM CARE A MISS MCINTYRE AND
THEN MISTER. LONGER. ABSOLUTELY
AS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS CAROLINE MCINTYRE
IN BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CABLE AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
INDUSTRY THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION'S MEMBERS WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
DIALOGUE WE UNDERSTAND HOW. WE
CAN PROVIDE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE
AND WORK TOGETHER ON THE
PRACTICAL REALISTIC AND
WORKABLE SOLUTIONS FOR KEEPING
CALIFORNIA'S SAFE. AT THE CABLE
INDUSTRY HAS INVESTED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO BUILD AND
MAINTAIN STATE OF THE ART
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS CAPABLE
OF DELIVERING SUPERIOR
BROADBAND VIDEO INVOICE SERVICE
FOR CALIFORNIANS. WHETHER
EXPANDING NETWORKS TO PROVIDE
FASTER BROADBAND OFFERING HIGH
SPEED VALUE WIRELINE VOICE
SERVICE AND MOBILE SERVICES OR
DELIVERING VIDEO PROGRAMMING
THE MEMBERS THE CC TA CONTINUE
TO INNOVATE AND INVEST IN THE
NETWORK INFRASTRUCTURE
BENEFITING CALIFORNIANS. ALL OF
THE CTA'S MEMBERS TAKE NETWORK
RELIABILITY VERY SERIOUSLY AND
WORK HARD TO ENSURE OUR BACK UP
SERVICE IN THE EVENT OF
COMMERCIAL POWER OUTAGE IS. THE
ELECTRIC UTILITY P. S. P. S. C.
VETS LAST YEAR WERE
UNPRECEDENTED IN SCOPE SCALE
AND HAVE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
THE STATE'S COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS THAT RELY ON
COMMERCIAL POWER. WE AGREE WITH
THE GOVERNOR THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES THE CPUC THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE THAT
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR CANNOT
HAPPEN AGAIN. THE CABLE
INDUSTRY IS COMMITTED TO
FINDING SOLUTIONS THERE ARE
SEVERAL KEY PRINCIPLES THAT WE
VIEW WAS FUNDAMENTAL TO
UNDERSTANDING THE CHALLENGES
AND FINDING EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS
TO SUPPORT PUBLIC SAFETY. IN A
P. S. P. S. OR OTHER EMERGENCY.
LET ME JUST START BY SAYING
THAT IT IS UNFAIR AND
UNREASONABLE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE CPC TO
ALLOW THE ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO
DE ENERGIZED THEIR NETWORKS AND
EXPECT THAT THE COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORK IS GOING TO BECOME A
WHOLESALE REPLACEMENT. FOR
POWER 21100% OUR THE
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK. THE
COMMUNICATIONS NETWORK IS IN
FACT DEPENDENT UPON COMMERCIAL
POWER AND WHILE WE DO HAVE
BACKUP POWER IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT MOST OF OUR FACILITIES
BATTERIES AND THEN GENERATORS
WE CANNOT BE EXPECTED TO KEEP
UP 1100% OF THE NETWORK UNLESS
YOU ARE WILLING TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND MAKE CERTAIN CONCESSIONS
FOR CHALLENGES THAT WE BUT HAVE
DOING CELL WE ARE COMMITTED TO
KEEPING POWER AND CAPABLE OF
KEEPING POWER UP TO OUR MAIN
FACILITIES ARE HEAD ENDS. KEEP
BEING AT THE BACK HOME POWER
FOR- WIRELESS SERVICES TO
SUPPORT CELL TOWERS I'VE BEEN
READING TO SUPPORT FIRST
RESPONDERS TO SUPPORT CRITICAL
FACILITIES ALL THROUGH AN
IDENTIFICATION PROCESS IN
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT BUT TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU ARE EXPECTING THAT WE
WILL BE ABLE TO KEEP 1100% OF
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS. CAN DID
AND HAVING THE ABILITY TO HAVE
CONTENT AS MEDICATION YOU HAVE
TO RECOGNIZE THAT ARE
CHALLENGES WITH. THE I AS I
INDICATED THE K. YLIDES DO IN
FACT HAVE BACKUP BATTERIES THE
FACILITIES THAT ACTUALLY
PROVIDE THAT LAST MILE
CONNECTIVE ITTY TO THE
RESIDENTIAL CONSUMER WILL IN
FACT LAST ON BACK UP BATTERY
POWER FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME. THERE AFTER YOU WERE
GOING TO HAVE TO BRING IN
PORTABLE GENERATORS OR OTHER
SOURCES OF POWER IN ORDER TO
POWER THAT NETWORK WE CALL
THOSE FACILITIES THAT ARE
PROVIDING THAT LAST MILE
CONNECTIVE ITTY. AND UPLOAD. WE
HAVE. IN EXCESS OF FIFTY
THOUSAND NOTES THAT ARE PART OF
THE CABLE NETWORKS IN
CALIFORNIA. ONE NOTE SERVES
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
HOUSEHOLDS THAT IS TWO HUNDRED
PORTABLE GENERATORS THAT WE
WOULD HAVE TO BRING INTO A
COMMUNITY TO ENSURE THAT POWER
CONTINUES TO BE AVAILABLE TO
THAT NETWORK INTO THAT
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS HOW. EVEN
IF WE ARE CAPABLE OF DOING THAT.
THERE ARE STILL CHALLENGES WITH
WHETHER OR NOT THE CONSUMER
WOULD BE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
UTILIZE THE SERVICE ONE THEY
MUST HAVE A BACK UP BATTERY FOR
THE VEAL PIE V. O. I. P. SYSTEM
SECONDLY MOST CONSUMERS ARE
ALSO GOING TO BE DEPENDED UPON
SOME SORT OF ENERGY SOURCE IN
THEIR HOME TO POWER. THEIR
COMMUNICATION DEVICE. I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE GHETTO POT
SYSTEM I AM TALKING ABOUT THAT
TELEPHONE SYSTEM THAT MANY VOID
CUSTOMERS COMMUNICATE OVER THAT
MAY BE A CORDLESS PHONE OR SOME
OTHER TYPE OF INSTRUMENT THAT
DEPENDS ON ELECTRICITY. IN
ADDITION JUST TO GET THOSE
PORTABLE GENERATORS OUT TO
THOSE COMMUNITIES WE'VE GOT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES WE'VE GOT
NAME BE ISSUES WE'VE GOT
INCONSISTENCIES WITH THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS VERY MISSION
GOALS. THERE ARE MANY MANY
CHALLENGES SO WE ASK THAT AS WE
COLLECTIVELY LOOK TO FIND
SOLUTIONS IN A SPACE THAT WE
TAKE ALL OF THOSE FACTORS INTO
CONSIDERATION. OUR PRIORITY
RECOGNIZING THAT 80% OF THE
CALLS THAT GO INTO NINE ONE ONE
ARE COMING FROM WIRELESS
NETWORKS WE HAVE MADE PROVIDING
BACKUP POWER TO THE BACK HOME
NETWORK THAT SUPPORTS THE CELL
SYSTEM OUR PRIORITY. TO PROVIDE
AS MUCH CERTAINTY ON OUR END
IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE
CONNECTIVE ITTY IS ULTIMATELY
THERE THAT WOULD BE NEEDED BY
THE WIRELESS COMPANIES TO
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THEIR
SERVICE. THERE IS NO ONE SIZE
FITS ALL SOLUTION HERE- AS
COMMISSIONER I'M SORRY DIRECTOR
GIRLY DID YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER- OUR INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
IN COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES-
OUR COMPANIES ALSO HAVE LOCAL
PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOLKS THAT ARE.
ALWAYS IN CONTACT WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND WE ARE LOOKING
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
COLLABORATION TO WORK WITH- WE
ASKED TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST-
REPORTING PROTOCOLS AND
PARTNERSHIPS WITH- WITH- YES
AND OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT
PARTNERS. AND MANY OF THE
CURRENT LAWS THAT ARE ON THE
BOOKS ALREADY PROVIDE AN
ADEQUATE FRAMEWORK FOR US TO
MAKE SOME IMPROVEMENTS IN THIS
SPACE INCLUDING CENTER
MAGUIRE'S SB SIX SEVENTY WHICH
I WE **** IN THE PROCESS OF. AS
DEVELOPING REGULATIONS THE
LEADERSHIP OF LOCAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT OFFICIALS IS ALSO
GOING TO BE VERY IMPORTANT IN
THIS SPACE IN THAT WE NEED TO
WORK WITH PHÃN COLLABORATIVE
LEAD TO IDENTIFY THOSE CRITICAL
FACILITIES AND OTHER LOCAL
PUBLIC SAFETY PRIORITIES THAT
WE MESSED IT MIGHT MUST FOCUS
ON DURING A P. S. P. S. OR
OTHER EMERGENCY. CABLE
OPERATORS CAN HELP PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS TO MEET THE
INDIVIDUAL COUNTY NEEDS AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES PRIORITIES
BASED ON THE MOST RELIABLE AND
ASSESSABLE TECHNOLOGIES WE LOOK
FORWARD TO COLLABORATING- WITH
THOSE AGENCIES AS I INDICATED
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU MISTER ALONG WITH. HELLO
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK SENATORS- MY NAME IS JOHN
LUNDGREN HIRING DIRECTOR
NETWORK SERVICES VICE PRESIDENT
WALKING A TELEPHONE COMPANY-
I'VE BEEN ASKED TO SPEAK FROM A
SMALL LOCAL STRANGER
PERSPECTIVE TODAY AND HOW IT
AFFECTS US IN THESE SITUATIONS.
GIVE A LITTLE BACKGROUND
VOLCANO- IS FIFTY FIVE MILES
SOUTHEAST OF SACRAMENTO NOT
VERY FAR FROM HERE ANSWERS FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTEEN SQUARE MILES
MUCH OF WHICH IS HIGHER FOOT
HILL AREAS TO VERY MOUNTAINOUS
AREAS WE HAVE NINE THOUSAND
TELEPHONE ACCESS LINES SEVENTY
THREE HUNDRED DSL INTERNET
CUSTOMERS CURRENTLY ABOUT 10%
OF OUR BASES SERVE WITH FIBER
DIRECTOR HOME. BOB WE SERVE THE
EASTERN PART OF AMADOR COUNTY
TO THE KIRKWOOD SKI AREA- IN
THE MOUNTAINS HAND ALSO SERVE
VERY SMALL PORTIONS OF ELDORADO
ALPINE COUNTY. IN ADDITION WE
SERVE NORTHERN PORTIONS OF
CALAVERAS COUNTY. IT'S THE
OTHER SMALL WORKS IN THE STATE
ARE VERY SIMILAR IN NATURE TO
THE TRAIN AND CANARIES THEY
COVER AND MANY OF A REPRESENT
IN THIS ROOM THIS MORNING
BECAUSE THEY FEEL THIS IS THE-
IMPORTANT. SITUATION. TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE FLAVOR WE HAVE
ALMOST TWO HUNDRED SPERRY SMALL
REMOTES TO SERVE OUR CUSTOMER
BASE- FIFTY OF WHICH HAVE AC
COMMERCIAL POWER TO THE
REMAINDER OF THEM WE USE THE
EXISTING COPPER NETWORK WE HAVE
TO ONE POWER. SO THIS IS IN
ORDER TO GET WITHIN FOUR
THOUSAND FOOT LOPS OF COPPER
TO GET BROADBAND OUT TO OUR
CUSTOMERS THE DISTANCE BATES. I
AM KIND OF PROGRESS.
APPROACHING THIS FROM MORE
BOOTS ON THE GROUND ABOUT.
APPROACHES THAT ACTUALLY
ACTUALLY GOING OUT ON SOME OF
THESE CALLS MYSELF AND CAN
WORKING THROUGH THESE THINGS.
THE CALIFORNIA UNTIL THE
EMERGENCY ASSOCIATION AFTER THE
FIRST P. S. P. S. SENT OUT A
QUESTIONNAIRE. AM I THOUGHT IT
WOULD JUST BE THE BEST WAY TO
CONNECTING CAPS LATE KIND WHAT
WE EXPERIENCE JUST BY. KIND OF
REVIEW THAT WITH YOU WHAT I
WHAT I SENT BACK TO THEM. SO. I
SHOULD START OUT BY INDICATING
THAT AT LEAST FOR THE FOR THE
AREA OF ALL CAN A TELEPHONE
COMEY SERVICE THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST EVENT LIKE THIS WE HAVE
EXPERIENCE THROUGH THE YEARS WE
HAVE HAD NUMEROUS SNOWSTORMS
LIGHTNING STORMS THE BUTTE FIRE
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN ANOTHER
EVENTS THAT HAVE COST P. GINNY
SERVICE TO BE DISRUPTED FOR
EXTENDED PERIODS OF TIME. OVER
THE YEAR WE'VE DEVELOPED A
BACKUP SYSTEMS AND THEIR
PRACTICE FOR AN EVENT LIKE
THIS. BUT FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS. THE IRONIC THING ABOUT
THIS EVENT WAS IT WAS PRETTY
MUCH LAID OUT. AS TO WHAT WAS
GOING TO FAIL MORE OR LESS WHEN
AND WHERE. IF THE VANCE WE'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN HAVE AN
UNPLANNED AND THE FAILURES ARE
NOT KNOWN BEFORE THE BEGINNING
OF THE EVENT. AND WE'RE THE
FAILURES WORLD HER. TO I SHOULD
PROBABLY HAVE THAT THIS WAS
AFTER THE FIRST PSP US ABOUT
THAT WE HAVE. WHAT IMPACTS DID
THE PS PS INCIDENT HAVE ON YOUR
TELLY. AS WE ARE BATTERIES AT
ALL SITES AND GENERATORS AND
ALMOST ALL OF OUR REMOTE
SERVICES SITES FOR TELEPHONE
SERVICE AS WELL AS INTERNET
SERVICE DSL ADDRESS FIBER ONLY.
WE WENT THROUGH MOST OF OUR
OUTAGE WITHOUT ANY INCIDENTS.
IN THE MOST CRITICAL PARTS OF
OUR NETWORK AT THE PEAK OF THE
PSP HOUSE. WE HAD FORTY SIX
PLUS GENERATORS IN OPERATION.
WHEN THE INCIDENT STARTED.
THERE WERE FOUR SITES THE
GENEROUS DID NOT START WE
CORRECTED TO THE SITES BEFORE
THE BATTERS RICH PLEADED SO.
THOSE AREAS NEVER EXPERIENCED
ANYTHING. ONE OF THOSE SITES
WAS A LITTLE LARGER SO THAT WAS
A GOOD THING. THERE WERE TWO
SMALLER SITES THAT FAILED TO
START AND THE BATTERIES WERE
DEPLETED. AND WE HAD VERY VERY
BRIEF OUTAGES ONE OF THE YEAR'S
EXPERIENCE SEVENTY MINUTES OF
DOWNTIME AFFECTED A PROXY ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY CUSTOMERS. THE
OTHER SITE THAT FAILED
EXPERIENCE ABOUT NINETY MINUTES
DOWNTIME. BEFORE WAS CORRECTED
IN THE AFFECTED ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIVE CUSTOMERS. AS WE
STRADDLED THE PHASE ONE AND
PHASE TWO LINES. FOR THE FIRST
PSP ELSE. BEING BEING IN BOTH
AMADOR CALAVERAS COUNTY WE HAVE
A SMALL AMOUNT OF AREA. THAT
HAD THE POWER TURNED OFF ON THE
SECOND DAY. IT'S MOSTLY A LINE
THAT FEEDS THE QUIRK WITH SKI
RESORT DIRECTLY. THERE'S ONE
VERY SMALL REMOTE SITE. IN THE
BEAR RIVER AREA THAT FEEDS OFF
OF THIS PLANET KERR QUIT. WE
ALSO HAVE A GENERATOR FAILURE
AT THAT SITE. THE BATTERIES DID
ALSO GOOD DAD BEFORE ABLE TO
RECTIFY THE SITUATION AS IT
TURNS OUT THIS GENERATOR HAVE A
MUCH MORE SERIOUS ISSUE. AND WE
HAD TO PLAY TEMPORARY PORTABLE
UNIT TO CORRECT. BY THE TIME WE
HAVE SERVICE IN THE RESTORED
ABOUT SIX HOURS AND EFFECTIVE
NO MORE THAN FORTY ONE
CUSTOMERS AS A MATTER OF FACT
IT'S A VERY REMOTE- RESORT AREA
AND- BY THAT TIME OF THE YEAR
I'M NOT EVEN SURE ANYBODY WAS
THERE. BUT WE STILL GOT RUNNING.
THAT WAS THE EXTENT OF
ORGANIZATIONS RESPECT OUR
TELEPHONE INTERNET SERVICES. WE
ALSO PROVIDE VIDEO CABLE
TELEVISION OTHER INTERNET CABLE
MODEM SERVICE AND A SELECT AREA
BOTH COUNTIES THESE ARE ALL
AREAS WHERE WE ARE NOT THE LACK.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT NETWORK.
AND THERE ARE ONLY BATTERIES
AND NOT GENEROUS AND MOST OF
THE SITES WE LOST MOST OF THESE
AREAS WHEN THE BATTERIES DIED.
THIS NETWORK IS LARGELY. NOT
MISSION CRITICAL AND THAT'S WHY
I SAY THAT IS WE ONLY DO VIDEO
ACROSS THAT NETWORK EXCEPT FOR
THE CHAIRMAN EMERITUS. ENHANCE
HISTORICALLY HAD NOT BEEN
BACKED UP THE SAME. AS A MORE
CRITICAL PARTS OF OTHER
NETWORKS IN ADDITION VOLCANO
PROVIDES WIRELESS INTERNET
SERVICE TO SOME OF THE MORE
REMOTE OR HIS FAMILY- CALORIES
COUNTY. ONCE AGAIN WE HAVE
BANNERS TO VIRTUALLY ALL THE
SITES BUT NO GENERATORS WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF TWO CRITICAL
BACK WHOLE SITES. WHERE WE DID
DEPLOY PORTABLE GENERATORS. ANY
SITES WITHOUT POWER QUIT AFTER
THAT IS A COMPLETELY SWIRLS
AREAS. SOME OF THE AREAS THAT
WE SERVE WITH THE WIRELESS
INTERNET WAS NOT AFFECTED BY
THE PSP HOUSE. WHICH IS THE
REASON THAT WE ONE HAND PULLING
THE GENERATORS. DID YOU HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO FORTY
RESPONSIBILITIES AND MISSION IF
NOT COULD YOU ACQUIRE THEM BY
OTHER MEANS. WHILE WE HAD
ENOUGH PROPANE. IS A RESOURCE
THAT MIGHT HAVE BECOME AN ISSUE
A CERTAIN POINT THE VENDOR WE
USE IS VERY RESPONSIVE BUT THEY
HAVE THEIR HANDS FULL TRYING TO
KEEP PROPANE TANKS FILLED IN
THE AREA AS MANY CUSTOMERS ARE
AREAS HAVE HOME GENERATORS. HOW
DID YOU SET PRIORITIES AND
WHERE WERE THEY- I WHAT WERE
THEY- FOR THIS INSTANCE. AS
WITH MOST OF THEM WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED OUR COMPANY LARGELY
DISCONTINUES OUR CONSTRUCTION
AND DAY TO DAY OPERATION AND
GOES INTO NETWORK MAINTAIN
VOTE. FOR EXAMPLE WITH NUMEROUS
GENERATORS WE ALSO HAVE AN EVEN
LARGER AMOUNT OF PROPANE TANKS
AT THE SITES. MANY SITES HAVE
TO LEARN FOR THE GALLON PROPANE
TANKS. THAT ON AVERAGE ALLOW
SITE TO RUN FROM THREE TO SEVEN
DAYS IF THE TANKS ARE FULL MANY
OTHER SITES ONLY HAVE FIFTY
GALLON TANKS OR IN SOME CASES
TO FOR THE CONTACTS. AND CAN
ONLY RUN THE SITE FOR TWO DAYS
OR LESS IT IS NECESSARY FIRST
TO REFILL FIFTY GALLON TANKS.
WHICH WE HAVE A PORTABLE
FILLING STATION. OUR
CONSTRUCTION HARD. AND THEN
HALL TANKS THE VERY SITES IN
EXCHANGE THE TANKS FOR THE
EMPTY ONES. ANOTHER EXAMPLE IS
OUR TO VEHICLE MECHANICS ARE
PRETTY MUCH. CLEARLY CONSUMED
KEEPING ALL THE GENERATORS
RUNNING MAINTAINING THEM
CHECKING THEM. HOW DID YOU
TRIAGE ACTIVITIES AND HOW WERE
THEY DRESSED IN THE PRIORITY.
WITH THE EXCEPTION THE FIRST
MORNING ACTIVITIES WE KEPT UP
WITH HOLE OR NECESSARY TASKS
LARGER IS MENTIONED IN THE
FIRST QUESTION. IS POSSIBLY THE
ONLY EXAMPLE OF TRIAGE AND
PROBABLY MOSTLY WHY WE HAVE THE
SEVENTY MIN AVERAGE AT THE
SECOND SITE. AS WE WERE
CORRECTING LARGER SITE FIRST.
WHAT LESSONS WERE LEARNED IN
ADDITION SHARE ANY OTHER
THOUGHTS THAT YOU MAY HAVE THE
MEMBERS UTILITIES TO BENEFIT
FROM THIS EXPERIENCE. PROBABLY
LESSON LEARNED FROM THIS OUTAGE
IN KNOWING MORE THESE EVENTS
ARE PROBABLY COMING. IS TO
BEGIN TO IDENTIFY SOME OF THE
LARGER IS THAT WE PROVIDE KILL
MODEM INTERNET SERVICE AN
ATTEMPT TO HAVE BACKUP POWER TO
THOSE SITES. AS A START AND WE
HAVE A RECORDING ORDER
APPOINTMENT TO DO SUCH AS- IT
WOULD REQUIRE MORE THAN SEVENTY
ADDITIONAL GENERATORS TO COVER
ALL OF OUR VIDEO AREAS THE
FAILED DURING THIS PSP US. THIS
IS JUST NOT PRACTICAL WAS
CONSIDERING OUR SIZE. WITH THE
ADDITIONAL MANPOWER THAT WOULD
REQUIRE. ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF A
LESSON LEARNED A LONG TIME
BEFORE THIS EVER HAPPENS WITH
OUR FIBER THE PRIM SERVICE IN
MANY OF OUR READERS WE PROVIDE
FIBER TO THE PLAN WE USE OUR
EXISTING COPPER NETWORK TO
POWER THE OPTICAL NETWORK
TERMINAL THAT'S ON THE SIDE OF
THE HOUSE. AND DO NOT RELY ON
THE COMMERCIAL POWER OR
BATTERIES. AS LONG AS WE KEEP
OUR REMOTE SITES RUNNING WITH
GENERATORS AND BATTERIES WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE TELEPHONE
SERVICE. TO THE CUSTOMERS.
LEGACY TELEPHONE SERVICE TO THE
CUSTOMERS ARE. IN THE HOME AS
WELL AS INTERNET SERVICE AGAIN
AS LONG AS THE CUSTOMER HAS A
GENERATOR IN YOUR HOME. VERSION
AND I'M GONNA I'M GONNA CUT YOU
OFF THERE OKAY I JUST WANTED
ASK BABY THE PANEL A QUESTION
REGARDING. THE WAY. RESPONSES
ARE COORDINATED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE FIFTY
COUNTIES. THEY RANGE FROM
COUNTIES LIKE THE ONE YOU SERVE
AN ALPINE WHICH HAS ABOUT A
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND I'M TO. LA
COUNTY WHICH HAS TEN MILLION.
AND NOT EVERY COUNTY HAS A
RESOURCES TO COME UP WITH
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PLAN SO
WHERE WE DO HAVE A COUNTY LIKE
ALPINE. IS THERE ARE SPECIFIC.
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THAT COUNTY
TO HELP IN CASE OF EMERGENCIES
OR IS THAT SOMETHING THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TAKES OVER
WITHIN ITS RESOURCES. PROBABLY
DEPENDS A LOT ON WORKS OUT- WE
HAVE FIBER AND MUCH MUCH OF THE
JANUARY UP IN THAT AREA BUT WE
ONLY JUST VERY TOUCH A VERY
SMALL PORTION OF ALPINE COUNTY.
IN THE QUICKLY MASON WHETHER
SKI RESORT US IS IN IN YOUR
EXPERIENCE AS THE INDUSTRY IS
THERE DO YOU COORDINATE WHAT
THE COUNTIES TO COME UP WITH A
RESPONSE PLAN IN CASE OF
EMERGENCIES. ANY KIND OF
EMERGENCY IS SOME AND WE KNOW
THAT IN SOME PARTS OF THE STATE
THEY HAVE REVERSED NINE ONE ONE
AND THEY HAVE. DIFFERENT KIND
OF COMMUNICATIONS OR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS- PROGRAMS.
TO ASSISTANT. BUT TO THE COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY COME UP WITH A
PLAN THAT YOU'RE INVOLVED IN
THANK YOU TO HELP DESIGN THAT
YOU PROVIDE INPUT INTO IN TERMS
OF.WHAT YOU'RE YOU WHAT-
SERVICES YOU CAN PROVIDE IN THE
IN THE. IN THE CASE OF AN
EMERGENCY- WHERE THE COUNTY HAS
HIS RESPONSIBILITIES YOU HAVE
THERE'S AN EXAMPLE IN SAINT
EQUAL WE HAD WHAT DURING THESE
OUTAGES INCENDIO COUNTY WE HAD
A LOT OF ELDERLY- INDIVIDUALS
WITH SOME OF THAT WERE HATS
MOBILITY ISSUES THAT ONCE THEIR
POWER WAS CUT OFF THEY COULDN'T.
TRANSPORTERS SELVES TO. A
HOSPITAL CLINIC OR TO AN AREA
THAT HAD AIR CONDITIONING OR
HAVE THAT OUR FOOD OR WATER.
AND SO THERE THEY WERE CALLING
MY OFFICE ASKING FOR
TRANSPORTATION ASKING FOR
SUPPORT THAT WAS NOT BE
PROVIDED. IF THAT IS NOT
INCLUDED IN TO DELIVER IT
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE COUNTY
IS I MEAN WHAT WHAT CURRENTLY
EXISTS AND INFRASTRUCTURE WITH
REGARDS TO THE COUNTIES OR EVEN
THE STATE IN RESPONDING IN
THESE ELEMENTS YEAH I CAN SPEAK
FOR EIGHTEEN T. SPECIFICALLY SO
WE HAVE EXTERNAL AFFAIRS-
RESOURCES TO ENGAGE WITH
GOVERNMENT AT EVERY LEVEL RIGHT
AT THE LOCAL. CITY LEVEL AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AT THE STATE WHAT
LEVEL AS WELL A INCLUDING
INTERFACING WITH- EMERGENCY
RESPONDING OR FIRST IS ON THE
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL TOO SO
WHAT WE DO IS BASED ON THOSE
ENGAGEMENTS AND THE FEEDBACK
THAT WE GET IN TERMS OF THOSE
CRITICAL SITUATION THAT YOU
DESCRIBED HEREIN- WHAT WHAT IT
IS A CLEAR TO YOU WHAT
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE BY
EVERY GOVERNMENT. AGENCY IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY CAN TO
PROVIDE SUPPORT TO THE PEOPLE
IN THE STATE NOT TO ME
SPECIFICALLY BUT- I RUN THE
NETWORK AND I'M NOT NEXT DOOR
FERTILIZATION BUT WHAT IS CLEAR
TO ME THOUGH IS THAT WE DO GET
CLEAR COMMUNICATION TO WHERE
THE CRITICAL AREAS ARE AND WE
PRIORITIZE OUR WE- INSURE. HELP
PATIENT NETWORK STAYS UP TO
SUPPORT THE CRITICAL IT IS A
CLEAR TO ANYBODY AT THIS TABLE
TERMS. OF WHAT'S AVAILABLE. AND
SOME. A GOVERNMENT PLAN
AMOUNTS. TO THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE IN CASE OF EMERGENCY I'VE
NOTICED A CHAIRMAN THAT. DOES
REQUIRE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
DEVELOP A LOCAL EMERGENCY
SERVICES PLAN. THAT WE AND
OTHERS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL HAVE
N OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN. I'M NOT CERTAIN HOW
FREQUENTLY THEY UPDATE THOSE
PLANS- BUT THOSE PLAN SHOULD IN
FACT INCLUDE IDENTIFICATION OF
MANY THE TYPES OF THINGS THAT
YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT. OKAY LET'S
FOR HELP AND I CAN I CAN SAY IN
OUR CASE WE HAVE SHARED THAT
WITH THE VARIOUS COUNTIES THAT.
WERE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE ISAND- YOU KNOW KIND OF MADE THEM
AWARE OF. WHERE THE KEY POINT
I'M INTERESTED IN KNOWING LIKE
IN A AND THAT MY COUNTY LIKE
ALPINE WHAT RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THAT. BUT WE
COULD DEFINITELY LOOK INTO THAT
CENTER SKINNER. THANK YOU
BRADFORD AFTER. MY HOPE MY
INITIAL COMMENTS ARE JUST ON A
REFLECTION OF THE WHOLE PANEL
SO FAR AND EVERYTHING THAT WE
FACED AN INTERESTINGLY EVERYONE
IS INDICATED THESE ARE ON THIS
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION AND I
REFLECTED ON DURING THE
BLACKOUTS OF ART IN OUR INCLUDE
INCLUDE ELECTRICITY CRISIS IN
THE EARLY TWO THOUSANDS TWO
THOUSAND PROBABLY MANY MANY
MORE CUSTOMERS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WERE AFFECTED BY
BLACKOUTS THAN THESE POWER
OUTAGES THE IT WAS
UNPREDICTABLE. AND MAYBE NOT AS
LONG OF DURATION FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE CASE OF HOW LONG SAY MARIN
COUNTY'S POWER CINEMA COUNTIES
POWER WAS OUT DURING THIS LAST
FIRE BUT- IT WAS CERTAINLY.
CUSTOMERS ALL ACROSS THE STATE.
AND UNPREDICTABLE AND SEMI
CONSTANT SO THIS IS NOT
UNPRECEDENTED. AND YET WHAT TO
DO ONE BIG DIFFERENCE IS. FOR
MORE DEPEND ON A LAND LINE
STAND. I AM LESS DEPENDENT ON
THE COMMUNICATION THING THAT
REQUIRED A- POWER SOURCE NOW.
IN THIS CONCEPT OF THAT. WOULD
WOULD THE DIFFICULTY IS. THE
LEGISLATURE DID NOT DIRECT. OUR
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES TO
DEVELOP ALL OF THEIR
TECHNOLOGIES. IN A POWER SOURCE.
YOU ALL DID YOU CHOSE TO. AND
SO NOW WE'RE IN A SITUATION AND
EFFECTIVE BEING TOLD LIKE WILL
DON'T REGULATE US DON'T
REGULATE VOICEOVER PROTOCOL.
BUT MAKE SURE THERE'S POWER SO
ARE. OUR SERVICE THAT WE ARE
PROVIDING TO RESIDENTS THAT
WE'VE SOLD TO CONSUMERS AS
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO BE
THERE THAT THE COMMUNICATION
THAT THEY CAN RELY ON. THE
SERVER THE EMAIL THOSE ARE
KINDA UNTENABLE. AND I THINK WE
HAVE TO PARTNER. AND WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN ACHIEVE A
COMMUNICATION SERVICE THAT IS
LESS DEPENDENT ON POWER BECAUSE
WE CANNOT ALWAYS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GUARANTEE IT WE'RE JUST
NOT. AND FOR A WHOLE. REASONS
LOOK AT AUSTRALIA. AND WE COULD
FACE THAT OR AN EARTHQUAKE OF
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE YOU KNOW
EVERY EVERY PREDICTION THE
VARIOUS FAULTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN EASILY HAVE THE
TYPE OF EARTHQUAKES THAT ARE
FAR WORSE MAGNITUDE THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SO WE NEED TO BE
PARTNERS IN THIS AND THEY'RE
PROBABLY WILL NEED TO BE
ADDITIONAL REGULATION AS MUCH
AS THE INDUSTRY DOES NOT LOVE
IT SO. PARTNER WITH US TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO DO IT RIGHT
BECAUSE ARE CONSUMERS BELIEVE
THAT THEY HAVE. A COMMUNICATION
SYSTEM THAT THEY CAN RELY ON.
AND THEN ALL OF OUR EMERGENCY
PROTOCOLS OR BASED ON IT NOW
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH. IN MY
AREA WHERE THE EARTHQUAKE
PREPAREDNESS PEOPLE COME TO YOU
AND ORIENT YOU TO WHAT YOU
SHOULD GET. THEY ADVOCATE FOR
BATTERY OPERATED OR SOLAR CRANK
OPERATED RADIOS. AND THEY TELL
EVERYONE TO MAKE SURE THAT IN
YOUR PUTTING TOGETHER YOUR
EARTHQUAKE PREPAREDNESS THAT
YOU MAY NOT RELY ON YOUR
CELLULAR PHONE NOW THE PROBLEM
IS THAT PEOPLE THAT IS NOT A
UNIVERSAL UNDERSTOOD THING AND
WE'VE NOT SET UP OUR EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATIONS TO BE THROUGH
THAT TYPE OF SYSTEM. BUT IF
THAT'S THE TYPE OF SYSTEM WE
NEED TO MOVE TOWARDS THEN AGAIN
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PARTNER
TO DO THAT. BUT TO. TO KIND OF
TURN TO US NOW AND SAY. THAT WE
HAVE TO GUARANTEE THAT POWERS
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN IN ORDER FOR
YOUR SYSTEMS TO WORK JUST IS
NOT GOING TO WORK TEN OF TEN OF.
BRADFORD THANK YOU I'M GONNA
HAVE GOAL A LOT OF WHAT CENTER
SKINNER JUST STATED BUT I'M
ALSO- EMBRACE WHAT. MS MCINTYRE
STATED I THINK IT'S TRULY
UNFAIR TO EXPECT. THESE
ENTITIES TO PROVIDE BACKUP
POWER TO ALL. THEIR RESOURCES
AND ALL THE SERVICES THAT THEY
PROVIDE- WE HEAR THE CHALLENGES
OF GENERATORS AND THINGS OF
THAT NATURE BUT MY QUESTION
STILL SPEAKS TO I THINK WHAT
THE REPRESENTED FROM THAT FOR A
BLACK. BOOK RICK BUT QUENEAU ON
WHY CONSIDER THAT FOR STATED AS
IT RELATES TO THE DEPENDENCY
ON. THE COPPER WIRE. AND THAT'S
CRITICAL AND I WE HEAR EIGHTEEN
TO USE IN THEIR SPENDING
MILLIONS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF- INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT
BUT WHAT PERCENTAGES THAT IT'S
BEING. GOING TORTURE MAINTAIN
THE COPPER WIRE BECAUSE
REGARDLESS AGAIN WHETHER IT'S
ON THE CELL PHONE WITH THERE'S
A VOICE. INTERNET PROTOCOL YOU
STEAL DEPEND ON THAT COPPER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AGAIN. EIGHT
YEARS AGO NINE YEARS AGO YOUR
OWN EMPLOYEES SAID YOU WERE NOT
MAINTAINING THAT SO I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW FROM RISE IN AND
EIGHTEEN T. WHAT COMMITMENT ARE
YOU REALLY MAKING TO THE COUPLE.
THANK YOU CENTER. THIS A COUPLE
POINTS HERE OF FOR SOFT
ADDRESSING CENTER SCANNERS-
COMMENT ABOUT THE UNPRECEDENTED
NATURE OF THIS- THESE EVENTS
pOCCURRED IN OCTOBER AND ALSO
PREVIOUS COMMENTS ABOUT HOW-
HOW WHETHER OR NOT THE IN THE
SHE WAS PREPARE FOR THE WORST.
IN TERMS OF THE PS PS EVENTS
ALITALIA FROM FROM MY
EXPERIENCE- COUPLE ITEMS ARE IN
THE INTERVENING IT'S OF THE
ENERGY ISSUES IN THE PAST I'VE
LIVED IN CALIFORNIA FROM WAS MY
LIFE. I WAS HERE MANAGING SOME
OF THOSE POWER OUTAGES ACKER
ROLLING BLACKOUTS BROWNOUTS HAD
OCCURS. DURING THE ENERGY
CRISIS THE DIFFERENCE THERE WAS
THAT THE RULING BROWN EYES WERE
POWER IF YOU SHUT OFF FOR A FEW
HOURS. THIS IS THE BALLOT BOB
BARR. YEAH YEAH. PLEASE LET LET
LET LET HIM BEEN TRUCK OUT OF
SO WE IN TERMS OF THE- THE
DEPLOYMENTS- WE WERE YOU KNOW
WE HAD- GENERATOR IS DEPLOYED
THAT WAS FIVE TO TEN TIMES MORE
THAN WHAT OTHER P. S. P. S.
EVENTS THAT HAS OCCURRED- AND
WE ARE INVESTING IN TERMS OF
GROWING THAT- GENERATING
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THAT RIGHT
BUT THAT TO ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION SENATE REFEREE ABOUT-
INVESTMENT IN TERMS OF- COPPER
WIRES- WE ARE INVESTING IN FROM
A COPPER WIRE PERFECT-
PERSPECTIVE IN PROPORTION IT
TOO WHAT OUR CUSTOMERS ARE
REQUIRED RIGHT WOULD YOU SEE OF
ABOUT TWELVE MILLION. CUSTOMERS
ON THE COPPER WIRE WITH MILLION
ON THE RIGHT NOW- I HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE OVERALL
NETWORK WE DON'T LOOK AT
INVESTMENT IN TERMS OF A SINGLE
TECHNOLOGY. WE LOOK AT-
INVESTMENT FROM A NETWORK
PERSPECTIVE IN TERMS OF THE
OVERARCHING NETWORK TO ENSURE
THAT WE GET THAT TYPE. GETS TO
ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF INVESTMENT
TO SHIP SUPPORT THAT AND GROW
THAT CAPABILITY SO THAT THEY
HAVE THESE ADDITIONAL-
CAPABILITIES THAT WE WILL ALL
TALK ABOUT IN TERMS OF HOUSE IS
CENTRAL TO OUR AT THE
ACTIVITIES. ARE YOU I TOTALLY
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
BUT I TOTALLY DISAGREE I SOLD.
TELECOMMUNICATIONS FOR IBM I.
SO THE SYSTEM THAT INSIDE THIS
BUILDING RIGHT HERE YOU STEAL
DEPEND WHETHER USING A WIRELESS
SYSTEM YOU STILL DEPEND ON THAT
IT FOR STRUCTURE. THOSE
INDEPENDENT PHONE COMPANIES DO
SPEND ON THOSE AND DEPENDED-
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT COPPER WIRE
TO MEETING CUSTOMER RELIABILITY
TO THEIR CUSTOMER.THAT DOES
NEED TO BE MAINTAINED WITH YOUR
CUSTOMER MIGRATES AWAY FROM ALL
OUR LINE GOES TO WIRELESS
THAT'S DEAL VITAL TO THE
COMMUNICATION IN OVERALL
SERVERS LIABILITY. EVEN. FOR
YOUR CABLE NETWORK AT SOME
POINT YOU'RE ON THAT BACK BALL.
TACKLE IN TERMS OF FIBER OPTIC
CABLE AND CALDWELL YOUR YOUR-
YOUR COPPER CONNECTS DOES SOME
YOUR FIBER- SOME OF IT YEAH I
BUT I'M BE SANDWICH BECAUSE
YOU'RE MY GREEN AWAY FROM BUT
IT'S STILL A NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR SERVICE
RELIABILITY. THANK YOU CENTER
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR THEM. DC HAVE SOME
QUICK COMMENTS ARE DISABLED FOR
SOME RESPONSES AND ADD THEIR IS
AT A COMMENT THAT WE NEED TO
HOLD LIKE I'M PARAPHRASING
ELECTRIC UTILITIES RESPONSIBLE
AND ACCOUNTABLE. ABSOLUTELY I
THINK THAT YOU'RE SEEN ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT IN THE
STATE- TAKE ACTION TO BE ABLE
TO HOLD IN PARTICULAR- UNBIASED
HERE PACIFIC GAS ELECTRIC
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
IN THESE MASSIVE POWER OUTAGES
AND I THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE
PREPARED FOR THE WORST A MATTER
IF YOU ARE- SL PROVIDER. PER
CABLE PROVIDER WHETHER IT IS A
POWER SHUT OFF. AN EARTHQUAKE A
CYBER ATTACK- WE HAVE TO BE
PREPARED WITH RESILIENT AND WE
DONE SYSTEMS. SO FIRST OF ALL
LET MEANS WE START TALKING
ABOUT REAL NUMBERS I APPRECIATE
ABOUT THE 7% OF RISING DISCUSS
I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
REAL NUMBERS. ABOUT
CALIFORNIANS. IN THE STAFF
REPORT IS ONE POINT ONE
APPROXIMATE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WE HEARD TODAY.
FROM REPRESENTATIVES TWO
MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT WERE
IMPACTED. FROM THEIR CELL CABLE
OUR LAND LINES BEING DOWN. FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR THOUSAND ON
CABLE LAND LINE ALONE AND
THAT'S A MULTIPLYING FACTOR BY
THREE. SO I THINK THAT'S THE
REAL NUMBER WE NEED TO FOCUS IN
ON IN HOW WE'RE GOING TO
IMPROVE THAT. BACKUP POWER IS
ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY NOW. AND
JUST BEING CANDID MANY OF YOU
WERE IN THE ROOM. I REPRESENT
IS TOLD US. THAT YOU ALL WERE
PREPARED FOR THE WORST. AND WE
FAST FORWARD TO LATE SUMMER AND
INTO THE FALL. AND THE WORST
HAPPENED. AND WE SHOULD HAVE
BEEN PREPARED FOR THAT. SO NOW
WE'RE HERE. THREE THAT WE'RE
NOT GONNA HIT A HUNDRED
PERCENT. AGREE WITH THAT. BUT
YOU NEED TO START WITH THE PLAN.
SO WHAT I WOULD HOPE IS GOING
TO COME FROM THIS HEARING VIEW
FULL NUMBER ONE A PLANE'S GONNA
BE PROVIDED BY BOTH
TELECOMMUNICATION CABLE TO THE
OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES ABOUT
HOW YOU CAN MAKE A MORE
RESILIENT SYSTEM. NUMBER TWO IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
COLLABORATION. IT'S A TWO WAY
STREET. WE CAN'T HIDE BEHIND
WERE FEDERALLY REGULATED
UTILITY WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD AND SAY WE'RE
GONNA BE COLLABORATIVE. WE'RE
GONNA PROVIDE INFORMATION. AND
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT NOT JUST
LARGE NUMBERS ABOUT HOW MUCH
WE'RE INVESTING BUT
SPECIFICALLY HOW WE'RE
INVESTING IN. AND WHAT THE
OUTCOME OF THAT INVESTMENTS CAN
BE FOR RESILIENCY WITHIN THE
SYSTEM. BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE
WILL NOT HAVE THE METRICS TO BE
ABLE TO DEFINE SUCCESS. THE
LAST PIECES STREAMLINING ALL
FOR STREAMLINING BUT HAS BEEN
THE NAME OF PUBLIC SAFETY. IT
CAN'T BE SMS SAID A NEW
BUSINESS MODEL IN THE STATE. SO
WHAT I WOULD HOPE IS THAT THERE
ARE GONNA BE COMPROMISES WE
MOVE FOR THIS YEAR OBVIOUSLY I
HAVE A BIAS AS THE AREA THAT I
PROBABLY REPRESENT WITH SENATOR
DODD WAS IMPACTED DRAMATICALLY
BY THE LOSS OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS CABLE
LANDLINE CELL. CABLE MAINLINE.
AND WHAT I WOULD HOPE. IS THAT
THIS COLLABORATION WILL BE A
TWO WAY STREET. WE WILL BE ABLE
TO BE CONFIDENTIAL MOVING
FORWARD ON CONCERNS. AS WE SIT
AROUND THAT TABLE- AND THEN
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO MOVE
FORWARD TOGETHER NINETEEN SURE
THE CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE
SYSTEM THAT THEY HAVE COME TO
RELY ON. I AND THAT WOULD BE MY
OWN COMES THINK THANK YOU SIR
MCGUIRE A CENTER DOLLY. THE US
CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY SO. I'M MORE
I'M MORE CONCERNED ABOUT. AND
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ITSELF THAT
AS YOU KNOW I STATED EARLIER
WHEN THE PC WAS UP HERE ABOUT.
WE HAVE A LOT OF I HAVE A LAND
LINE IN MY HOME BECAUSE MY CELL
SERVICE. THE SOCKS HOUSE OUT
FOR NEW POLITICAL STATEMENT. IN
A LOT OF MY CONSTITUENTS DO IN
THE IN THE ROLE AREAS BUT WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE LIKE EIGHT
MILLION PEOPLE THAT HAVE LAND
LINES AND FORTY FOUR MILLION
PEOPLE THAT USE. NEWS IS THIS
FOR THEIR MAIN HOME USE AND
IT'S ABOUT MAKING MONEY IN
PROFITS AND THAT'S WHERE THE
THAT'S WORSE DRIVING THE MOVE
TO. YOU KNOW SELL SERVICES AND
MOBILE DEVICES. IT IS ALSO WHAT
THE PUBLIC WANTS. BUT THE SAME
TIME WE STILL NEED TO HAVE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE SO YOU CENTER
FOR CENTER BRADFORD PRODUCTS OF
WHAT I'M I'M NOT EXPERT IN.
WHAT THE INFRASTRUCTURE REALLY
NEEDS BUT I KNOW ONE THING THAT
IT DOESN'T WORK FOR. THE
CONSTITUENTS I REPRESENT IS
THAT. WHEN WE HAD A CAMPFIRE WE
COULDN'T COMMUNICATE WITH
PEOPLE TO GET THEM GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BECAUSE THEY
WERE GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION. TWICE VOTED FOR THE
FEE ON THE NINE ONE ONE IS TO
GET THAT IN PLACE. SO IS IT THE
LAN IS IT THE COPPER LINES OR
THE FIBER OPTIC LINES THAT THAT
REALLY CARRY THE LOAD THEY DO.
SOME POINT THIS HAS TO GO TO
SOMETHING THAT TRANSMITS IT
SOMEWHERE I'M ASSUMING. SO I
WANT TO KNOW WHO'S RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT BACKBONE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IS IT EIGHTEEN
T. IS IT COMCAST WHO WHO
ACTUALLY. IS RESPONSIBLE TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN IS IT YES.
KITTERY ANSWER THAT QUESTION
FOR ME. OR DO WE JUST SELL IT
TO WHOEVER I WANNA BREAKS IT'S
BROKEN AND NOBODY MAINTAINS IT
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
I CAN'T GET. PROVIDERS TO COME
TO MY COMMUNITIES. WHERE THEY
CAN'T MAKE A PROFIT EVEN THOUGH
WE ARE SUBSIDIZING THEM TO DO
IT. IT IS ALL ABOUT PROFITS AT
THE END OF THE DAY I NEED TO BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE WITH MY
CONSTITUENTS WHEN THERE'S A
FIRE. OR THERE'S AN EARTHQUAKE
OR THERE'S A MUD SLIDE OR
WHATEVER IT IS. AND WE AND I AS
I STATED EARLIER WE STEPPED UP
TO THE PLATE WE PUT THE MONEY
IN PLACE. FOUR EIGHT AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY TWO I BELIEVE WAS THE
NUMBER. I WORKED WITH THAT I
WAS A CO AUTHOR JOINT AUTHORED
WITH- MY FRIENDS FROM- THE-
IMPERIAL THAT HAVE THE SAME
ISSUES I HOP IN LASSEN. AND YOU
KNOW WHAT THE MONEY IS THERE
AND NOBODY'S ACCESS AND THAT
MONEY BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
THERE'S OUR PROFIT IN EVEN
THOUGH WE'RE SUBSIDIZING. SO I
WANT SOMEBODY ANSWER WHO WHO'S
MAINTAIN THAT BACKBONE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO THAT WHEN
THERE'S A FIRE I CAN ACTUALLY
GET A LAND LINE OR WHATEVER IT
IS OR GETS SELL SERVICES OUT
THERE. SO WE CAN COMMUNICATE
WHO DO WHO DOES THAT. UP TO
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION SO- IN
TERMS OF WHAT TYPE OF
FACILITIES FEED- CELL SITES- I
COULD SPEAK SPECIFICALLY FROM
EIGHTEEN T. PERSPECTIVE. I AM
NOT AWARE OF A SINGLE CELL
SITES BEING FED BY COPPER-
ANYMORE ADDED TO MAYBE ONE DAY
MAYBE TWO BUT- FROM MY
KNOWLEDGE I'M NOT AWARE OF A
SINGLE ONE. THAT STEP BY COOPER
ALMOST THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR
CELL SIZE ARE FED BY FIBER
OPTIC CABLES- BECAUSE OF THE
HIGH CAPACITY DEMANDS THAT ARE
CELL SITES NEED ANY
CAPABILITIES. THAT'S REQUIRED
TO SUPPORT THE SERVICES THAT WE
ALL VALUE AS CONSUMERS- AND THE
VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE FIBER
OPTIC CABLES. A HEARING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RELATIVE TO
EIGHTEEN T. IS MAINTAINED AND
MANAGED BY OUR WATER LINE
EIGHTEEN T. TEAM WHICH IS ALSO
AND MY RESPONSIBILITY. CENTER
HIS HIS FROM MINE FROM VERIZON
AGAIN. FROM VERIZON PERSPECTIVE
WHEN WE ARE DEPLOYING A
WIRELESS FACILITY ANYWHERE- WE
HAVE TO GET AT LEAST TWO OTHER
THINGS OTHER THAN OUR WIRELESS
FACILITY ITSELF WE NEED TO GET
THE BACK HALL OR SOMETIMES
CALLED FROM HALL WHICH WE DO
WITH FIBER. WE DON'T DEPLOY
THAT OURSELVES WE LEASED OUT
FROM OTHER CARRIERS LIKE AT AND
T. THE CABLE COMPANIES AND OR
SOME OTHER CARRIERS OUT THERE
THAT SPECIFICALLY PROVIDE FIBRE
MICRON CASTLE- WE ALSO NEED TO
GET POWER TO OUR FACILITIES SO
WE HAVE TO GET THAT FROM A
THIRD PARTY TO WE DON'T DO
POWER. JUST AS WE DON'T DO
POWER WE'RE NOT DOING THE
FIBERS- WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
WHOSE RESPONSIBILITY IS IT- I
THINK THE QUESTION SHOULD BE
TALKED ABOUT MORE AS- AS HOW OR
WIRELESS. NETWORKS BUILT. AND
WHO HAS THE RESPONSIBILITIES OF
THE DIFFERENT PIECE PARTS OF
IT. ON AND HOW MUCH OF THAT DO
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE BECAUSE WE
ACTUALLY WANT TO GET CELLULAR
SERVICES TO SOME OF THE PLACES
WHERE THERE IS NO CELL SERVICE
RIGHT- SO I THINK THAT- I AGREE
WITH EIGHTEEN TEASE COMMENT
THAT. COPPER REALLY IS NOT PART
OF THIS EQUATION ITS FIBER- AND
YOU GET FIBER YOU PUT IT IN THE
GROUND AND YOU PUT IT ON- UP
ON. HOLES BUT- IT'S CRITICAL
POWER AND FIBER TO GET CELL
SERVICE. OKAY SO I'M GONNA
CLOSE MY COMMENT WITH THIS
STATEMENT. SO I UNDERSTAND
COMPETITION I UNDERSTAND FREE
MARKETS AND I THINK IT'S UPON
THE LEGISLATURE AND- YES TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WITH ALL THE
COPPER- ALL THE FIBER TO SAY
FOR AND THE AND THE POWER IN
THE STRUCTURE IS BUT AS UPON US
IN THE P. YOU SEE TO FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO MANAGE. OUR
PUBLIC SAFETY PROBLEMS THAT
WE'RE HAVING SO WHEN WE TRY TO
TACKLE THAT WHAT WE HEARD FROM
THE P. YOU SEE AS WELL THEY
WON'T SHARE THEIR INFORMATION
US BECAUSE IS PROPRIETARY FOR
TO THEIR BUSINESS MODEL. WHAT I
HEAR FROM YOU SAYING IS P.
GENIES THE PROBLEM BECAUSE THEY
SHUT THE POWER OFF. SO
SOMEWHERE THERE HAS TO BE. A
CENTRAL COMMAND SAYS OKAY WE'RE
GOING TO FIX THE PROBLEM HERE
BECAUSE WITH THIS IS NOT GONNA
GO WE'RE GONNA HAVE FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE PLEDGE ARE
GO. IF FOR THE SHORT
TERM HOPEFULLY. THE MORE BUT
POWER SAFETY SHUT OFF SITUATION
SO WHO IS THAT- THAT'S ONE TO
IS IT YEAH WE NEED ARE WE AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY GONNA SUPPORT
TO ONE PERSON THIS IS A- YOU'RE
GOING TO PUT THIS GREAT INTO
PLACE AND YOU'RE GONNA MAKE ALL
THESE PEOPLE PLAY THAT'S WHAT
I'M HEARING THE LEGISLATORS SAY
IS LEGISLATORS ASKED TODAY IS
WHAT PIECE OF LEGISLATION DO WE
NEED TO RUN. THIS THAT MAKES
THAT COORDINATION HAPPEN
BECAUSE WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
WE'RE RUNNING A LITTLE PIECES
ME CENTER REQUIRE MY SEAT MATE
HAS BEEN FRUSTRATED BY THE FACT
AND HE'S TRYING TO K<c.cyan> ÁI.</c>
AND I AM HERE. SENATOR JACKSON
I HEAR. BERKELEY FOLKS I HERE.
YEAH I HOLDEN SAY SO. AND WHAT
IT USUALLY HAPPENS IS WE DON'T
GET IT RIGHT. BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE ALL THE INFORMATION WE
DON'T GIVE THE POWER TO THE
RIGHT PERSON IS GOING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO IT SO I'M I'M
HERE TO. SHARE WITH YOU. YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO GET. WHAT YOU WANT
AND NEITHER IS- YES AND NEITHER
IS. THE P. YOU SEE INTEL WE
FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION SAYS AND GIVE SOME
OF THE POWER TO SAY WE'RE GOING
TO FIX THIS PROBLEM ONCE AND
FOR ALL. THAT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
A SYSTEM SET UP WE HAVE THE
BACK CALL ON THE FRONT HOLE. IN
THE SIDE HOLE AND THE GENERATOR
WERE SUPPOSED TO BE. SO THAT
WHEN WE HAVE AN OUTAGE THAT
WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THE- AND
CENTER DOLLY. I'M I'M JUST
GONNA. WHAT I HEARD TODAY. AND
WHEN WHAT WE WENT THROUGH TODAY
IS THAT- YOU SEE. IS ASKING US
ABOUT THAT THE INDUSTRY'S
ASKING A SIT DOWN. WITH THE P.
YOU SEE THROUGH AN INFORMAL
PROCESS P. YOU SEE IS SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO TRY TO EXPEDITE.
OUR PROCESS WE'RE GOING TO.
CREATE A SYSTEM IN WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO. ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
AND I FROM IF I CAN ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION I THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE THE LEGISLATURE AND THE P.
YOU SEE AND IN THE- INDUSTRY.
WORKING AT TEN OO YES WORK IN
IT TOGETHER TO IDENTIFY. THE
MOST PRESSING CONCERNS AND COME
UP WITH SOLUTIONS TO A MAN AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE- THAT'S WHAT
THIS PROCESS IS ABOUT. AGAIN
FIND THAT GOING DOWN THE STEPS
IF WE NEED LEGISLATION. WORK ON
IT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO SELL
LEGISLATION WERE CARD PASS AT.
TEN IF WE NEED THE P. YOU SEE
TO ACT WE'RE GONNA COURAGE THEM
TO ACT QUICKLY AND OF COURSE
THE INDUSTRY IS MAKING PROMISES
THAT THERE MEGA MAKE
INVESTMENTS. INTO THEIR INTO
UPGRADES. ARE WE'RE GONNA MOVE
ON UNFORTUNATELY WE WILL START
THIS CENTER STERN IF YOU CAN
HAVE A- OF VERY BRIEF BECAUSE
WE HAD WE STILL HAVE. WITH
THEY'RE ASKING US TO LEAVE THE
ROOM- BY ONE O'CLOCK SO WE'RE
GONNA TRY TO- GET TO OUR NEXT
PANEL WHICH IS. THIRTY MINUTES
AND WE STILL. HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENT WHICH WOULD BE LONG AS
WELL SO. UNDERSTOOD AS CHAIRMAN
I'LL TRY TO PUT IT PUT A FINE
POINT ON- MY COLLEAGUES TO THE
NORTH A CENTER DOLLY MCGUIRE-
JUST TO GET A SENSE FOR THE
PANEL HERE DO YOU ALL OF YOU
THINK IT'S FEASIBLE TO PUT
FORTH YOUR FIRST DRAFT OF A
PLAN TO MAKE THESE AREAS
RESILIENT LAYING OUT YOUR
INVESTMENT TIMELINE YOUR
PRIORITIZATION PLANS AND CAN
YOU BRING SOMETHING LIKE THAT
AFTER THIS HEARING PLEASED TO
GET THE PROCESS STARTED
LEGISLATURE. AND PUT THAT FORD
AT JUST AT LEAST GET THE
CONVERSATION ROLLING IS THAT
SOUND LIKE SOMETHING IS
FEASIBLE- AT LEAST THROUGH US
WE KNOW THIS CAN BE PARALLEL
PROCESSES BUT I JUST WANT TO
GET A SENSE I KNOW THEY BOTH
BROUGHT THAT UP BUT WHEN YOU
GET SOME FEEDBACK FROM YOU ALL
AND THAT'S ALL I HAVE MISTER
CHAIR. I THINK IT'S FEASIBLE
BUT I'D I'D LIKE IT TO BE NOT
JUST OUR IDEA BUT OUR IDEA IN
CONCERT WITH TALK AND- YES AND
TALK INTO BECAUSE WE ALL KNEW
EACH OTHER AND LET ME MAY THINK
MAINTAIN MISS SOMETHING THAT-
YES NEEDS AND SO I MEAN I
REALLY THINK IT'S GOT TO BE A-
YOU KNOW IT AND IT SOUNDS LIKE
POLYANDROUS BUT IT HAS TO BE A
COLLABORATION AND I WILL SAY.
THIS IS NOT TO. BE CRITICAL.
THIS EVENT AS AS- DIFFICULT AS
IT HAS BEEN I THINK HAS PUSHED.
ALL OF US. INTO A DIFFERENT
PLACE I MEAN I'M HEARING OUT
REACH FROM. FOLKS THAT I HADN'T
HEARD OUT REACH BEFORE IN TERMS
OF SITTING DOWN AND TALKING TO
EACH OTHER SO WE'RE PREPARED TO
CERTAINLY THE WIRELESS IS.
PREPARED I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT PANEL ANSWER FROM THE
OTHER. ANOTHER ONE BUT WILL ASK
MR AMANDA. THE ANSWER'S YES YES.
ABSOLUTELY WORKING THROUGH YES
YES THINKING OF PERFECT OKAY-
WE'RE GONNA NOW HERE FROM THE
IMPACTS TO THE CONSUMERS FROM
VARIOUS OF REPRESENTATIVES FROM
OUT OF THE CONSUMERS IN OUR
STATE BEGINNING WITH ANNA MARIA
JOHNSON SHE IS THE- WITH THE
PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S OFFICE.
REPRESENTING A COMMUNICATIONS
WATER. I'M SORRY SHE'S A BRENT
THE BRANCH PROGRAM MANAGER OF
COMMUNICATIONS AND WATER POLICY
THAN WE HAVE REGION ACOSTA THE
TO THE DIRECTOR OF TELECOM PAUL
POLICY WITH THE UTILITY REFORM
NETWORK. AND WE SET HAVE STEVE
MOVE. MY CAR GAR THE OWNER OF
THE FARM TABLE IN PLACERVILLE.
WELCOME AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE. BEGIN WITH A
MESS SANTA MARIA JOHNSON. PRESS
BUTTON THERE THERE YOU GO.
CHAIRMAN WESSEL AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME HERE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING. MY NAME IS ANNA MARIA
JOHNSON PROGRAM MANION PROGRAM
MANAGER AT THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE IS AN
INDEPENDENT ORGANIZATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITY
COMMISSION THAT ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS.
FOR SAFE AND RELIABLE SERVICE
OF ENERGY WATER AND
COMMUNICATION I'M HERE TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT COMMUNICATION. AS
YOU HAVE HEARD THROUGHOUT THIS
MORNING THE OCTOBER PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF.
HIGHLIGHTED THE VULNERABILITY
AND FAILURES OF THE
COMMUNICATION NETWORK FOR BOTH
WIRELESS AND WIRELINE SERVICE.
IT'S SIMPLY A FACT WHEN POWER
WENT DOWN A NUMBER OF CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS CELL
SITES THAT TRANSMIT WIRELESS
PHONE AND DATA SIGNALS WENT
DOWN. WIRELINE NETWORKS WENT
DOWN THE ROUTE TRAFFIC TO AND
FROM CELL SITES. AND AS MORE
COMMUNICATION COMPANIES ARE ARE
MOVING TO VOICE OVER INTERNET
PROTOCOL WHICH IS VOIGTS. DOES
SERVICES ALSO WENT DOWN
CUSTOMERS WERE OUT OF TOUCH
BUSINESSES WERE OUT OF TOUCH
FIRST RESPONDERS RUN OUT OF
TOUCH WHEN THE SERVICES DIDN'T
WORK THIS IS A MATTER OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY. AND IT'S
SOME IT'S CRITICAL THAT THESE
SERVICES ARE WORKING SO THAT
CONSUMERS CAN GET EMERGENCY
EVACUATION ALERT. DIAL NINE ONE
ONE. OBTAIN INFORMATION ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE
COMMUNITY AND COMMUNICATE WITH
THE LOVE ONCE. WE MUST BE CLEAR
HERE. CONSUMERS ARE DOING THEIR
DUE DILIGENCE THEY ARE CHARGING
THEIR PHONES SOME HAVE ALREADY
BACKUP POWER AT THEIR HOMES FOR
MODEMS FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
VOICE OVER INTERNET PROTOCOL.
CONSUMERS ARE PAYING THEIR
BILLS. CONSUMERS PAY SURCHARGES
ON THOSE BILLS. THE BURDEN IS
ON THE COMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
AND THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY IS ON THEM TO
ENSURE THAT THE NETWORK IS
WORKING WE CAN NO LONGER PUT
CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS TO BIRD
AND TO DO THINGS THAT IT'S THE
COMMUNICATIONS JOB AND
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO WHICH IS
TO MAINTAIN THE COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORK. AS SUCH WIRELESS
WIRELINE CABLE COMPANIES MUST
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO ENSURES
CUSTOMERS CAN USE THEIR
WIRELESS AND WIRELINE SERVICE
DURING EMERGENCY AND POWER
OUTAGES. AND THEY MUST SHARE
DETAIL ADDED INFORMATION WITH
FIRST RESPONDERS SUCH AS CAL
FIRE AND CALLOW YES BECAUSE
THIS IS CRITICAL INFORMATION
FOR FIRST RESPONDERS TO LOCATE
AND CONTACT WILL THE BOOKS
CUSTOMERS. NOW I'VE BEEN
SITTING HERE HEARING THE PANEL
COMMUNICATIONS ARE COMPANIES
AND I CANNOT HELP BUT HIGHLIGHT
TO YOU THAT THIS IS NOT
UNPRECEDENTED AND THIS IS NOT
NEW. POWER OUTAGES HAVE
OCCURRED. DECADES AGO. JUST
RECENTLY IN THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN STORMS IN JANUARY AND
FEBRUARY THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
REPORT I WILL RE FROM THE
REPORT FROM THE COMMUNICATIONS
SAYING THAT MANY OF THOSE
OUTAGES FROM THE STORMS COULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED WITH BETTER
AVAILABILITY OF BACKUP POWER
FOR WIRELESS PROVIDERS AND
IMPROVE RELIABILITY OF CABLE
FACILITIES FOR WIRELINE
PROVIDERS. THE PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHOT US CANNOT BE USED AS
AN EXCUSE TO HOLD
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR MAINTAINING
THEIR COMMUNICATIONS NETWORKS
WORKING DURING A POWER OUTAGE.
IT IS A MATTER OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
YOU HAVE HAD OR HEARD YOU KNOW
THAT MANY HEARINGS HAVE BEEN
HELD FOR FIRST RESPONDERS CAL
FIRE CALLOW YES HAVE STATED I
EVEN AS EARLY AS- MAY OF LAST
YEAR. THAT LACK OF BACKUP POWER
IS ESSENTIAL FOR COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORK IT WAS ALSO MENTIONED
THAT THE PUBLIC ADVOCATE'S
OFFICE FILE A MOTION FOR THE
COMMISSION TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION IN MAY TWENTY ONE OF
TWENTY NINETEEN. AND ONE OF
THOSE ITEMS WE ASK FOR
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO REQUIRE
BACKUP POWER A WIRELESS
FACILITIES IN HIGH FIRE THREAT
AREAS AND FLOODPLAINS. ACTION
IS THE MEDIA N. AS DIRECTOR
JOEL DO SHE- OF THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICE STATED TO YOU
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE THIS IS
A DIRE SITUATIONS WE ARE WE ARE
IN. AND CONSUMERS CANNOT BE
CONTINUE TO BE PUT IN PUBLIC
HARM. THEY ARE IN HARM RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE THIS COMMUNICATIONS
NETWORKS ARE NOT RELIABLE. AS
SUCH ARE ASKED IT'S CLEAR.
THERE ARE PROCEDURAL VEHICLES
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW IN THE
COMMISSION TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO REQUIRE WIRELESS
CARRIERS TO TAKE ALL MEANS
NECESSARY TO KEEP WIRELESS
SERVICE WORKING DURING A POWER
OUTAGE. INCLUDING HAVING BACKUP
POWER. DOES BACK UP POWER
REQUIREMENTS CAN USE EXISTING
WIRELINE REQUIREMENTS WHICH
REQUIRE SEVENTY TWO HOURS IN
CENTRAL OFFICES THE ROUTE NINE
ONE ONE CALLS TO NINE ONE ONE
CENTERS. SECOND COMMUNICATIONS
PROVIDER MUST IMMEDIATELY
PROVIDE REAL TIME DETAIL
ADDRESS INFORMATION TO FIRST
RESPONDERS SUCH AS CAL FIRE AND
CALORIE AS- AND LASTLY. THE
COMMISSION WAS ACTIVELY MONITOR
AND IN FOR COMPLIANCE WITH ANY
ORDER LEGISLATIVE ORDER
COMMISSION ORDER ANY ORDER MUST
BE MONITOR AND ENFORCE TO
ENSURE COMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
ARE MEETING THOSE REQUIREMENTS.
AS I STATED WE CAN NO LONGER
SHIFT THE BURDEN TO CONSUMERS
CONSUMERS PAY THEIR BILL AND
THOSE BILLS ARE NOT CHEAP. THEY
EXPECT SERVICE TO WORK AND
SERVICE MUST WORK ESPECIALLY
DOING EMERGENCY SITUATION.
PUBLIC SAFETY POWERSHOT UPS
PROVIDE A NOTICE TO
COMMUNICATION PROVIDERS. BUT
THE ISSUE IS POWER OUTAGES HAVE
BEEN KNOWN TO BE THE ROOT CAUSE
OF MANY OUTAGES IN ACTION MUST
BE TAKEN NOW TO RESOLVE THE
IMMEDIATE PROBLEM. THE PUBLIC
ADVOCATE'S OFFICE AND MYSELF
WILL CONTINUE TO PARTNER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND THE
COMMUNICATIONS PROVIDER TO FIND
SOLUTIONS BUT WE ARE VERY CLEAR
THAT THOSE SOLUTIONS MUST BE
IMMEDIATE. AS ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING ON
WHAT ELSE NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE
HAVING REQUIREMENTS OF BACKUP
POWER WILL GO A LONG WAY OF
ENSURING THAT COMMUNICATION
SERVICE WORKS. AND WE CAN NO
LONGER RELY ON VOLUNTARY PLANS
OR JUST PLANTING GENERAL'S THAT
THE COMPANIES ARE SAYING WILL
CARRY OUT. ANYMORE SOME ALSO
NOTE THAT IT'S VERY UNFORTUNATE
THAT CONSUMERS WERE PUT AT RISK
FOR COMPANIES SUCH AS EIGHTEEN
T. TO TAKE ACTION TO INVEST
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND NOW SAY
THEY WILL HAVE FIX. OUR BACKUP
POWER IN HUNDREDS OF CELL SITES.
THEY HAVE KNOWN THIS ISSUE FOR
A VERY LONG TIME. AND THE FOCUS
HERE IS IMMEDIATE ACTION AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE COMPANIES.
THANK YOU AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR QUESTIONS THANK YOU MS
JOHNSON. MISS COSTA. THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR TODAY ON
VIRGIN ACOSTA AND THE TELECOM
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR TURN THE
UTILITY REFORM NETWORK I WANT
TO ADDRESS THREE GENERAL POINTS.
INFORMATION FROM CUSTOMERS
ABOUT TYPES OF OUTAGES. THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE DO NOT FLY
UNDER THE RADAR SOME OF THESE
RELATE TO POINTS THAT WERE.
REST BY EARLIER SPEAKERS IN BY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE POSED
SECOND IS CONFIDENTIALITY OF
INFORMATION REGARDING THESE
OUTAGES AND THE THIRD AREA IS
WHAT CAN STATE OFFICIALS DO. TO
BEGIN. THERE ARE WIDESPREAD
REPORTS OF WIRELESS AND VOIP
OUTAGES BUT WHAT ELSE WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER THERE WERE
ALSO LANDLINE OUTAGES WE
RECEIVED INFORMATION FROM
CUSTOMERS INDICATING THAT
SERVICE WAS LOST IN THE SANTA
CRUZ MOUNTAINS DUE TO
INADEQUATE BACKUP POWER FOR
REMOTE TERMINALS REMOTE
TERMINALS ARE BOXES THAT YOU
WILL SEE THAT TAKE LONG
TELECOMMUNICATIONS LINES ARE
TYPICALLY LOCATED IN RURAL
AREAS THEY COMBINE THAT TRAFFIC
AND THEY SEND IT OFF TO THE
TELEPHONE COMPANY SWITCH THEY
RELY ON COMMERCIAL POWER IF THE
POWER GOES OUT THERE NEEDS TO
BE BACK UP. WE HAVE INFORMATION
FROM A CUSTOMER THAT EIGHTEEN
T. TERMINALS FILED. BASED ON
PRESS REPORTS WE BELIEVE THE
SAME THING OCCURRED IN
MENDOCINO COUNTY AND FROM THE
STATEMENT OF THE REPRESENTATIVE
FROM MORAN EARLIER THIS MORNING
IT IS A DISTINCT POSSIBILITY
THAT SOME OF THESE LINES WERE
SERVED BY A REMOTE TERMINALS-
THE COMMISSION HAS THE
AUTHORITY. TO REQUIRE THESE
CARRIERS TO MAINTAIN THIS
EQUIPMENT AND TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS ADEQUATE BACKUP POWER
THIS IS PART AND PARCEL OF THE
REGULATED COPPER NETWORK. AND
WE BELIEVE THE COMMISSION
SHOULD ACT PROMPTLY TO INST TO
DO THIS TO ENFORCE IT TO MAKE
SURE THAT. THERE IS AN HOUR AND
WE ANTICIPATE THE NETWORK
EXAMINATION TO SEE WHAT THEY
HAVE TO SAY- THE SECOND THING
IS THAT. WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA
YOU DO. SO OUR QUESTION IS IF
YOU IF YOU LOOK AT THE FCC
REPORT IT'S JUST A GENERAL
SUMMARY OF OKAY A HANDFUL LEASE
LAND LINES ONE OUT HERE IN THE
COMBINED EVERYTHING TOGETHER.
WHAT WE'RE CURIOUS ABOUT IS WAS
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO HELLO
YES TO THE CPUC POSSIBLY TO YOU
SAYING HERE'S WHAT ONE OUT IT
WAS CAUSED BY THIS- THAT
INFORMATION SHOULD NOT JUST BE
SUBSUMED INTO THE GENERAL
CATEGORY OF LANDLINE OUT IT IS
IF YOU'RE GOING TO FIX
PROBLEMS. YOU NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED. SO
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
REPORTING OF THOSE ISSUES WE
HAVE A REPORT FROM LAFAYETTE.
ON ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WE DON'T
SAKE HAS GOTTEN ANY ATTENTION.
SHE IS A CUSTOMER OF A
COMPETITOR. WHO LEASES
FACILITIES FROM AT AND T. WHEN
THE POWER WAS RESTORED HER
SERVICE STILL DID NOT WORK SHE
WAS TOLD BY. THE COMPANY THAT
YOU GET SERVICE FROM WAS THAT
AND I'M QUOTING FROM HER EMAIL
TO ME- EIGHTEEN T. HAD A HUGE
OUT ITS PROBLEM FOR HOME PHONE
AND INTERNET SERVICE DUE TO
PROBLEMS WITH THEIR BATTERY
BACKUP SYSTEM. AND THEN THE
CUSTOMER PROVIDED TO TURN- A
NOTICE THAT WAS FROM THE CITY
OF LAFAYETTE REFLECTING A
CONVERSATION AT THE TT PROVIDED
ON A LOCAL COMMUNITY WEBSITE
AND HERE'S WHAT THEY SAID. IN
CHECKING WITH MY NETWORK TEAM
THEY INDICATED THAT ONCE PGA
ANY POWER WAS RESTORED A PIECE
OF EQUIPMENT IN A NUMBER OF OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD CABINETS THAT
PROVIDE INTERNET AND PHONE
SERVICE WAS AFFECTED AND NEEDS
TO BE REPLACED. THEY'RE HAVING
TO LOCATE THE REPLACEMENT CARDS
AND EXPECT TO HAVE SOME OF THEM
REINSTALLED LATER TODAY AND THE
SEATING. THE SHOULD BE
VERIFIED. AND WE NEED TO KNOW
IF THIS HAPPENED IN LAFAYETTE
TODAY IN ANOTHER PLACE WHY DID
IT HAPPEN- WHEN IT. WHAT THE
SERVER REPORT TO AND ONE THAT
THE SITUATION WAS. EXISTING AND
IN REPORTS WAS INFORMATION
PROVIDED ABOUT WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED SO ONCE AGAIN. YOU
THERE IT'S- YES THE CITY. YOU
CAN GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS
AND TRY TO FIX IT- SECOND THING
IS FINALLY IS BACK CALL. THAT
IS A HUGE THING AND WE'VE HEARD
ABOUT THAT EARLIER TODAY I'LL
JUST NOTE THAT DURING THE TECH
FIRE ON OCTOBER TWENTY FIFTH
DECEMBER MEDINA COUNTY
SHERIFF'S OFFICE SENT THIS
TWEET. WIRELESS CALLERS WITHIN
THE HIGH DESERT AREA MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO CONNECT ON NINE ONE ONE
LINES SO PHONE CALLERS ARE
EXPERIENCING A FAST BUSY SIGNAL
OR DEAD AIR AND THEN THE LINE
DISCONNECTS CARRIERS AFFECTED
EIGHTEEN TT. MOBILE SPRINT
METROPCS AND VERIZON NO. TO
REPAIR AT THE TIME. THAT SOUNDS
TO ME LIKE A TRANSPORT PROBLEM.
MAYBE THE TECH FLYER MAYBE A
BACKHOE WE DON'T KNOW BUT MY
QUESTION IS SOMEBODY WHO'S
FOLLOWING THIS FOR CONSUMERS.
IS WASN'T REPORTED. HASN'T BEEN
VERIFIED AND HAVE THEY GOTTEN
TO THE BOTTOM OF IT. OKAY SO
MOVING TO CONFIDENTIALITY. WE
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
THE FCC IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
HAVE CONDUCTED IN DEPTH
INVESTIGATIONS ABOUT MAJOR
TELECOM OUTAGES AND ISSUE
PUBLIC REPORTS THAT DESCRIBE IN
DETAIL THE CIRCUMSTANCES
IMPACTS AND EQUIPMENT FAILURES
INVOLVED. TWO EXAMPLES ARE THE
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE FAILURE OF
VERIZON NINE ONE ONE FACILITIES
THAT AFFECTED THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION CUSTOMERS IN ARLINGTON
VIRGINIA FOLLOWING THE
DIRECTIONS STORM THIS WAS
INVESTIGATED BOTH BY THE
VIRGINIA STATE COMMISSION AND
THE FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION. PUBLIC. THE NEXT
THING IS WHAT CAN YOU DO NUMBER
ONE DIVERSE ROUTING. THE POSTER
CHILD FOR THE NEED FOR DIVERSE
ROUTING I THINK IS MENDOCINO
COUNTY BECAUSE WHEN THE FIBER
WAS CAUGHT IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN ALL SERVICE ANY KIND OF
SERVICE WAS OUT. TO WATCH WHAT
THE COUNTY. THE REDWOOD FIRE
BURNED A FIBER OPTIC CABLE ALL
SERVICE NORTH OF THAT DAMAGED.
PART WAS OUT AT LEAST- HUMBLED
I'M NOT SURE ABOUT DEL NORD BUT
DEFINITELY HUMBOLDT. I'M. BUT
TO COMPANIES DIDN'T LOSE
SERVICE ONE OF THEM WAS
SUDDENLINK AND THE OTHER ONE
WAS ONE OH ONE THAT LINK WHICH
IS A LOCAL HUMBOLDT COUNTY
COMPANY. WHY BECAUSE THEY LEAST
CAPACITY FROM ANOTHER COMPANY.
ON THE LINE OWN BY PGD RUN BY
ANOTHER TELECOM COMPANY IT WAS
IN EAST WEST ROUTE IT WASN'T
DAMAGED SO IF YOU'RE SITTING AT
HOME ALL COUNTY YOU COULD BE
FOLLOWING WHAT WAS GOING ON
DOWN SOUTH. THE OTHER THING IS
THAT ONE OH ONE NETLINK HAD.
FIBER WRAP OR OR- MICROWAVE
ROUTE MIKE WITH CLUBS RUNNING
UP ONE ONE. THEY WILL NOT
DAMAGED IN THE FIRE BUT THEY
SAID THEY TOLD THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
THAT IF THEY HAD BEEN DAMAGE
THEY STILL WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO PROVIDE SERVICE BECAUSE THEY
HAD THAT EXTRA CAPACITY AT
LEAST ON A SEPARATE LINE THAT
WAS NOT AFFECTED. ROUTE
DIVERSITY IS PART AND PARCEL OF
A RELIABLE RESILIENT NETWORK
PEOPLE AT LOCAL OFFICIALS HAVE
BEEN CALLING FOR THIS FOR A
LONG TIME WE BELIEVE THE
COMMISSION HAS THE AUTHORITY TO
ORDER THESE COMPANIES. TO
UTILIZE SUFFICIENT DIVERSE
ROUTING IT CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
MITIGATE OUTAGES OKAY. LASTING
WHAT YOU CAN DO A MINUTE OKAY
ONE MINUTE. S. DIVERSE ROUTING
ADDRESS BACKUP POWER UNDER
MARIA DRESS THAT WHAT SEVEN TEN
THE WHOLE IT'S SUNSET LET IT
STAY THAT WAY WHAT THE D.
COMPANIES CAN'T THROW THAT IN
THE FACE OF THE COMMISSION WHEN
THEY'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
ISSUES. FIVE THEY SAY WE'RE
DOING THIS MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE DOING IT IF THEY SAY
WE'RE INVESTING MAKE SURE
THEY'RE INVESTING AND LET THE
COMMISSION HAVE THE EXPERTISE
NECESSARY TO DO. THE FOLLOW AT
G. GO AND LOOK AT WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND VERIFY. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISS COSTA MISTER
MCCARTY. THANK YOU FOR LETTING
ME SPEAK TODAY. MY NAME IS
STEVE MCCARTY- ON THE OWNER OF
THE RESTAURANT UP AND
PLACERVILLE CALL PERFORM TABLE
AND I WAS ASKED TO SPEAK TO
DATE- AND NOT ABOUT. YOU KNOW
WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE WHAT THE
PROBLEMS OF COME TO BE BUT BUT
MORE ABOUT THE IMPACT OF THE
LACK TELECOMMUNICATIONS HAS ON
A OF LOCAL BUSINESS AND AMONG
THE OTHER BUSINESSES THAT THAT
I WORK AROUND IN THAT.
PARTICULAR AREA. REALLY WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS JUST TALK ABOUT
THE FACT THAT THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT IS HUGE- WHEN YOU LOOK
AT A COMPANY LIKE MINE. IS A
RELATIVELY SMALL RESTAURANT-
BUT WE HAVE- TWENTY EMPLOYEES
AND THAT. WITH OR WITHOUT
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
WITHOUT WHEN THE POWER WENT
OUT- IT OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE THE
GENERAL ISSUES OF REFRIGERATION
ELECTRICITY POWER THINGS LIKE
THAT. WE WERE FORTUNATE IN THAT
THE CITY HAD ARRANGED FOR AFTER
THE FIRST- POWER OUTAGE- TO
HAVE A GENERATOR. THAT PROVIDED
SOME POWER TO THE LOCAL
DOWNTOWN DISTRICT BUSINESSES.
AND I WAS FORTUNATE TO BE ON
HAPPEN TO BE ON ONE SIDE OF THE
STREET THAT ALLOW THAT POWER.
BUT WHAT REALLY IMPACTED US WAS
THE LACK OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS-
WE HAD A LOT OF CUSTOMERS
CALLING TRYING TO FIND OUT ARE
WE OPEN. WE HAD NO IDEA THEY
WERE CALLING BECAUSE OUR FOR
OUR PHONES WERE OUT. MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHEN WE TAKE
BUSINESS MOST BUSINESSES THAT
I'VE TALKED TO IN THE STREET
HAVE THE CAPABILITY OF STORING
CREDIT CARD DATA IN THERE-
POINT OF SALE SYSTEMS. BUT. YOU
CAN'T YOU CAN'T GET PAID UNLESS
YOU CAN TRANSMIT THAT DATA. TO
THE MERCHANT- PROCESSORS AND SO
YOU END UP HAVING FOR FIVE DAYS
WORTH OF CREDIT CARD
TRANSACTIONS SITTING IN YOUR
REGISTER- UNABLE TO GET PAID.
OBVIOUSLY THE- BILLS DON'T STOP
AND WHEN YOU HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY OF NOT HAVING THAT
INCOME IT'S SOMETHING THAT'S A
HUGE STRAIN ON ON MY BUSINESS
SOME OF THE OTHER BUSINESSES
THAT ARE IN THAT PARTICULAR
AREA- SO IT WAS IT SOMETHING
THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT. WE'D
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
AND HAND HOW TO DO IT- IT'S
JUST SOMETHING I WANNA MAKE
SURE YOU GUYS ARE AWARE OF THAT
THERE IS. AND I'M SURE YOU ARE
THAT THERE IS A HUGE ECONOMIC
IMPACT AND THESE ARE THE KIND
OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN FOR FROM
A BUSINESS STANDPOINT THAT A
LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE.ALSO THE FACT THAT SOME
EMPLOYEES HAVE. NO IN ABILITY
THEY DON'T HAVE A CELL PHONE
MAYBE- THEY CAN'T COMMUNICATE
WITH THE RESTAURANT THEY DON'T
KNOW IF WE'RE GONNA BE OPEN
THEY DON'T KNOW WHETHER TO
REPORT TO WORK- IF THEY REPORT
TO WORK AND THEN- I MAY HAVE TO
PAY THEM THE- TO BASICALLY DO
NOTHING- IF I'M OPEN- CUSTOMERS
ARE COMING AND THEY DON'T KNOW
WE'RE OPEN. SO MY BUSINESS
CLOSED DOWN SIGNIFICANTLY-
BECAUSE OF THAT. SO ALL THESE
THINGS ARE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
THINGS TO KNOW AND I CAN
APPRECIATE THE HEADACHE THAT IT
IS TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO.
GET A RUN AROUND ALL THESE
PROBLEMS BUT- I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S- IN
EVERYBODY'S FOR FRONT THAT THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THERE IS A
HUGE ECONOMIC IMPACT ON
BUSINESSES AND- HILL AND NEVER
WANT TO DOWNPLAY THE SAFETY AND
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL AND HAND
JUST BASIC COMMUNICATION NEEDS
BUT- OTHERS ALSO THAT
ADDITIONAL COST AND THE COST
FOR TO US. IS FAR GREATER THAN
JUST THE LOS. BIZ FOR THE DAY
OR WEEK OR WHATEVER. BOB. IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYBODY IS AWARE OF.
I THINK THAT'S IT. YOU'RE ALL
COMING IN HANGING IN FOR THE
LAST PANEL REALLY APPRECIATED.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
THAT NO I JUST WANT TO TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY NO QUESTIONS
BUT TO EVERYONE THAT THAT'S
BEEN HERE THIS ENTIRE TIME AND
OTHER PREVIOUS PANELISTS AND
YOURSELF THANK YOU FOR COMING
AND GOING AS REALLY APPRECIATED
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO- THAT
CONCLUDES THIS PANEL WE KNOW
WILL. ACCEPT PUBLIC COMMENTS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN.
AFTER MAN MISTER TERRY BRIEFLY
IGNACE YOUR HERNANDEZ A BEHALF
THE COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE
CALIFORNIA HAWAII NEVADA WITH
OF COURSE THOUSANDS OF WORKERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA- PARTICULAR
WITH EIGHTEEN TEAM AND OTHER
COMPANIES. WE'RE HERE I WANT TO
FIRST OF ALL THANK- ALL OF THE
MEMBERS WERE HERE THROUGHOUT
THE TESTIMONY- WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FRANKNESS OF FOR
A LOT OF THE DISCUSSION TODAY.
AND THE WILLINGNESS TO- IT
APPEARS ON BEHALF OF THE
LEGISLATORS TO DO SOMETHING
GOING FOR TO DO MORE WORK GOING
FORWARD- AS ONE OF THE-
WITNESSES. TESTIFIED THIS SOME
OF THESE ISSUES ARE NOT NOW
SOME OF THESE ISSUES WE HAVE
BEEN FIGHTING AND DISCUSSING
FOR NUMBER OF YEARS- SO WE DO
LOOK FORWARD TO A VERY ROBUST
AND AGGRESSIVE. APPROACH TO
THESE ISSUES- CW A DOES LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING AT THE TABLE
BOTH IN THE FORMAL AND INFORMAL
DISCUSSIONS. OR WORKERS ARE
OFTEN THE ONES THAT HAVE THE
DIRECT CONTACT WITH THE
CUSTOMERS THE CONSUMERS AND WE
FIND OUT WHAT'S GOING ON ON THE
GROUND WE CAN PROVIDE THE REAL
STORIES. WE CAN HEAR THAT IF
YOU'RE HEARING ONE THING THAT
THIS IS WHAT THE POLICY IS BUT
WE'RE HEARING ON THE GROUND
SOMETHING ELSE IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING OR NOT HAPPENING. WE
HAVE ABOUT THE STORIES WE WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THOSE
STORIES. ONE FOUR WE LOOK FOR.
LOOK FORWARD TO BEING PART OF
ALL OF THOSE DISCUSS. THE LAST
THING JUST WANT TO MENTION IS
HIGHLIGHTED EARLIER THE SUNSET
AT SEVEN TEN. SHOOT ME SECTION
SEVEN TEN ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
IT REALLY OPENS UP THE WORLD TO
DO A LOT MORE AND FOR THE
COMMISSION TO DO A LOT MORE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
PART OF THAT WE LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CREST OF ACTION AND SWIFT
ACTION- BUT THAT SUNSET NEEDS
TO REMAIN OTHERWISE IT'S GOING
TO REALLY REALLY HOLD BACK. ANY
EFFORTS- THAT WE HAVE GOING
FORWARD SO WITH THAT WANT TO
THANK YOU AGAIN SEE W. A. IS
POISED TO BE THERE TO WORK
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY TO
REALLY. FIND SOME REAL
SOLUTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
TRACY WRI WROTE COUNTY
REPRESENTS OF CALIFORNIA I WILL
BE VERY BRIEF- WE REPRESENT THE
THIRTY SEVEN COUNTIES- THAT
HISTORICALLY ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY. AFFECTED BY
THESE TYPES OF OUTAGES AND THAT
WAS EVEN BEFORE PS PS EVENTS-
IN FACT. LAST YEAR IN FEBRUARY-
BEAR VALLEY AREA WAS OUT OF
PHONE AND INTERNET SERVICE FOR
FIVE WEEKS. AND THAT WAS NOT A
P. S. P. S. ABOUT- THESE AREAS
ALSO ARE AREAS THAT SEE MORE
DISASTERS AND HAVE MORE OF A
NEED FOR A RELIABLE
TELECOMMUNICATION. AND SO WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION- WE THINK THAT- THE
P. YOU SEE IN THE N. O. YES IS
IN A GOOD PLACE TO ASK FOR THE
DATE I THINK WE NEED TO START
WITH THE DATA. BEFORE CRAFT THE
SOLUTION IT WE ARE SPUR OF
THOSE EFFORTS AND ALSO THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT BATTERY BACKUP
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK UNDER
PUBLIC COMMENTS. THAT CONCLUDES
OUR COMMITTEE MEETING THANK YOU
FOR ATTENDING AND. SURE IT AT
THE CHURCH WHERE HER YOU HAVE
SOME SAGE REMARKS BUT I DO NOT
SO THANK YOU FOR COMING